You wish you speak over the Ethan Klein situation. I don't think
you walk upright if you are in any way supportive of Hassan on
this issue. >> So Hassan does suck. Yes, Hassan sucks.
I'm sitting here like I just think it's probably bad that we
have a bunch of people online explicitly lying about Hassan.
So the idea that we're using the chat reaction to signal the
fact to signal the fact that he was calling for her death somehow
you're using the chat as an example. Doesn't matter. Doesn't
matter because it totally defeats this point. Yeah. They hate
Ela. couple of questions and I answered. Is Hassan a socialist
like he says or is Hassan a sock like he says? Which one? He
says he's both. Which one is it? You're talking about how it's
justified to nuke all every single person in the IDF. And let
me just let me just randomly sprint. >> No, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no. Hold on, hold on, hold on. People in the IDF.
No, no, no, no, no. He didn't say that.
>> Israel is in the wrong. Israel is actually engaging
in an apartheid, which is a crime in and of itself. Israel is
doing a genocide in Gaza and an aparttheid in the West Bank.
Two crimes in and of itself. And every
every type of armed resistance against both the settlers and
also the Israeli occupying force in the West Bank. Doesn't matter
if it's your favorite podcasters like uh wife that participate
in these raids. The violence that the pal So this is furthering.
Okay. It's continuing on from I don't care if you think these
people are good. If they are participating in this, they are
also valid targets.
>> What? What's up, Ry? How's it going? >> Went well,
young one. You wish to speak over the Ethan Klein situation.
>> Yeah. What's your What's your take? I think you I think
I just saw a tweet from you. It popped up on my phone, so I was
like, "Oh, I'll message Rally cuz decent chance we have a different
take on it." >> Yeah. So my take is that I don't believe
his intent was to call for Ela Klein to be considered a valid
military target, but I believe the consequence of his statements
are that people in his audience would view her as onetoone morally
with these valid military targets. Effectively
making it >> but only in one location, correct?
>> Only in one of two locations. Correct. >> What
do you mean in one of two >> The Gaza Strip or the West
Bank. That is the context under which this entire conversation
takes place. >> His statements. Yes. But I'm saying that
his the consequence of his speech puts Ela Klene in a similar
Miller uh moral place as these various people who are conducting
the actions in Gaza and the West Bank. >> Sorry, I don't
mean >> by bringing her up as a direct comparison and uh
a statement about how it's justified to there all of these people
are justified uh military targets. Sure.
>> Frankly, there is no connection. Really, there's no
connection between her at >> Perfect connection there.
Um, he's he's making So, I think there's a perfect connection
there. So, I would say he's trying to make the point that no
matter how legitimate the Israeli military looks, no matter how
like terroristic the Palestinian militias look, it doesn't matter
if Israel kind of looks like you and they look like a justified
military because they got uniforms and they they operate like
with more um like more transparently. Doesn't matter. They're
the illegally occupying force. they are doing like an apartheid
state. They are the people who are ethnically cleansing like
that same ethnic group from the region. No matter what that group
is invalid in this situation and anybody participating in that
group, any member of that group is a valid military target if
they are in the West Bank in illegally occupied territory. Right?
So he's saying no matter how good they >> why is Ela Klein
a valid
context. >> So she is the most innocent person who would
be participating in this. Right? She was like a secretary. She
just went one time. she's the most innocent version versus then
he talks about doesn't matter if they are terrorists, doesn't
matter if they're wearing like a hijab, doesn't matter what the
they're doing, right? Doesn't matter how scary they look, they
are still the morally correct actors here. So, he's taking the
most kind the the the >> No, he's talking about he's not
talking about they're the morally correct actors. He's referring
to yes, they're what they're doing is legal, but he's also stating
that these other groups are valid military targets. He's saying
that it is the moral thing to do is to get rid of these valid
militaries. He even I believe he even said the word moral maybe
earlier >> it's totally morally justified to to attack
to use violence against the occupying force. Yes.
and all of these people. And then he brings up Ela Klene in this
context. And I agree it's not to explicitly say that she is also
a valid military target, but it is to bring her up in a context
to put her in a similar light as these other valid military targets
by bringing up her past uh service by sitting inside of a car.
>> A car that was probably that she wasn't supposed to
be sitting in that was going into Raml at night had like fired
at it, right? from the unit that does all of the night raids
into Ramala >> or Yeah. sitting inside of a car doing literally
nothing. Do you think that that's a valid that makes her a valid
military target? >> No, I don't think it makes her a valid
military target. If somebody fired an RPG at that car, would
you think that was valid? >> Yeah, I would say so. Yeah,
probably. >> Well, actually, to be clear, I don't know
what exactly that raid was. I don't know what what exactly that
raid was, but um assuming that it was a like a raid that we would
typically see inside of the West Bank, I would say yeah. >> Yeah.
So he's saying any member of the IDF who's engaging in operations
in the West Bank in going to Ramla, right? Even going and he
specifically says he your favorite podcaster's wife because she
went on those raids, right?
Yeah. So but she's not currently nor does she currently support
those raids as per my >> Yeah. He's she wouldn't even be
but she's also not currently in the West Bank or the Gaza Strip
which is >> so why bring her up? She's not currently in
the West Bank. She's not currently engaged in rage. She doesn't
currently support the IDF. She doesn't currently support the
West Bank. No matter how little you participate, if you are a
member of that military, I think you're a valid target. Which
I disagree with. >> She's not in the military. She doesn't
support the military. She doesn't >> why he's not advocating
for violence against her. He's saying that is that is the most
innocent example I can think >> Why is he Why is he bringing
her up? She doesn't support the military innocent. She doesn't
support what they're doing in the West. >> The most innocent
example of somebody who would have been a valid target. Like
even this person, even this person would have been a valid target.
>> Well, no, we we already agree. Well, are you arguing
that he believes that she would have been a valid military target?
>> Yes. Yes, he's saying that explicitly. uh then then
yeah, I mean I would appeal to that being uh but even beyond
the idea of her that being
I would say that that her bringing her up and subsequently the
response that we see from his chat clearly illustrates that he
is putting them on a similar moral footing because what happened
immediately after he said this his chat had multiple different
messages calling her terrorist wife. >> I'm never ever
going to I'm never going to engage in the chat. The chat totally
[__] Anybody who is in the chat is in my opinion.
My point is the how his audience the whole point of being a content
creator in general. How his audience takes his messaging? I already
agree with you. His intent wasn't to say, "Hey,
do you think his audience hates a because of her connection to
Ethan Klein or because of Hassan?" Do you think they're Do you
think they're mirroring Hassan's opinion on Ela Klein?
>> they're not. They're obviously not. When has said when
does Hassan said
>> what if Hassan said those things? Are >> you serious?
Wait, are you are you saying that Hassan's representation of
Ela Klein is not that she's like a terrorist sympathizer?
>> I think she she's an
that Hassan's interpretation of Ela
She is not a pro- genocide
pro uh uh Gaza
uh baby killer. That is the representation from Hassan about
Ela Klein is that both Ela and Ethan are like pro- babykilling
genocidal maniacs. That is the interpretation. Yes. Yes. So >> that
scientist thinks anybody who's like
that would be like that. But no no those are not equal, right?
>> He doesn't he doesn't do those statements, right? >> How
is it not Can you Can you actually answer how is Elila Klene
not a terrorist by Hassan's own arguments? You can call her a
terrorist by his own
>> Right. So when you say these these comments inside that
>> do you believe the IDF engages in operations that are
on terrorism that argument any day that she's going to >> Would
you call the would you call the IDF would you call the fact that
like let's say you know they're actively engaging in an ethnic
cleansing campaign. Would you not call that like state terrorism?
Would you not call that like terroristic? Is are they not like
literally clearing these people out to cause terror and make
them flee from >> Sure. When was she in the IDF and what
was she doing and was it required? >> Uh, she was literally
the the assistant to the commander who did all of the night raids
into Raala.
>> Okay. And do you think when was you think the Israeli
government has engaged in like crazy in Ramla in the capital
of the West Bank? >> No, I I agree that they have engaged
in crazy. I'm saying that when you are state required to be able
to do something uh like like mandatory No, but she didn't. Did
she participate in any offensive capacity in the raid or did
she just sit inside of the car? >> No, but she that's Hassan
saying you don't need to commit to participate in you're having
a conversation with me as to whether or not it's reasonable to
call her a terrorist. And your argument is it is. Mine is that's
rhetorical. There is no argument for her being a >> Is
it reasonable to call the Houthy kid a terrorist?
>> Yeah, because he said he's a Houthy and he supports
the Houthies. >> Okay. So Ela Klein obviously didn't she
supports the annexing of the West Bank? >> I don't know
if we have her on tape saying she supports the annexing of the
West Bank, but she participated. She was >> Did she support
Did she support the annexing of Gaza?
>> Also, do we have more evidence that Elila Klein was
in the IDF or more evidence that the Houthi kid was in the
>> Uh I mean I mean I don't I mean we have perfect evidence
that both of them were a part of both. I don't think that's he
said he was like saying
hold on I'm gonna keep on more evidence that we were on kick
we both scream on both of us were objectively >> Klein
is a member of that so Ela beat >> obviously the kid was
a part of the Houthies he said he was a Houthie >> uh okay
I'm black so I can say the answer
hold on are you under the assumption that this guy lied when
he said he was a Houthi soldier >> I so I'm going to ask
the next question to you do you have any evidence that he engaged
in offensive operations for the Houthies He said he was a soldier.
No. In the Ethan video, >> he said, "Are you a soldier?"
And he said, "Yes." No.
>> Any evidence that he participates in any offensive operations?
>> Wait, he said yes. >> People are saying, "No,
he didn't."
>> Okay. Can I get a link to the >> Maybe we'll have
to go back through it. I thought I remember him explicitly say,
"Are you a Houthy like
or are you a soldier?" I think there was two different things.
Maybe I'm misremembering. And he said yes. He just said yes.
>> Okay. Um, I'm just saying what evidence we have offensive.
>> Either way, it it doesn't. And if you have the >> So,
you would say if he didn't engage in offensive operations, you
wouldn't call him a hoofy.
>> Let's Let's assume that the soldier thing can't be found.
Let's assume that's just absolute nonsense. Okay. Um, no. I Yeah,
I don't have evidence that he was a soldier, but I have evidence
to show that he actively supports the Houthies while they're
engaged in genocidal actions or not necessarily genocidal actions,
but like uh terrorist actions. Yes, I have evidence of that because
he's actively supporting them during terrorist actions. Do you
have any evidence to show Ela Klein is supporting like terrorist
behavior from the IDF? >> Terrorist behavior. I just know
she was like basically complicit in it. By the way, just so you
know, I don't think she's a valid military target, right? I disagree
on that. But the problem with me, the problem for me, just real
quick, I just need to tell you what my actual problem is with
this. The problem for me is that a bunch of like this Destiny
idiot in my chat have come out and said Hassan's explicitly calling
for Ela Klein's death, which is obviously not happening. They're
just lying because they hate Hassan. That's where I'm coming
from. So, I'm saying Hassan is a thousand times more tethered
to reality than any of the other people. And so, I'm gonna sit
here and keep talking about those other people. Not really. >> think
is more tied to reality on this? No, I could. Wait, wait, hold
on. Which one is the more reasonable opinion that everybody's
for thinking that he is saying that they're uh that Ela Klein
is a valid military target or that um other people the other
people saying is saying that is is a valid military target. I
think it is way more for
everyone who believes that I was saying El Klein was a valid
military target is stupid. I think that is a way more statement
than the statement that no No, no, no. Sorry. You're totally
misconring what I'm saying. Hold on. It's not about valid military
target. They're saying that he is directly calling for Ethan
Klein or sorry, Ela Klein's death. There are a bunch of people
who are actually going live right now.
There's just chill for two seconds. I just got to finish my point
really quickly. There's Asold. There's Te there's Destiny saying
that he should be for this. That you could argue Hassan should
be for this. Okay. >> Hassan is not direct.
>> If if I I I didn't see the full context of that. If
I see the full context of that, I imagine that I probably almost
no matter what would disagree with it. The only circumstance
I could see where that could make sense to me is if he's explicitly
talking about Eli Klene uh justifying some kind of violence against
Hassan for this and I could >> they're saying they're saying
that
Hassan was directly saying you can go to her house right now
and kill her. That's what said
they're arguing that arguing it's legal to murder in California.
is a more reasonable interpretation of his words than the interpretation
that you are if you think that's what he said. I to be clear
Hassan's position is more he said than what I believe there.
>> That's totally that's totally crazy. And I think the
only way you can believe that is if you have everything no you
have to have the whole context stripped out. Have you have you
watched the whole >> Actually I had a normie I had a a
literal unplugged person just real quick before you start before
you start the story. Can you just tell me if you watch the whole
context? So, did you go back to like when he's watching? >> Yeah,
I did. I watched what is it the I I watched it from the VA. I
watched about 3 minutes. >> Yeah. Yeah. Perfect. Perfect.
Perfect. >> Yeah, I watched about 3 minutes. I had a normie.
Okay. Somebody who's not plugged into politics listen to it and
they were like, "No, that sounds pretty bad." Yeah. No, that
sounds like they're saying they're a valid military target. Okay.
So, I heat checked this. Okay. So, this idea that it's just like,
"Oh, you're you have to be to interpret it this way." No, you
have to be charitable
for to to Hassan and his his platform that this don't forget
this isn't some dude off the side of the road. This is a person
who gets paid money to speak in front of an audience. We have
to hold him to a different standard and he misses that
standard in spades on this one. And that is the problem. I agree
that his intent certainly was not to do this. I don't know why
this would be the moment he decided to do. If this
>> what does he have to do other than repeatedly stating
that he's only talking about active military targets or sorry
active military and active like illegal settlers armed illegal
settlers in the West Bank. What more do you need him to say to
exclude Ela Klein right from being a valid target right now?
>> Don't bring her up because it's not relevant. That was
the the head of this this whole discussion. She isn't a part
of this argument. He hamfisted her into this argument. That is
the reason for this confusion. She doesn't support what they're
doing. As for my knowledge, somebody please please correct me
if I'm wrong. I, as for my knowledge, she doesn't support what's
going on in the West Bank. She doesn't support what's going on
uh with the annexing of all of Gaza. She doesn't support any
of these things. She was in the IDF a long time ago. It's not
like she was in the IDF yesterday and it was mandatory military
service. When she went on this raid, it she wasn't like actively
a part of it. She just sat inside of the car like these all of
these various things. Forced to go on the raid. Well, she she
she had to get hamfisted into that statement. Hamfisted into
a statement where he is currently talking about the valid uh
the validity of of targeting people in the IDF right now. That's
what he's talking about. And to hamfist somebody that was in
there decades ago, like what the are you doing? >> That's
a part of his secondary.
Everybody thinks that Israel is everybody thinks that Israel
is the moral actor here because they look like the real army
and the other people look like terrorists. He's saying no matter
what. Okay. No matter what here, when you have this these guys,
no matter how they look, they're still the good people here.
And no matter how nice and kind the IDF looks, even if it's your
favorite podcaster's wife when she goes on that raid, it doesn't
matter. They're the morally bad actor here. That's his >> You
are great. You are rephrasing something I already agree. I agree.
His intent wasn't to say that. That requires charity. If you
read the transcript of what he said, he is putting her in there
as like, yeah, you know what? She's right up here with all these
various different people. Let me use this example. He he like
if you if we read the transcript line for line, I think it is
you have to be charitable to him to imply that he isn't saying
that she is on that level a valid military target. You have to
be charitable. >> I just need to uh Yeah, sure. Sure. Sure.
I'm going to go ahead and
I've got so many notepad windows. Hold on. I need to get a notepad
on screen cuz we're just going to go through and we'll just write
down the statements as they happen, right? I think we can just
easily write down the statements as they happen and say which
ones apply to like as we're going through and talking about it.
But give me one second. I need to actually figure out how to
get like a notepad window in here that doesn't have my other
notepad windows. Give me a second. God, I miss arguing with people.
You're like the only person who will come on and argue about
this stuff. Thank you. >> Uh, sure. >> Okay. Give
me two seconds. I just need to get this pulled up. Okay. Hold
on. Okay. Oh, this should work, I think. What's up? >> I'm
looking at something else right now. All right, let me go I'll
go to my own clip here because I got the whole thing clipped
out for us. Okay, >> No, not that. That's my stream. Don't
go there right here. >> But it shows thinking >> like
any kind of violence that Israeli settlers
or the the Israeli military experiences in the West Bank is literally
legal. Okay. It is legal resistance against an occupying military
force. I cannot I cannot repeat this enough. Just >> Okay.
So, right from the beginning of this, any violence they they
undergo in the West Bank is legal and morally justified, right?
>> Okay.
Do you think that he says anything
here? Is it just the the reference to Ela means so to me that
already colors >> the manner in which he referenced? It's
the manner in which he referenced her. Do you agree that this
colors all of his other statements and he's making all other
statements within this context? We can argue he we can argue
whether or not he goes on a >> Yes, I agree. I think this
context doesn't make it better. I think it makes it worse because
my whole point is that he brings up a erroneous actor who has
no connection to the greater point that he's making in order
to be able to uh connection there. >> I think it was a
dick. >> No. So there's there's somebody who was just participating
on a podcast what two days ago that was calling him a right >> bro
what?
So they were they not on their podcast, did they not? What I'm
talking No, it's not a connection. No, the connection is obviously
the night. The connection is the connection is obviously the
night raid, but I'm saying there's no reason for him not to take
a [__] at this person, right? This person is a participating
because he's Wait, hold on. Let's say me and you have a conversation
about Israel Palestine. Is this just a moment to take a Let's
just say I don't know saying like uh uh Tucker Carlson was a
part of the night raids. No. What? What the what what connection
does he have? Oh, because he justified the night raids at this
specific time. Yeah. No, no, no, no. There's a time and there's
a place and in a specific context. No. In the context of talking
about valid military targets and whether or not it's justified
to target the settlers inside of the West Bank, which it is obviously
besides children, you know, and whether or not it's justified
to target the IDF in the West Bank, which it is, and whether
or not it's valid to target the IDF in Gaza, which it is, right?
to randomly bring up somebody who hasn't been in the IDF for
years, who doesn't support what's going on in Gaza. >> Sorry,
it's not random. It's not random. It's not random. He's obviously
bringing her up as a part of like talk, right? But I'm saying
it is
he's bringing up her up in the context of effectively a hit list
of morally justified actors. He's going through a list of people
who are morally justified to kill and then he's like, "Oh yeah,
now is a good time for me to bring up this other person who was
in the IDF in the past." Just so that way it can sh on them.
No. You're talking about how it's justified to nuke all every
single person in the IDF. And let me just let me just randomly
sprint. >> No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Hold on,
hold on, hold on. People in the IDF. No, no, no, no, no, no.
He didn't say that. Let's just I need you to admit that he's
saying IDF members engaging in military operations in the West
Bank.
>> wait are are you of the opinion that Hassan would deny
the claim that every single person >> Are you going to
ask me to mate Hassan when we're arguing about what this clip
>> No, we're not.
We're talking about him as a person. I my my statement is very
clear. Okay. In >> literally asking me to read bias into
this. Why would I read why you ask me to read bias into it? Why
can't we just be unbiased and say what he's saying? >> Stop.
Stop. Hey, wait. J, what is my claim? Run it back to me. What
is my claim? Your claim is that he brought this up for no reason.
He threw Hila in here when Hila is not currently an active military
target. He put her into the list of active military targets.
>> Why did he do that? >> Because he doesn't like
her. >> Okay. And what is the consequence of that? What
is my
whole point of my
>> In your in your argument, you would say that bringing
her up in the context of being a valid military target that people
would just only hear that and they would think, "Oh, I'm going
to >> No, no, no, no. I'm not saying that that will necessarily
happen. My my argument is very simple. in the context of Hassan's
coverage and how Hassan is uh speaking about this specific issue
and his his audience's opinion of Ela Klene, he has an unbelievable
unbelievably
reasonable interpretation that as a result of statements like
this putting her against the backdrop of active valid military
targets who are in the IDF and saying, "Hey, by the way, my co-host's
uh my ex-cohost's wife is a part of the IDF. Just putting that
out there when he knows everybody in his audience believes that
like she's a terrorist and she's a equivalent to a that they're
going to view her as on the same moral level as these other valid
military targets. Absolutely. He knows that. Now, is it going
into that intense? I don't think so. >> At worst, hold
on, just so we're clear. At worst, that could be she's an active
she she would be a valid military target if she was in Gaza or
the West Bank. That's the absolute worst you could read into
this. >> No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. I'm not saying
that his intention is to say that she is actively a valid military
target. I'm saying the consequence of his statements is saying
that she is on the same moral level as these valid military targets
as a result of her part her participation in the apartheid in
her as her participation in the genocide. That is what I am saying.
That is the consequence of these things. I think you have to
back that up. It's not relevant, which is 90% of my which is
the chat's response to him saying that. The chat's response to
him saying that is literally to just say terror wife terrorist
wife
stuff like that to go to go in on her. How is that not a clear
indication that they are experience that they don't like her
being similar to these people? >> Just to be clear, nobody
here likes Hila Klein. I'm not arguing with you that he likes
Klein that he doesn't engage in Klein. I'm not Everybody here
thinks Ela Klein is genocidal. Step that up. They are genocidal.
>> Genocidal and that she supports the state of Israel
existing and Israel will not exist without enforcing their
>> What is Hassan's opinion of people who are propagating
the genocide? What does he think should happen to them? >> They're
not fit to be dog catchers. They're not fit for any elected office.
>> Yeah. And then off of that, great. What does that they're
not fit? They're they should be excised from all of society.
And then when we're talking about in the context of this person's
backdrop against valid military targets, do you think that there's
a reasonable interpretation that oh yeah, some people might view
this person as a valid military target? >> No. Because
it obviously is downstream of this context >> and we're
and we're operating off of entirely different. I think if you
spend every waking moment of your ability to to on other people
saying that people like this don't deserve to be in civil society
and then when it comes time to talk about people who deserve
to be sorry not ought to be his argument was that it's morally
just >> by way the entire just to be clear you keep you
keep hyperbolizing this the argument is when you're engaging
when these people are engaging in offensive operations in the
West Bank or Gaza They are valid targets for violence. >> You
know, to be clear, he said it's they're it's morally good. They're
they ought to be He said it was morally good. It's a good thing.
>> Morally good for them to defend themselves. Yes. In
the West Bank and the Gaza Strip. >> Morally. So, it is
morally good for them to kill these people. So, that that's what
I was saying. It is morally engaged in offensive military operations
in the Gaza Strip or the West Bank. You're never going to not
be able to include that because it is is literally explicit or
implicit. >> The reason why it's not relevant. The the
reason why that's not relevant is because he's putting the backdrop
of somebody that has connection to it when the people inside
of his audience believe that this person is morally impunable
up to this day for that same action. So the problem is you have
a person who uh him and his audience have have been uh pushing
is a pro- genocidal maniac who is unfit for civil society. And
your clever idea is to take actual people that you're saying
are morally good to be killed and put that person in direct connection
with them with no actual argument. There's no merit to the argument
that he's making and I refuse.
Well, he's talking about the uniforms or he's talking about like
this passing. This is ridiculous. We never the whole >> He's
literally saying that the whole
he's not talking about the uniforms. He's he's making a like
level one take. He's making the whole thing. We can go over it.
He's making the level one take of yeah, bad things are happening
in the West Bank. Bad things are happening in Gaza and therefore
because the IDF and the settlers are doing it, they are valid
military targets, which is true. He's doing he's not doing any
analysis.
>> Do you disagree that he is also talking about why people
allow this? why people aren't more outraged about it in the context
of the people on side look like terrorists and the people on
the Israeli side look justified. >> Okay, we'll we'll just
listen. We'll keep listening. >> Just like let me pull
back so I make sure I don't miss anything. >> It is literally
legal. Okay, it is legal resistance against an occupying military
force. I cannot
I cannot repeat this enough. Just like any kind of violence,
any kind of authority >> violence that the Israeli occupying
force experiences in the Gaza Strip is actually once again totally
legal and totally moral resistance by the Palestinians doesn't
matter if they're the Alaka brigade. Do we disagree with any
of this yet? That any kind of violence that is the to against
illegal settlers or military
>> or the IDF I sorry oh sorry any kind of violence that
illegal settlers or military experience in the West Bank is legal
and then the same statement any kind of violence that the IDF
experiences in Gaza is totally legal and totally moral resistance.
Do we disagree with those two statements?
>> Say that within reason. Yeah. I mean, you could argue
like prisoner of war or something, but within like I'm not going
to get nitpicky,
>> Doesn't matter if they're a part of the Palestinian
Islamic jihad. Doesn't matter if they're DFLP, PFLP, or even
former fat militants. >> So, he's saying right there, do
you know what he's saying there? >> Doesn't doesn't matter
if they're former members of like various different uh uh like
resistance groups.
>> Now, why why would he make that differentiation?
Why would he say it doesn't matter if they're like former >> Because
there is a because he is arguing that any group any group of
people that participate in armed resistance is justified in doing
it. Very clear. It's very obvious. >> Yeah. Okay. Perfect.
Yeah. Exactly. >> Yep. Because any resistance is morally
justified. Okay. >> Okay. It is perfectly legal, perfectly
valid, and perfectly moral.
>> Okay. 100%. This is not >> moral resistance, by
the way, is what he's included in one of these. I am going to
give him resistance on each of these like this is to me it's
saying resistance from the occupation right in these territories
that they control you are allowed to resist >> not like
a black and this is not a gray >> no I don't I don't agree
with this his because his audience do you disagree that his audience
interprets resistance as including uh resistance against like
uh uh support for the Israeli state?
>> No. And that's totally history outside
talking only about the West Bank and the Gaza Strip in the context
of watching a a documentary on armed settlers and segregation
the West Bank. >> Hold on. I understand he is talking about
this. I understand that he is talking about this. What I'm stating
to you is that resistance amongst his audience is not exclusively
to do with inside of Gaza or the West Bank. That's what I'm stating
is that resistance is not exclusively set to that parameter that
they believe resisting the apartheid, resisting the genocide
is a global effort that must be undergone. >> Uh I I totally
agree that some portion of his audience believes that. Do you
think it's >> I think every single
>> say again. Do you think it's incumbent on Hassan to
say, "Actually, I don't mean that you could do anything to any
of these people cuz he is clearly arguing this." You think because
of his audience, because his audience believes this, he has to
go and actually say things that are like totally outside of his
perception.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely. If I'm having a conversation
about how resistance to the IDF, resistance to uh uh the state
of Israel or the the Israel's occupation and genocidal conduct
inside of Gaza, if I'm stating that these people who are who
are putting pressure onto these areas are valid military targets,
I need to specify if I was if I was in Hassan's shoes, I need
to specify that I'm talking explicitly and exclusively about
the individuals who are actively participating. No, I'm you've
already agreed with me that he is explicitly talking exclusively
about this. We've agreed on that. You're saying that people in
his audience will believe that >> on the on the deductive
merits, but if we're talking about the interpretation that like
his audience or the the people watching him can easily walk away
with. No, I I think this is an entirely separate idea. I can
be charitable to
of his speech. I am going to be charitable to this guy in this
moment, but that comes from charity. that does not come from
listening to what he says. >> So even though we both so
we both clearly agree that he is not labeling Ela Klein a valid
target here, >> right? We both said that since the beginning
I do not believe
I'm only saying that now I I agree with you. You said it from
the beginning. I'm just laying it out for people that you agree.
So, we only disagree on like what his I guess what his burden
is with regards to his audience to double down or triple down
or quadruple down on saying now this is only in the West Bank
or Gaza. This is only in the West Bank or Gaza. That's what we
disagree on. I think he's already made it clear and I Okay, go.
Sorry, I don't want to cut. A large part of my argument is going
to be predicated on the idea that he um he is obfiscating what
he is talking about by bringing up somebody who is not currently
in Israel, not currently in Gaza, not currently in the West Bank.
They're in California. They have no support for anybody in the
West Bank or sorry, any of Israel's um operations in the West
Bank to my knowledge. Somebody again, correct me if I'm wrong,
they have no support for the annexing of all of Gaza. Again,
somebody correct me if I'm wrong. I I truly if I'm wrong that
could change my entire perspective on this. Um but between those
two things he is bringing up somebody who has no connection to
the point he's making. The point he is making is that these are
monsters who are justifying and participating in this annexation
and then he brings up somebody who's neither participating nor
justifying what's going on in these areas >> and that could
only have entire chat on that person here. Sure. That would only
be true if he wasn't making his secondary point here, which is
why he brings up the former terrorists and says it doesn't matter
who's participating in resistance on the Palestinian side because
he's saying it doesn't matter how bad they are. Doesn't matter
what their reputation is. They could be the most morally black
actors in the world. If they're engaging in resistance within
the within the Gaza Strip or the West Bank, they are morally
good in that case. That is a morally good action. Even if they
are morally black people, even if they're evil. Okay, that's
what he's saying. That's what this point is making about the
terrorists. And so just
of even the most morally good, even the most innocent of people
participating in these operations on the IDF side. >> No,
I'm sorry. Listen, bro. I love you. I'm never going to get away
with that. I'm never No, no, no. You're telling me that the reason
why Hassan brought up Ela Klein is to say, well, even the most
morally good people like Ela Klene, if she participates in the
>> Okay. No, no, no. He believes she is a pro- genocidal
monster. He would never bring her up as an example of somebody
who's clean. >> Yeah. He thinks basically everybody who's
left of like the 99th percentile leftist in anybody who's right
of that in Israel is like a genocidal monster.
>> do you think that do you think Hassan thinks that Ela
Klein is, you know, better? If you were to put her in the population
of the Israelis, like how good would she be versus the rest of
the Israelis? Do you think he would think she's like a really
evil Israeli or a really good Israeli relatively? >> No.
I'm not sure what the this has to do with anything, but if I
had to guess, I'd say maybe um based on his rhetoric. Wait, based
on what he says or what he actually believes. >> Based
on what he says, cuz I can't mind reading this. >> Oh,
then yeah, she >> I don't know why you differentiate between
the two. It feels like
because she has a platform. She's the same but worse because
she has a platform.
>> Okay. I think I think Hassan believes that all of these
people like anybody who is not like actively protesting against
the government right now is genocidal, right? They're supporting
an apartheid state. They are literally ethnically cleansing and
starving to >> But he would consider somebody like Ila
Klein worse because she has a podcast where according to all
of his rhetoric, she is spewing pro- genocide rhetoric because
he's deranged. He has no idea of reality. He'd 100% say worse
than some random Israeli who just like goes to their 9 to5 who's
an account. >> I'm talking about like his read of her beliefs
like what she would be doing if she was in the IDF right now.
Whoops, I just skipped forward. [__] >> I'm
talking about her as a person. He views her as and more specifically
he speaks of her as if she's like a walking demon. That's the
way that he speaks of >> He's talking about people who
are getting like actively raided and actively like violence is
being done to them in the West Bank and the Gaza Strip. Ela Klene
was the secretary for the commander of raids into Ramla, right?
We both agree on that.
>> Uh I I'll take your word for it. I don't know what her
position was. I was I'll just literally watched the clip earlier,
but we literally watched the clip earlier. That is the connection.
>> We both agree that that is a reasonable connection,
right? To say that, hey, there's somebody I know who's like popular.
There's probably the the person people would most identify. >> That's
a reasonable connection. No, I don't I don't think so. No. Let's
say let's say that Sam Cedar was in the IDF. Do you think he
would have brought up Sam Cedar? Why do you think he brought
her up? >> Yes, I think he would have brought up Sam Cedar.
>> If Sam Cedar was if Sam Cedar If Sam Cedar was entering
the West Bank as a part of a military operation from the he would
be a validator. Yes. 100%. That's so easy. That's so [__]
easy. >> He would have brought up. >> Yes, we do
live in to totally different realities. If Sam Cedar was a part
of the IDF and he entered the West Bank as a part of a military
operation for the IDF, he would be a valid target of violence.
Absolutely. Yes. >> Oh, he
Thank you so much for disconnect. Maybe there's a disconnection
going on here. I'm not saying that when challenged and if you
can find anybody who could get in a room with this guy to challenge
him if he didn't immediately try and leave that room and call
you like a baby killer, right? If somebody could get into a room
and challenge him and say, "Hey, if Sam Cedar was in the IDF
with this, would he invoke
Sam Cedar?" No, no, no. What is the the motives for him invoking
Ela Klein? He would not have a similar motive because Sam Cedar
has gone because the motive was simultaneous making the point
and on her yes he's simultaneously making the point. >> So
you believe so let's say a reality let's just get this hard down
if Ela Klein in the reality did not ser the IDF and Sam Cedar
did you believe he would have brought up Sam Cedar in this
>> Yes
100%. Especially if Sam Cedar Sam Ced was in the exact position
Ela was. Hold on. If Sam Ced was in the exact position Ela was,
yes, 100%.
>> No, no, no. I'm sorry. Just Just so we're clear. No,
I have to I have to get a point out really quickly. Just to be
clear, what my belief is for his position is just this one thing.
Okay, I have to get this point out. I'm sorry. I have to get
this point out. What his position is is no matter who the person
is, if you are engaging in offensive operations into the Gaza
Strip or West Bank as a member of the IDF, you are a valid target
for violence no matter what. That is the point he is making here.
Absolutely. Yes. >> So it wouldn't matter if it was Sam
Cedar. It wouldn't matter if it was a [__] If it
was a [__] you could still Oh, hold on. Wait, what?
Oh, really muted. Okay. >> I I asked if you could say again.
I didn't hear your point.
>> Sorry. the uh so I think his point is in my opinion
his point is no matter who is engaging in offensive operations
on behalf of the IDF as a member of the IDF into the West Bank
or into the illegally occupied parts of the West Bank or the
illegally occupied parts of Gaza, those people are valid military
targets. Full stop. Valid targets for resistance for for violent
resistance.
That is what he's saying here. Doesn't matter who they are. Doesn't
matter how much they participate, which by the way I disagree
with. But it's not him calling for somebody to die. It's not
him for calling for violence and I don't even think it's reasonable
to say that you could interpret it as Ela Klein is a valid target
for violence in Bair right now. I disagreed to his audience.
But my my whole point is that um we live in diametrically opposed
realities. If you think all else equal,
if Ela Klein was not in the IDF and Sam Cedar was, he would have
brought him up in this context. Just be very It's not just the
IDF, right? Hold on. Hold on. You're misrepresenting my point
because it's not just the IDF. It's participating. It doesn't
matter. >> It's not relevant. It's not relevant. Okay.
It's not relevant to the point that I'm about to make. It's not
relevant to the point I'm about to make. >> It's misrepresenting
my point. I'm going to crack. >> Do you believe that there
was any attempt because this will just get to the heart of it.
Do you think he wanted to bash Ela Ela Klein by bringing her
up in this context or do you think he was just bringing her up
just as Okay. So, you do not agree that he would have brought
Sam Cedar up because why would he want to bash Sam Cedar? He
loves Sam >> because he got to do both here. >> So,
you think he would have brought up Sam Cedar to randomly bash
Sam Cedar? >> No, I don't think he would have tried to
bash Sam Cedar. I think he would have continued on with the with
the example and used that as an example to say no matter what
if you are participating in illegal raids into the West Bank
you're a valid target for resistance for for violent resistance.
>> So he would have just randomly bashed Sam Cedar for
no reason. >> I don't think it's bashing. I think Sam Cedar
would agree with that. >> I don't think it's bashing. >> You
guys don't understand. You guys actually just don't understand
their worldview at all. Sam Cedar would literally agree with
that point. >> That's insane. That's where
That's insane. That's insane. You need to answer this question
right now. You think Sam Cedar would disagree with what I just
said, that if he entered the West Bank as a part of an illegal
raid that he would be a a valid target for violence. You think
Sam Cedar would disagree with that? >> No, that's not that's
not what I'm saying. What I'm saying is very simple in this context.
The manner in which he brings up Ela Klein is very obviously
to bash her. And you already agreed with that. The reason the
manner in which he brought her up the reason why he brought her
up was to [__] on her and compares her to who actively
deserve to be. >> There's a relevant connection and he
on her both at the same time. >> No, there is no good connection.
The connection is dog. There is no good
>> There's a great connection. She literally went on the
illegal raids. Sorry, I say illegal. Technically know
she went on night into the >> That's not relevant in the
cont. How is it relevant? Let let me just very simply how is
it relevant for in the context of people who are currently
currently
because that's the context people who are currently engaged in
military action in the West Bank and Gaza are valid military
targets. How was it relevant to bring up somebody who not only
is no longer um engaged in military action in the West Bank or
in Gaza or they're not not only that they're not in Gaza, they're
not in Israel, they're not even in the continent, nor do they
support what's going on in the West Bank, nor do they have to
add more qualifiers. I can literally tell you right off the top
of >> No, no, no. Because the reason why those qualifiers
matter if she was still in Israel in the IDF and like that, I
could be far more understanding. >> She's saying a bunch
of things. So I can just tell you my point is all the rest of
this is like >> yeah go ahead. I mean those bunch of things
are very very relevant to my >> the whole point he's going
to saying no matter how bad the actors are on the Palestinian
side, they're still justified. No matter how good the actors
are on the IDF, no matter how much you think you should trust
them because they look like moral actors, they look like a real
military. They look like they're the good guys. No matter how
much that is the case,
they're still bad. They're still it's still morally good for
those really evil looking guys to attack. Only >> the only
part where I get that is where he says at the end like their
clothing talks about the clothing of the uh the terrorists. That's
it. >> So you he talks about the clothing of the Israeli
>> 90% of the clip is literally
like firstation
for why
valid military targets. >> Yeah. But he talks about how
the Israeli military looks, right? Even if they look like the
good guys. >> That's not about their uniforms. >> Okay.
What does he mean when he says they look like the good guys?
He's referring to like their structure in comparison to uh like
their structured uh military. They have good PR, but their reputation,
their reputation, >> They have good relations with America.
Their their reputation, right? >> So, the reputation. >> You're
sure. >> Yeah. So, I'm saying the terrorist reputation,
too. That's why he's saying the terrorist by the reputation.
Before he talks about how they look, he talks about the reputation.
He's saying no matter what Palestinian is doing it, that resistance
is morally justified. But we can keep we can keep watching as
>> Yeah, but that's not that's not relevant to that's that's
not a connection to a
has no connection. >> Connection to Ela.
>> It is a connection to Ela because engaged in these exact
operations that he is criticizing that are happening in this
video. >> So he's matter your favorite podcast. Doesn't
even matter. Your favorite >> He's randomly bringing up
somebody who has no current connection to the conflict. doesn't
agree with the conflict. She has no has a current connection
to the conflict and a current connection to him. >> No,
no connection to the conflict in a in a manner that would be
relevant >> in a material sense. Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure.
Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure. Like she's not officially conflict. He's
just bringing her up. What? Because she
>> what? just because
>> because he doesn't like actual
and to me he's saying it doesn't matter which person who participated
in these raids who participates in this violence doesn't matter
which person it is no matter how good they might be no matter
how no matter what they're still in the >> he doesn't believe
they're good his audience doesn't believe they're good
>> well he's literally saying no matter so your favorite
podcasters's wife
>> I think he's explicitly laying that out for people who
aren't in his audience if you tell >> he's saying he's
bringing her up as an example of a good person a good person
who could be a valid military target because the average person
who's reading
he doesn't believe that she is a good >> She like I feel
like you're playing like 90 chess to justify where he just wanted
to take a jab at this chick by comparing her to active valid
military targets
>> Why did he why would he even bring up the night raids?
Why would he bring why would he bring up the night raids at >> To
sh on her. >> Are are night raids connected to what he's
talking about right now? >> Yeah, they are.
>> Okay. Did Ela go on night raids? >> Uh, I'm assuming
the one raid was at night. Yeah. >> Yeah. So, there's the
connection. And he is saying it's a heating up went on night
raid too. >> Engaged in violence. That's what he's talking
about. >> I'm I'm telling you that it is both a relevant
point. It is a point where it like makes sense where you could
bring this person up and because he's a spiteful [__]
he's doing it.
>> No, it's it's not a relevant point. It's not relevant
at all because she doesn't support the conflict in the manner
that he's criticizing it and he doesn't uh she she's not even
in the region. It's not relevant. >> She doesn't have to
be in the region. He literally says it was in the past. He literally
says it in the past tense. >> Yeah, I understand. He said
my point is that bringing up a past tense situation isn't relevant.
It's not relevant to this conversation. He's very obviously relevant
to his conversation. He can get a dick at her. He literally participated
in the exact thing you're criticizing and it's funny for him
to bring that up to his chat cuz that person her husband's basically
calling me a right >> What? Like what? I'm not sure what
any of this has to do with the argument >> that he's talking
to Ela Klein because of them consistently talking about him,
right? Making multiple podcast. >> I have no issue with
him talking. What I have an issue with is him uh making a statement
that very obviously implies to his audience that she's of a similar
moral caliber to people who could be >> okay but they can
only be actively when they're engaging in a certain context.
>> Where does he say that? Where does he say that? Because
in a cont
totally agree
they can only be active when they're engaged statement. He's
talking about people who are actively engaged in military actions.
And then he brings up somebody who is not engaged in any military
action, who condemns the military action and is in a different
on a different hemisphere, bro. And you're just Oh, yeah. No.
What? No. The argument breaks down. I agree. It doesn't break
down. It doesn't break down. It's all within this context. >> Milary
action. Yeah. Yeah. You know, stuff like this. Yes. Anybody engage
in the current military action. And then he randomly brings up
somebody that is not engaged in the current military action.
If you want to do that, what he would say was he would have to
say >> confirm both before and after that it is only people
who are actively engaged. >> did you Hold on. Did you just
say someone who's never engaged in any military action? >> She
has engaged in a military action. >> No, let me get my
let me get my point on. You're you're you're talk we're talking
about uh uh him having a discussion about current contextual
military action. That's what that's what this conversation is
about is about anybody who is engaged in this military action
is
this is why I'm saying there is a secondary point here that's
absolutely happening whether or not you guys want to accept this
or not that where he is also talking about how this has been
acceptable for so long and it has to do with how the Israeli
argument Israeli army is organized and how the Palestinians are
like a ragtag group of terrorists it absolutely has to do with
that context that's why he brings up that it doesn't matter if
they're the litally former terrorists Um, >> oh, sure.
Sure. >> Like you could say that's a part of the argument
is is that context. You could say that's a part of the argument.
I do not believe he sufficiently and I would say it's self-evident
by his chat um and how his community took it. There is not sufficient
context.
>> I'm going to reject on its face that you can base somebody's
opinion on how a chat talks about them, okay? Or talks about
what their opinion was. We've rejected this so many times in
the past for so many different streamers. Our disagreement isn't
about his opinion. I I don't believe that his intent was to call
for her death. That's not my opinion. I don't believe that's
his intent his intent. My argument is that his his audience is
going to say after that point, Ela Klene is of a similar moral
caliber to the people who are actively engaged in Gaza and in
the West Bank. And it seems as though his audience agrees with
my interpretation of how they would probably take it. >> Okay.
I'm not dis I'm not even making his audience receives it. Right.
>> I don't care about I don't give a [__] about
how his audience receives it. >> I literally don't care
about the conversation. Can you tell me what every single person's
criticism is? Every single person's criticism. >> They're
saying that he is saying it's legal to kill people in California
in terms of viewership. They're saying it's legal to kill Hilocline
in the state of California. that that's what Asthma Gold and
Teto both said this was arguing. >> The problem is isn't
whether or not
is or going to
think it's justified to do it. Do you think Asmin thinks Hassan
is going to take like a block and go to Ela Klein's >> No.
No. Literally said you should report this guy to the FBI. You
should report this guy to the FBI because he's just said it's
legal to kill Ela Klein right now. That's what he said. >> Yes.
Nobody. Do you think that Do you think Asmin thinks that Hassan
himself is going to take a gun and do that? Do you think that's
what he meant when he said that? >> No, he's just calling
out into the
>> But But hold on, hold on. He's saying Hassan himself
said that. Yes, he is saying himself said that. Just be clear.
He's saying himself said that.
Do we have to go watch it so we can figure out what is saying?
Cuz 100% saying it's illegal
to kill. Very simple English. I'm going to put this out in very
simple English and we're going to see if we agree or disagree
on this. Um, the issue that people have with Hassan's statement
is that people will interpret it as justification to say Ela
Klein is a valid target for No. >> Yes, it is. That is
just true. >> No.
Asmin Gold literally says outright this is legal direct calls
to this is direct calls to violence. He's saying it's legal and
morally good to go right >> To who? J. To who? To who is
it cause the violence to? To who? The audience. The audience.
>> Everyone. But it's about what Hassan's saying. That's
what he's criticizing. >> Yes, he is saying stuff that
is reasonably interpretable as saying
It's not in any way. We both we both agreed. So you are arguing
that could say, "Oh, well uh Ela Klein bad so we can kill a And
you agree? Yes. When you cultivate a [__]
we apparently we apparently just vow to what the audience thinks.
Now the audience makes jokes, right? Every every every streamer,
every streamer, every content creator is beholden to their audience.
If their audience thinks something, if you can create the perception
that their audience thinks something, then you get to go punish
them for it. Makes sense, I guess. >> Yes. If you form
a hey, if you form a audience and then you say something to them
that could be interpreted as go smack this chick. Yes, you're
responsible. Yes, that >> I don't think it can be reasonably
interpreted this way. Okay, so what is what is what is Dan saying?
Hold on. What is Dan saying? Let's see what Dan saying. Here's
the high quality edit of Hassan wishing for Ela's death. By the
way, do you think that framing is
>> This is Dan. There is a high quality edit of Hassan
wishing for Ela's death. No, I don't I don't agree that Hassan
is wishing for their death. >> Okay, so that's what people
are saying.
>> is it is it saying is this saying that uh Hassan's audience
sees his totally not calling for Ela's death as him calling for
the death or is Dan saying here that directly calling for the
>> That isn't this that isn't people's worry. People's
worry I agree that people think that this is a direct one to
one go snipe this person. I don't agree with that. my argument,
which is what they're scared of. They're not worried about the
words. The problem is you're saying, "Oh, because Assange said
this, nobody would care." Guess what? I promise you, Dan Saltman
would not care if Assan said this in the shower. He would not
give a Okay. The reason why anybody is worried about this is
cuz he said it live in front of people who could interpret their
words as a death wish. Nobody else.
That is the reason why they're worried. this opinion on like
level of audience culpability like creator audience >> that
is such man what are you talking
>> that your chat goes and says
in the chat and now that's proof that Hassan is calling for her
death or that people think he's calling for her death >> because
they say the same thing they say whenever Ela Klein's brought
up in any context I guarantee we go find anytime Ela Klein's
brought up in any context do you think they spam the same words
or >> what do you say is what >> when he brings up
Ela Klein in any context do Do you think they spam the same thing?
Baby Klein, genocidal Ela. Do you think they spam all those same
words or not >> over a period of time? Yeah. It didn't
start that way, but he cultivated the audience to believe that
she was like a pro genocide. >> You don't think there's
any culpability for Ethan and his audience constantly building
up this cycle? You don't think there's any culpability on both
sides at >> Uh there's maybe a little bit. If you ask my
honest opinion, I 100% am team Ethan. I think it is. I think
the idea that any I don't think you walk upright if you are in
any way supportive of Assan on this issue. >> So that the
way the chat reacted would have happened no matter what
if he mentioned Ela in any context. So the idea that we're using
the chat reaction to signal the fact to signal the fact that
he was calling for her death somehow. You're using the chat as
an example doesn't matter. Doesn't matter because it totally
defeats this point. Yeah. They hate
>> that doesn't mean you try to kill her. >> What
do you think? like we agree, right? Just because they hate Ela
and they talk [__] about her does not mean they want
to speech like this has on them. Do you think that they're going
to believe have a higher or lower opinion of her as a result
of speech like this? >> Lower opinion. Sure. >> Okay.
Yeah, they will. So, I don't I don't know why you're using this
as an argument. Well, >> does that mean that he was calling
for her death as harming their opinion
for like now explain to me what a year? explain to me why him
lowering her their opinion of her slightly is him is is because
of him calling for their perception that he's calling for their
death. The >> whole point of this is it's not slight. The
whole point of this is that it's not a slight reduction. This
is >> I'm against
you. >> Go find clips of this, but I'm arguing that anytime
he brings Ela up, you get the same chat reaction. The >> the
problem the issue isn't >> you agree with this you're talking
you agree with that, right? Yes or no? Do you agree with that?
Do you agree with that that the chat would say that? >> Yeah.
I mean, not in every single context, but in most context. Sure.
The point the issue isn't so the >> No, I actually have
to I have to do one more thing here just really quickly,
>> The answer, bro. I already answered. >> I know,
but there's really it's really important. You told me the main
reason you knew that they think he's calling for her death is
because of their chat reaction. You just told me that they
intentionally or you doing this on accident? I honestly can't
tell. I'm not saying the reason why they are calling for the
reason we know that he's calling for her death is because of
that reaction. I never said that. In fact, I said the opposite.
What I'm saying is that it is clear that they are honing in on
her as a morally egregious actor by spamming that when she is
brought up. That is my point. It's not that they're ingesting
it as like, oh, this is just an example to be able to make like
a greater point that he's trying to make. It's that they're explicitly
using this as ammo to further go harder against her against the
backdrop of a list of people he thinks it's morally justified
to kill. That's my point. And I think it is very reasonably interpretable
that he is saying that they're on the same level and and especially
because it sounds like we had a principal disagreement here which
is really really different and really really weird to me which
is if you form a audience who are hair triggered to violent action
and especially in a context of a time where in which violent
action against this group that is labeled pro- genocide is not
uncommon. He brings up somebody who is not engaged in any military
action, who condemns the military action. >> Jesus Christ.
Hello. Holy [__] I had to close so many tabs to figure
out what was going on. Holy sh I think I just lost a whole bunch
of what you were saying. I had like some tab just started autoplaying
music when I sat down for some reason. Jesus Christ.
Holy sh. So I again What violent action has anyone in Hassan's
audience taken?
>> You said you said a group that's on a trigger for violent
action. I'll grant that maybe I misspoke, but I can't tell if
you're just not listening to me. It's that the group that what
I said was is that against a group of people who have had consistent
uh uh violent action against them, which is the people who are
labeled as pro- genocide.
>> Do you disagree that there has been violent action against
people who have been labeled as pro- genocide? You can't. You
literally can't. >> I so nebulous like almost certainly.
But why would why would we use that massive why would Hold on.
Why would we use that massive a grouping?
>> That just seems like you're trying to web people together
for no reason. >> He is labeling these people as pro genocide
when people are getting >> that for this opinion and they're
not even prot.
>> What are you the who went to the Israelis who went to
the diplomats who are actually an active part? people from the
embassy who went to the thing. >> Okay. So actual Israeli
government
>> Okay. You don't think you don't think that had anything
to do with them being Israeli government? >> Is that an
okay thing? Why are you saying that? Like it's like >> Okay.
Just so we're clear. No. No. Let me let me explain. Let me cook
for two seconds to explain. I'm saying that you are trying to
connect those things and I have no evidence that it's because
they were talked about on the internet as progenocide or something.
I have no evidence of that. I have every piece of evidence in
the world to know that they were to think that they were targeted
as diplomats of Israel, actual government officials. But you
are trying to broaden what the actual connection is and say anybody
who's labeled pro genocide. Guess what? There are some people
who are progenocide and those people should be criticized. And
I'm not going to not criticize them cuz some schizophrenic went
and attacked Israeli embassy members. That's insane. >> Nobody's
talking about criticism. We're talking about the manner in which
you criticize people in a highly politicized time. If you if
you don't want to use that example, which I disagree on the merits
with that like, oh yeah, they were part of the Israeli and they
could have been anti- genocide. They literally could have been
pro Palestine. Like just the argument that they worked the building
is not an argument. That's I don't valid argument
that's how they were found. But even still, you could you could
look at other instancing
or whatever that happened. >> Just to be clear, you understand
I'm not justifying that, right?
>> You understand I'm not justifying that, right? I'm telling
you that the reason they were found the reason they were targeted
was because they were Israeli diplomats. Do you disagree that
he went to a function for Israeli diplomats? Do you disagree
that the guy went to a function for diplomats? >> Yeah.
Yes. It was a is it was I'm not sure if it was an I thought I
thought it was just a history like a historical thing at a Israeli
or a museum. >> It was young diplomats or young Israeli
>> Oh, okay. Well, yeah. Something like Yeah, sure. >> Sure.
So, it wasn't like their genocidal beliefs. It wasn't saying,
"Hey, these people are genocidal." It was their connection to
Israel, right? It was their connection to a thing. You went to
true frenzy. We don't believe that's >> We We don't know
those people. I mean, what wasn't like I I'm not sure if it was
ever confirmed, wasn't it? Like that that in that meeting they
were talking about like aid and stuff like that, how to get aid
to Gaza.
I so I believe the the woman who got I think worked with some
some agencies, but honestly uh we did a little deep dive into
those agencies. They don't seem very compelling to me. >> Okay.
So the the point
that I'm trying to make these people
violence is it regardless of this they were targeted for a for
by proximity to the Israeli administration. I find no evidence
that he did a deep dive into all of these people's these specific
people's political affiliations
um or anything like that. He just people because he believed
that they were sufficiently connected to the Israeli >> Yes.
Yep. That's what he did. So why so so now that
are people who are being for their connection to the Israeli
government? >> Yes. So how does that map on to Ethan >> That
maps on because you have a clear you have a clear motive. Just
to be clear, domestic. >> You said pro genocide, right?
Your your point was it was a progenocide narrative. If you call
these people progenocide, that's going to get them killed. That's
what you were saying. Now you're saying it's a connection to
these said calling them genocide will get them killed. I said
environment where being called pro genocide can get you killed,
which is absolutely the case because these people these people
weren't just targeted just because they were in the Israeli government.
They were targeted because the is they believe the Israeli government
is pro genocide. That's the reason why the connection is that
they all believe that you're sufficiently pro- genocide if you
support uh uh >> If you are willing to be a functionary
of the government of Israel.
>> They believe you're sufficiently pro genocide if you're
if you're willing to be a functionary of the government of Israel.
Like a diplomat for the >> No. Where was it stated that
it was explicitly that it had that was the the
uh the only reason that they were targeted was because they worked
at that
>> reason. I do think the genocide thing is downstream,
but I think the connection
progenocide or pro you think do you genuinely think if that person
knew knew for a fact that those people were working in the Israeli
embassy in an antagonistic fashion towards the Israeli colonial
project or whatever the want to call it. Do you think he would
have targeted them?
>> Okay. So, you agree with me. It is a pro- genocide thing
and he just assumed that because they worked there they were
pro genocide. >> The direct just so we're clear the direct
connection you work for this country that is committing a genocide
that is actually doing ethnic cleansing. I don't believe the
genocide part but no the that was used as evidence for the real
target which was the pro genocide. That's my point. It's not
because
it's because it was enough of a signal to this guy that they
were pro genocide that they would do it. So my argument is >> you
have to materally support the promote genocide, right? You are
materally supporting them by working for them, right? >> No,
you don't know that. He doesn't know that. He is assuming. >> He
doesn't. He doesn't know that. He is assuming. But I'm telling
you that working for the Israeli government, helping the Israeli
government work is probably to most people a bigger connection
than just being like, "Yeah, I support Israel." Right. >> Yeah.
And do you Yeah. And do you think do you think that
uh >> by the way the guy >> do you think that people
in Assan's audience believe that people like Ethan and Ela Klene
are aiding the Israeli government through let's just say PR?
Yes or no? >> Uh possibly. But it's like a >> the
answer is absolutely yes. He said as much. I believe he has said
as much >> I believe everybody in his audience.
So, uh, this is getting dicey cuz I still I don't think political
violence is ever the answer. But I don't think that people who
are media personalities have ever been laid out as targets by
the people in that sphere. Unless you want to count bad empanada,
>> but I I'm telling you, did a video explicitly said,
"I'm calling for violence." And who did he name? >> Well,
sure. But yeah, of course I would include bad empanada. He's
on there. They signal boost him all the time. He's like their
pal, their friend. >> Wait, who did Noah Samson name? Because
I could have talked about weapons
>> Sorry, I'm talking about no Samson because he did a
video where he explicitly called for violence. He did what? Arms
dealers in the US. He did uh like their factories infrastructure,
right? Yes. >> Yeah. Politics
calls for violence. >> Yeah. He did explicit calls for
>> So loner loner box >> and that's like a guy who's
actually going out and calling for violence and he is not he's
not going after like media personalities who support Israel.
>> What do you mean? In that video, he was talking about
media personalities that supported Israel. No, >> sure,
but I don't believe he laid them out as a target for violence,
right? >> I wasn't that the whole point is that his argument
was that they would be included as well, that the whole apparatus
would be included. >> I need to go find the clip then.
Uh cuz No, I thought I thought I remember laid it out and he
laid it out very >> weapons dealers and their and the infrastructure
used to provide weapons to Israel. I thought those were the people
that he explicitly called for violence against. I thought there
was also another I thought it was like maybe like politicians
and that it was but the the argument for the basis of the weapons
dealers was wasn't just material support uh and and the politician
wasn't just material support it was also like
paying
uh uh support beyond it like uh
what you call it uh I wouldn't say PR but it was like uh political
support but either either way nonetheless uh because I I'm not
going to just hold everything up just cuz over clip. Let's just
say that it was exclusively over like military infrastructure
and stuff like that. In a time like this where there are direct
calls to violence, you have to as a content creator be more careful
with you your speech. You have to be like you you are always
going to have to be uh based on this. There has been a >> I
don't think
I think Hassan has been like failed I think he's failed to be
careful in the past and I've called him out for that. To me,
the Tom Cotton one's the most obvious one where he's just clearly
saying, "We should kill this guy." Right? He's clearly doing
that in that Tom Cotton tweet. I don't think he's quite gotten
as bad in most other cases. This is not one of those cases. This
is a case where people are blowing this up. There's a reason
why it took four or five days for this to come out, by the way,
as well. Is it's obvious when you look at the context of the
clip that this is not true, right? That he is not calling for
Ela Klein's death. But it comes out four or five days later,
4 days later. >> You're being charitable to him.
No, I don't think it doesn't require any charity. It requires
a blank slate reading of it. You have to be uncharitable to him.
>> I said I literally showed this to somebody who has no
political like anything. They're just a normie and they were
like, "Yeah, that sounds like they're putting Ela Klein on the
same level as all these other people." >> Her her former
actions. Sure.
>> No, I I'm telling you what I spoke to another homo sapien
about. I'm relaying to you what another human >> homo sapiion
just to be clear. Did that homo sapien think that Hassan was
calling for Ela Klein to be killed? >> Oh yeah, they Well,
no, no, no. To be clear, they I mean, yeah, they said I I'll
give you their exact words as I remember them. It sounds like
what they're saying is that Ela Klene is the same as these people
inside of
uh Gaza and the West Bank. >> Okay, that's not what I asked.
I said does he think did the person think that they were calling
for
right because in the context of the claim >> the only way
it's defensive violence right there's an a group like literally
transgressing on you
any kind of terminally online brain said that's this is all I'm
doing and and the implication of that hey that they're the same
as this other group is like yeah it sounds like they're saying
>> permanently online I don't even I'm just watching the
clip and like I've I've litally written up the state terminally
online and we have biases about this. >> I mean, you could
call it terminally online or you could say people with a political
understanding
>> who who know the situation. If you have no context for
Israel Palestine, if you have no context for Israel Palestine,
you could easily misunderstand this. You might think, by the
way, this has happened to everybody when he says, "Oh, former
FATA members, former Fatah militants, right? There's Asmin Gold
and Teone both thought that that meant former IDF soldiers."
like fatal was like a division of the IDF or something. So if
you don't have any contract
an argument about them not knowing a >> but I'm telling
you that many people interpret it that way. >> That's not
an argument. That's not my argument. And if anything that would
pertain closer to your friend know people are not going to understand
this and are going to jump to conclusions. >> Does your
friend know is Israel
>> Not really. No. >> Okay. Does he know what you
were talk does he know like what Hassan was saying at all? Like
does he have any context for this at all? I'm not talking about
being terminally online. I'm talking about literally just >> they
watch the clip. >> Yeah, but do they have the context for
the clip?
>> like do they know about I feel like you can't even interpret
this clip. I've watched so many people fail to interpret this
clip because they don't know anything about Israel Palestine.
Did you tell them that that doesn't mean like former military
members? >> Yes. I answered all of their questions about
the various groups that they
>> Okay. Did they ask about Fatah? They ask what that was.
>> Oh, they it wasn't relevant. They they knew that they
were referring to whatever. You could tell by the in context.
Like I I I think you kind of just have to not be super bright
or maybe motivated to think that that was referring to a different
>> No, no, no, no. For the clip that I'm talking about,
for the clip I'm talking about, there's definitely um it's cut
so that it sounds like that. But if you're right, I think if
you go back and watch the whole thing, um it does actually lay
out that those would be Palestinian militant groups, militia
groups. Okay. Anyway, uh do we want to keep watching through
this? Oh, by the way, I'm saying I'm saying that I think people
need some actual some actual evidence that their violence would
help. And I think there's just so many people who are pro-Israel
that targeting people based on the pro-Israel belief or even
like a pro Israel, I support Israel in their genocide belief
wouldn't be enough. They're looking for people who have tangible
like who provide tangible material support and not just in some
uh some like voice type way. I I believe that is literally like
a part of the guy's argument in the manifesto, the manifesto,
right? Is they need to be tangibly a part of it. >> Okay.
I mean, do I we don't have any evidence to show that he knew
that they were tangibly a part of it? No. >> Um, he was
following the the groups or whatever, like some of these people.
I believe he's was he following the guy or was he just following
the heritage center? I can't remember now. We're trying to trace
like how this came out. I don't know why we haven't found any
of
>> At the end of the day, my argument comes down to
Destiny into this weird debate, bro. Logic. It's actually [__]
sad. Uh, okay. 09 Ghost, hop in the gourd.
So at the end of the day, my argument is pretty simple. um saying
this specific thing even in context to his audience who is specifically
weaponized to believe that this woman is pro- genocide is very
dangerous because in the especially in the context of the time
that we live in it makes them uh far more likely his audience
that is far more likely to in want to or think it's justified
to engage in uh physical action against this person. Sorry, say
that whole thing again. I'm sorry. I I was not paying attention
for a second. >> It it is it is wrong because given the
context of how frankly Hansa audiences,
um saying something like this has a very reasonable interpretation
of lowering their opinion of this person to a point where in
which somebody might feel justified in taking action uh physical
action against this person. Uh, one, I would argue that this
did not lower their opinion of Ela Klein. One iota. Okay. Everybody
knew that she went on that night raid. That is a constant talking
point for everybody in this sphere. Did not lower their opinion
of him. One iota. Okay. Two, uh, we have no evidence. So, you
keep saying he's got a audience. We have no evidence of somebody
in his audience like going and killing somebody because they
support
>> But we have evidence of people in his audience sending
him skulls. We have evidence of people in his audience. >> Where?
Go ahead. Show me the evidence in his audience. Do you believe
bad empanada sent the skulls? >> Oh, sorry. To be fair,
excuse me. I should have said justifying it. That is fair enough.
Justifying it. I consider that pretty much just as bad. If you're
saying if you're saying it's good to send this guy as bad as
goals. >> Yes. 100%. Say yeah. When you have a platform,
yes, absolutely. If if you're like, "Yeah, it's a good thing.
It's funny. Somebody else should do that again." I think it is
funny that CPS did that um in monetization.
So I I dislike this thing where you have to put this whole group
together. You have to put bad empanada, all of Hassan's orbiters,
Hassan, H3 Stark, and like all of anti uh all of anti Ethan Twitter
together into one group and then take every bad action done by
anybody in that group and apply it to every other person and
every other group that's attached in any way. That's like just
that's crazy to me. >> No. All I have to do is just say
the ads on a stream. Nope. All I have to do is say the people
that he has on his >> Do you believe that he has significantly
platformed bad empanada? >> Objectively, he has significantly
platformed bad empanada. Objective saying by being on his stream
by watching his videos what you mean? >> No. He was on
his stream with him like several times. No. >> Was it Wait,
was it Hassan's stream or was it Noah Samson stream? I I haven't
kept up. >> I saw that Noah Samson. He's talking about
the charity stream. Yep. That and then playing his videos on
his stream. Yeah. Endorsing him verbally on his stream. Yeah.
Absolutely. And then Noah Samson, who also justified the skulls,
was on his stream as well, literally physically sitting next
to him. So yeah, he has these people in his house. Sure. So now
he's responsible. So anybody that you've had on your stream or
anybody that you platform in anything but the most heated controversial
of ways, you're responsible for all of those opinions, right?
You bring somebody into your house, you're responsible for all
of their opinions. >> No. When you bring those people after
you know these very uh very significant negative things, right?
After you it has come to your attention, you have these people
in your place and then to continuously sh on these same people
that you believe or are or sorry that are uh um
uh in question. Like I would argue that that uh you know having
Noah Samson on and Noah Samson on Ethan and Ela that is what
I'm talking about. It's not that he had Noah Samson on to talk
about some charity drive that they were doing and nothing. Literally
Ethan Klein and never got brought up. They were talking about
like giving food to homeless people or some [__]
That's not what happened. They would he would have them on and
they would literally make fun of Ethan and Ela on the stream
knowing full well that that uh uh Noah Samson is saying like
yeah the skulls were funny. >> I do believe that Noah Samson
is 100% endorsed by Hassan. I was not saying he wasn't. I was
saying that I don't believe Bad Ampanata is endorsed to the same
level. Although probably we're starting to get there
endorsed
on the same level. Can you tell me the only reason why bad empat
is cuz that guy's like on the run or some [__] >> when
he's talking about bad empanada. Can you tell me where he's endorsed
him where he said positive things like what what are the positive
things he said? >> I would have to get a clip but yeah
he said like oh I I think I remember at one point him saying
like while bad empanata is unhinged sometimes and stuff like
that I think his like heart is in a good place or he he goes
after the the pro- genocidal maniacs or something like that.
Yeah, there was a clip. >> I believe he said his his Israel
Palestine video essays are well done and well researched. I disavow
anything he does on Twitter or anything outside of that, but
his videos are are good, right? Maybe. But hold on, that's going
to be my understanding as of like four months ago. I've not followed
the stuff very much recently. So, it's possible four to five
months, past four or five months, he might have said something
>> Okay. Yeah, without like clip forming or clip hunting,
sorry. We would need to uh I guess we can agree to disagree on
that. Somebody sent me the Noah Samson clip and I I'm curious.
I know a totally degenerate loser from that guy. >> Me
too. Look,
>> total piece of [__] >> The politician.
>> Oh, no. He said the propagandists.
He said the propagandists. The politicians, the weapons companies.
So, and he objectively calls Destiny, for instance, a propagandist.
He calls >> Yeah. Sure. Sure. Sure. If he said the if he
said the propaganda then I would say for every single content
creator. >> Sure. I would say if he said propagandist then
I would say he's targeting content creators 100%. >> I
I will link it to you. I'm I'm sure you would. >> I believe
you 100%. >> Yeah, I believe. Okay. Yeah. He said the
I could have sworn he said the
will to have on people on his program after they had a controversy
directly calling for violence against other streamers. >> Um
sure. Yeah. >> Yeah. And this is the type of audience he's
cultivating. And so we have a moment real quick. >> I'll
pull it up.
>> You sent it to me. I'll pull it up. Did you throw it
in the general chat?
>> No, no, no. I Do you want me to throw it in Jen or I
can just DM it to you? >> Do I want you to You throw You
DM it or throw it in chat? Either one. Doesn't >> Okay.
My bad. Here's the DM.
I didn't >> Okay. So, just just I have to walk this argument
all the way back before we start watching this. We will start
watching it, but I have to start walking the argument all the
way back. So because because he's platformed Noah Samson who
has called for violence towards propagandists and these people
and even though he's never explicitly avowed violence and he's
I believe he said political violence um based on speech is not
valid. No like I believe he disavows political violence. I believe
Hassan explicitly devou disavows political violence. Right. >> I
don't think he has ever explicitly disavowed political violence
against people he considers to be pro genocide. >> Okay.
Ogre boy. You got a clip showing otherwise? That would be fine.
But I'm saying so basically if he has not made it clear that
he opposes political violence against people I'm trying to steal
man you by the way. Um if he's not made it clear that he opposes
political violence and he platforms as in he has no assumption
on his show who has called for political violence in that video
then when he also says Ela Klein went on this night raid then
he is because his audience hates Ela Klein he's lowered her reputation
really significantly. He she is now going to fall from outside
of that range of of politically viable viable for political violence
into the range for viable for political violence. And even though
he isn't trying to do that, he's unknowingly doing that because
his audience believes and he's lowered his opinion the opinion
of the audience enough that they will now see her as a target
for political violence
>> potentially. Yeah. >> Okay. Um so if we apply
that same >> he doesn't condemn political he does not condemn
political violence that comes from his friends. I I I've never
seen him condemn Noah Samson for saying this. >> I've never
seen him do that. I don't know. But I don't know if he's aware
that Noah Samson said it.
>> Yes, he is. No, let's stop playing games. He is. There
is no There was every there was so many I'm pretty I promise
you that somebody either
enough that like heion people he saw if he if he didn't bring
it up on stream, it's because he's ignoring it maliciously. Okay,
that's the only reason why there you cannot be that big and not
hear of something like this.
>> I think you definitely could, but it's I don't need
to
stream. You're telling me that there is nobody who's adding him
with this. There's nobody who's mentioning this in the chat.
There's nothing. There's nobody. He's He's just insulated from
this entire controversy surrounding
I think Noah's like
creative friends.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I think he's friends with Noah Samson.
I honestly if you like ask me for sure, I don't know. I don't
know that he disavowed it anyway. Like even if it was like brought
up on stream, I don't know if he'd disavow. >> Definitely
wouldn't. He would just say that it's like out of context or
something like that. >> Okay. So, in that context of somebody
who does not disavow political violence directly called towards
people who are quote propagandists when he includes propagandists
as like Twitch streamers, he's not disavowing any of these things.
He's platforming these people, signal boosting them, saying that
they're good representations of that explicit thing that they're
calling to violence for Israel Palestine, right? And he's also
signal boosting people who are uh uh engaged in the types of
[__] that bad empanada is engaged in. And then he
he makes this claim about uh El Klein in in even in the context
that he is. Uh, yes. I believe that is harmful because explicitly
to his audience that is going to make them more likely to view
it as, you know, maybe it's not a bad idea if somebody were to
smack that. >> So would you say that because of this Hassan
supports violence? He supports political violence. >> Yeah.
In his content. Absolutely. 100%.
>> So I'd say everybody So would you say that Hold on,
I'm going to text you an argument. Okay. >> So you think
that follows pretty easily,
>> No, no, no. We're not muted. I'd say that follows pretty
easily, right? that you would you would say this is crazy >> as
a I would add an extension
that action not necessarily as a human I don't think that you
have to so for instance if Assan disavowed Noah Samson's thing
here and said that's not cool and like told him explicitly like
that's not a good thing >> if Hassan disav if he went live
tomorrow and said oh I heard Noah like call for violence in this
video I totally disavow political violence you'd totally say
okay now nobody now we have no >> in a way in a way that
is convincing vincing. Yeah, I would say that's that's justified.
Yeah. >> What would it take to be convinced >> uh
for Hassan?
I think he believes in it. >> If you're are you asking
me to be convinced or >> So there is no So there is no
Wait, how does that >> think that is Hassan's opinion?
I don't think he cares about political violence against these
people. I don't I don't think he disavows it. I believe that's
his opinion. >> Okay. The only for me to believe you would
need to never talk to Panata again.
Never talk to Noah Samson again Noah Samson and like make up
with Ethan >> Wait. Okay. All right. All right. I am >> he
would need he would need to entirely change his character. I
think I think if I saw any evidence
people criticizing the son followed any of these moral standards.
I think you would. But if I saw any evidence that anybody here's
the reason why I would feel this >> because the reason
why people are upset with Assan is because he condones political
violence. The whole basis is that he's okay my discord not yours
with
and raping people and refuses to ever condemn them because he
views the group that they reside in or the group themselves as
the victim. >> We have to do we have to walk this down.
Where does Hassan condone rape as a form of vi resistance? >> Oh,
when he refused to cond that back, right? Yeah. Yeah. So, it's
not it's not >> Wait, he didn't Wait, but he condemned
something specific. >> Oh, he didn't. Right. >> He
did rapes on October. >> He condemned He condemned violence
against civilians. >> Is rape not a form of violence against
>> When Okay, hold on. If if we're of the opinion that
Hassan are you just saying he did once or are you saying this
is the merit of his
opinion
because in the discussion with Ethan Ethan explicitly brought
up several different instances in which people were
has said I've watched him say I believe I watched him say it
on uh here's Morgan yes I'm not talking about a single statement
I'm talking about I'll lock this down for everybody okay because
I think it's a crazy thing to say that Hassan supports I think
That's nuts. Okay. Hassan will not sufficiently condemn the actions
of Yes. But that is not supporting, right? That is a different
thing.
when you say things like
Palestinian resistance groups are justified in attacking the
Israelis
and then they go, "Yeah, but like not the civilians or the civilians,
right?" And then your response is, "I can't condemn.
I can't do that. So instead, I'm just going to for a multi multiple
hours. >> Do we have a >> You think that is Do you
think that is like What do you think that is? >> Do Do
you have that clip? Is that clip? Does that clip exist? >> Yeah.
Look at the entire E. Wait, can you give me the in the through
the entire Ethan Klein debate where he
was a terrorist organization that warranted significant scrutiny
that Houthies were a terrorist organization >> You're totally
moving the goalpost. I'm asking you for where the song said that
attacks my argument that when they said but and rapes and murders
of civilians are bad and he said well I refuse to condemn I want
that quote that you just said he said >> I never said he
he quote said that he what no what I'm saying is that he did
refuse to condemn over their October 7th during that debate >> that
he so >> I I believe he even refused to recognize >> I
need that because I could have sworn I I didn't watch the whole
thing right so I could have sworn that in the Pierce Morgan debate
he did. He basically said, "Yeah, obviously I don't think attacks
against civilians are good. Obviously, I don't want violence
against civilians." I could have sworn he said that, >> bro.
In the NPR interview, he said he's a sock dem. Okay, that's not
what I'm talking about. What I'm talking about
when he makes arguments when he's talking to people and he's
making >> I totally agree with you that he's willing to
minimize all of Hamas's crimes. Absolutely. He he he lies about
his positions and when you ask me meets grass when a debate comes
and time comes do you condemn Hamas for these rapes he goes well
blah blah blah and he moves the goalpost and shifts things around
the Ethan Klein debate was perfect to illustrate this he never
explicitly said yes I condemn the these rapes that happened on
October 7th he never said this >> okay he might not have
ever said that I agree with you and I agree he absolutely downplays
the evidence that there that exists for violence happening on
October 7th. I totally agree with that. What I'm saying is I
don't think he specifically ever said, which I just this is the
only point I disagree on you, but you you said Hassan supports
civilians and I'm like, no, I don't think you ever >> I
believe in a So this this is a very So this is maybe where we're
going to disagree. I think in a principal discussion with your
former co-host where the principal distinction is whether or
not you support
um because they believe you support uh terrorist organizations
when they bring up to you real material instances of them raping
civilians and then you cannot uh concede that yes the rape did
happen that is support okay I think which the way I look at it
is he shouldn't have to condemn your he should be able to say
these actions are evil and I condemn anybody who does them right
>> so what he shouldn't what you shouldn't be expected
to do is to say I condemn this group that I see as like absolutely
necessary to prevent like the extinction of the Palestinians
that they are violently resisting a like a genocide. I don't
think he should have to say I condemn that group wholesale. He
should have to say I condemn these actions these actions that
have happened. I condemn these condemn the killings of >> I
agree able to do that. >> Okay.
I need to so I need to see where >> so does >> so
somebody is saying he's never denied rape occurring. He only
denied systemic/mass.
Now that's not true necessarily
because I think that he he specifically there's some argument
about Hezbollah people and he goes what did Hezbollah do bro
what did do but that's >> yeah exactly >> in the
moment kind of [__] where I'm like okay
>> in the with Ethan Ethan literally brought up articles
and a woman
that she that uh of her experience with and then he explicitly
uh said like we don't uh what was it like we don't have uh uh
something like we don't have like any evidence or or uh like
videos or anything like that of these things happening and then
when presented from uh with it uh by Ethan he literally refused
to accept it in front of him literally in front of him he refused
to accept it >> okay let's go through that that section
I guess um I'm fine with him refusing to accept certain things
Right. So what I think he did I don't remember this section.
What I think his position would be was there's no evidence of
mass or systemic rape. Right. That's that would be his argument
and that he would agree that rape happened. So he would agree
that rape happened. I've seen him make this point that he agrees
happened.
>> Right. He disagree with me that he has agreed happened
on October 7th. >> Uh he said it. I I don't think that
that is a part of his coverage. He hems
then if if if the response is going to be he said it but I don't
believe he believes it then I don't know why we even have the
conversation >> whether or not I believe that he believes
it it's that he's inconsistent with his mentioning of it that's
the point he'll say it in only very specific circumstances like
maybe once but the overwhelming bastion of his coverage is to
never talk about it ever and including in the moments that you
brought up like what did
uh my >> I know all the clips I'm telling you that like
what when you say something that's outside of my understanding
of the clips that I've watched right then I'm going to go well
I don't know if he said that but what you said is civilians and
I'm like no I don't believe that >> so in the Ethan Klein
debate he said that there's nobody who testified there's none
of these different things you know the common talking point and
then when Ethan Klein sent him several bits of evidence showing
that that actually did happen he just refused to recognize it
>> okay is that >> refused to recognize that because
of like what's going on in the debate where Ethan's is going,
"You support this. You support people getting >> No, I
I believe if I remember correctly, the reason why he brought
it up is because he's like, uh, Hassan said, "Yeah, there's there
I haven't seen evidence for like nobody's come forward to like
testify." And then he brought up clips of this happening. He's
like, and then he said something like, "So this person didn't
testify or something to that effect." Yeah, I think it was probably
quippy, but at the end of the day, you have to concede that unless
you're supporting the records. In my opinion, that's just how
it works. You can't in front of a 100,000 people. I think that's
how many people were watching on each stream. You can't in front
of a 100,000 people just go like, "No, I'm not going to I'm not
going to recognize the evidence that's right in front of me,
like articles and stuff like that showing it." You can't do that.
Otherwise, you support it. Like, that's pretty simple
when that's the principal distinction. Do you support or do you
not support this terrorist organization? I believe you do. Here
is evidence of a thing that you say this terrorist organization
does not do and you refuse to recognize it. I'd say you're supporting
them. >> Pretty simple. >> Let's uh
>> let's go watch a clip. Let's get the clip because from
what I understand, he has said that no rap happened in captivity.
I think this person was arguing that somebody they knew was raped
in captivity, right? They're testifying to this, right? >> I
don't remember the specifics, but
When testifying, he previously covered on stream. He was saying
he knew about that case, but that case was in captivity. And
the argument was Ethan was proving October 7th essays.
>> Also, just to be clear, the UN report
>> did. I thought Hassan said that there were no in captivity
or that although I thought he said,
>> I believe he said there's one whenever whenever he gets
referenced, he always says there's only ever been one confirmed
rape in captivity. That is what he consistently says. >> there's
only one confirmed to have happened in captivity, which obviously
implies that there is no other confirmed
Even singular confirmed
like I don't >> No, I said I'm I'm listening to you. Don't
worry. I I I was just grabbing another soda. >> Go ahead.
>> All right, let's go on the pale.
>> Is that a There is
>> Did you put
on me?
>> Is this song worth this level of defense? I'm I'm just
going through and showing like this is what I think I remember,
right? And if I'm wrong, I'm fine with being wrong. You >> sure
did. Hold on, hold on, hold on. I missed this.
>> Hassan does suck. Yes, Hassan sucks. I'm sitting here
like I just think it's probably bad that we have a bunch of people
online explicitly lying about Hassan.
That's That's the only point I'm making here. If you hear anything
else, I'm sorry. Right. I'm I'm tired of people getting lied
about. I'm tired of the lies. I just want the lies to stop. Okay.
We have We have a bunch of lies going out. Okay. calling for
someone to attack Ela because she served in the military over
a decade ago. We disagree with this as well, right? That he did
not say this. Zan did not say that. >> I don't believe
that he's I don't I don't believe he is making an explicit call
for it. I believe that there is an implicit uh
>> you don't even believe you don't even believe that Hassan
is implicitly calling for it. You believe that
>> you might interpret it that way. >> I am saying
that the implication of his words is that it would be justified.
That is what I'm believe I believe he is >> the implication
of his words is it might be just but you don't you don't think
that you think that people could misunderstand him just to be
clear you already agreed with me but there is nothing there's
a different way an implication is your intent it is reasonably
interpretable for from his words that it would be justified to
attack Ela Klein >> it's reasonably interpretable by
okay but you don't believe that he is implying that or that he
is saying that outright right
>> my reading being says no, but it is within the scope
of human beings online that would be reasonable reasonable in
their reading of it that they could take that away. Yes. And
therefore, it should have never been said. Just because I can
read and or I I can listen to this and be charitable to this
and and understand what I believe his intent to be doesn't mean
that his entire audience is going to. And in fact, I would argue
his entire audience is specifically tailored to take this in
a way that says, you know, if uh Ela Klein, you know, if she
gets smacked, then >> what percentage of of Ethan's a or
sorry, of Hassan's audience do you think didn't know that Elila
Klein went on those night raids?
>> Uh my Discord, not yours. Um I I think I I I don't know.
Very low.
>> Very low. Okay. So, what do you think is changing here?
What's changing is our valid
it's her moral equivalency and her moral proximity to the people
who are actively engaged in militant action in the West Bank
and right now. >> Bill knew that already, right? >> No,
he's he's closing the gap on their moral proximity all the time.
And that's the point is he's significantly closing the gap in
this instance. >> He's closing the gap.
>> What does that mean? He's closing the gap between The
natural difference
in the west military target that justified good to kill is and
Ela Klein is shrinking in his audience's
uh
>> He's just pushing his audience closer and closer to
saying like if somebody killed Ela Klein, it wouldn't be that
big of a deal >> or would potentially even be good. But
>> I don't I don't think he's pushing his audience closer
to that. I think his whole audience I think his whole audience
that's baked in already. this this whole thing is like there
I think it's already baked in with them. I think that's why in
any context they would say
hila whatever the [__] genocidal hila all these things
right that's my >> no because no that's ridiculous because
then your argument would be it couldn't get worse >> I
don't know if their opinion of Ela Klein could get worse I don't
think it was made >> worse you have to take that back that's
one of the most ridiculous things I've ever heard in my life
>> I don't think their opinion could possibly be made worse
by reference to the night raids I don't think so >> by
reference to that you have to take that back you you can't believe
that >> by referencing the Sean
already knows about her night raids. It's like a >> Sean
said tomorrow Ela Klein deserves to be killed because she went
on those night raids. You would say that oh well their opinion
of her isn't going to be lowered and there's no consequence to
>> Oh, sure. If he was saying she should be Yeah. Okay.
Okay. I see. >> So their opinion of her can be lowered
and it's just we're arguing whether or >> No, no, no, no.
Sorry. That changes something else, right? That's not that's
not their opinion of her wouldn't go lower. their opinion of
what could be done to people with her like with that level of
opinion would go would change, right? It would be like your how
you think you can deal with people that you have this opinion
of changes, right? That's what's changing there. >> Yeah,
but her their opinion of her would then change. >> What
has changed?
>> Is it what you can do to people who you have that opinion
of? >> Why? What new information do they have about Ela
Klein?
>> just tell me that. What new information do they have
about Ela Klein? Can you answer the question? What new information
do they have about Ela Klein? There's a difference between people's
changing opinion of her versus people's changing opinion of what
they could do to her
>> based on that opinion. Yes. That they already have all
of those facts baked into their opinion, right? >> Come
on. Come on, man. >> Wait, hold on. Do you not think those
are different? >> So, just to be clear, you think that
it is the same exact moral opinion if I say that uh if somebody
in Assan's audience says goes from I actually love Ela Coin.
She's the best person on planet Earth. in fact Jesus the second
coming of Christ to hey actually I think ila Klein deserves to
die that is having that is not a change of opinion that's a change
of the uh underlying your opinion of the underlying number of
people that are like influence your opinion >> you think
there are significant number of I so what underlying fact has
changed that influences their opinion thank you >> I don't
think any facts did change >> you just said that that was
your >> no I'm saying that that's what your argument is
>> I'm saying there is no fact that's changing they're
saying is saying somebody who went on these night ra
when political violence is appropriate not your opinion on Ela
Klein. >> Do you understand? >> This is just this
is literally just base semantics. I I really don't know why you're
making this argument. It is my argument is hey
Hassan's audience's opinion of Il Klein can lower
and your argument is no.
>> Oh sorry. Not based on the not based on a fact they
all already have. That is ridiculous because they can their opinion
of her is influenced based on their opinions of those facts.
No. >> Yes, it would be
understanding of the night rafore
logically it is possible for them to change their opinion of
her in those facts not change. Correct. >> Um maybe if
they'd heard so here would be an example of this. If they'd heard
about some more violence that had been done by like these night
raids, then yes. But I don't hear Hassan saying >> No,
all they have to hear is that, hey, if you previously went on
these night raids, you are justified as a valid >> But
that's not what he's saying. We we have already agreed that's
not what he's saying. I don't think there's any reasonable interpretation
where you could think he's saying this. We can agree, you and
me, that he isn't saying this while also agreeing or we don't
agree while also making the statement that people listening to
this message can take away the opinion that she is on the same
moral footing as the people who are currently engaged in it or
a similar moral footing >> was and literally everything
before that clip as we've already agreed is talking about your
need in these places engaging in this Just to be clear, you think
it's ridiculous for me to believe that Hassan's audience is primed
and ready to go to believe that somebody who he's referred to
as a propagandist, a genocidal propagandist, would um uh be available
for or morally justified and being a target of violence. I have
evidence of this. One of his close friends, one of his close
friends on stream that I refuses to he refuses to condemn believes
that propaganda justifies for moral violence. >> Who has
called for that violence? Yes. And he hasn't condemned that actively.
>> And you think it's ridiculous for me to believe that
there's people in his audience that are primed to view Ela Klein
as a propagandist who is justified for violence. You believe
I'm >> based on that statement? Yes. I believe anybody
who's already there who's already know Samson fan who's already
primed in this way would already know that she's gone on these
night raids and would either already think that or this
night raids because I I don't how are you not able to conceptualize
this? It's not whether or not they know that he went on the night
raids. It's whether or not they believe that having previously
been on the night raids warrants X
And his argument is that X treatment is getting closer and closer
active military members. >> So you think unintentionally
he's convinced a bunch of people that all former active military
members of the Israeli government who have gone on any raid into
the West Bank or the Gaza Strip are culpable and can be targeted.
Now you think he's convinced a significant portion of his audience
of >> What? From the >> I have to say yes to that.
No, I don't say yes to that. That has to be your opinion. That's
what you've been arguing the whole time. >> Explain how
I would have to say yes to this. All I'm stating is that it is
reasonably interpretable that that would be a consequence of
it. That's it. You understand that me and you could call for
somebody to die in >> disagreeing on what's reasonably
excuse me. You understand me and you could call for somebody
to be killed right now on this stream. And at the end of the
day, it we if nobody nobody in our audience cared to take us
up on it, that wouldn't change that
example of somebody in this committing level of violence. >> That
is my argument. My argument has nothing to do with actually whether
or not somebody will do it. Right? That's not my argument. It's
whether or not it's reasonably interpretable that people would
justify violence against them. And it 100% is. I just I totally
disagree on this and I I think this framing is like totally broken,
right? I think there's no evidence that somebody in Hassan's
audience has done violence, right? I think there's no evidence
of that. I don't even think there's evidence that they have a
propensity for
>> I I mean I think that's ridiculous when his friend literally
is justifying political violence against like
>> Okay. I'm just I'm loving that. Ah, so I don't want
to go to the topic that I sent you the DM about, but [__]
me. Um, >> well, no, because it's going to be different
because again, it's about specifically condemning this specific
action. And I would stand on that no matter what. It's about
condemning this specific thing. He can have Noah Samson on as
long as he says, "Hey, bro." And it's very convincing. Hey, bro,
that that [__] cannot fly. If you say like that,
no, you you're you're [__] I'm going to fun of you.
I'm going to do all this different [__] I'm going
to say how ridiculous you are. You cannot say like that. I'm
not going to let that slide. If he had did that when he had him
on, then we're chill. But he doesn't. In fact, he ignores he
ignores
>> Okay. So, he's totally totally culpable for that opinion
and his audience. >> No, not I don't I hate this extreme
that you keep doing. I'm not saying that
Hassan might as well have done it. What I'm saying is that there's
a clear precedent in Assan's community that it is okay to justify
political violence against people who are pro- genocide. Do you
disagree with that? Yes. There's a clear precedent. >> I
There's a clear Sorry. Then there's one case of somebody there
saying that political violence would be okay. That is the president.
>> His friend he has on stream. Bro, what?
>> I'm asking you about levels. You said, sorry, I was
going to disagree if it was broad. I was just going to disagree
on whether or not it was broad. I think there are a lot of people
who watch these streams and have no inkling towards political
violence, that do not believe political violence is justified.
I was going to say I would need evidence that they actually support
this. And if you want me to say yes, okay, I do think I do think
that they support political >> Even if you support Even
if you support political violence against uh people who support
who are randomly pro- Israel because they just call anybody pro-
Israel they want, right? whoever is pro-
that political violence against them is justified and even fine
enough to be able to allow you to get on his stream without a
word of condemnation and have him cherish you in your opinion
on Israel Palestine. >> I think the opinion on Israel Palestine
is a little disconnected but I think um >> he should be
he should be absolutely disavowing like uh Noah Samson's calls
to violence 100%. But his opinions on Israel Palestine is a part
of the reason why he's making these calls to violence. >> Sure.
But what do you hold on? Hold on. What do you disagree on? What
do you disagree on? >> What do you think's No.
There's There's a fantastic No, no. There's a big disconnect.
Okay. You can have an opinion on the state of Israel Palestine
and have a different opinion entirely on what the reaction to
that should be. Right. Those are totally distinct. We'd agree
on that. Yes. And wait, you can have an opinion on Israel Palestine
and I have an opinion on description versus prescription. >> Yeah,
of course. >> Okay. So, descriptively, what does Hassan
disagree with uh with Noah Samson
>> It's only on the prescription,
right? If he does, if he doesn't want political violence. >> So,
what I'm saying is he can agree with the descriptions that they
give of the situation in Gaza, right? But their prescriptions
are different. I've seen no evidence that Hassan's prescription
is violence for people for like these people, right? And the
evidence you have is saying well actually because he agrees with
the description for Noah and he agrees with their prescription
not condemning the kidnappings of the people on the boats. >> Yeah
that's I absolutely hate that worst part of their entire debate
worst part of the debate. >> Wait just to be clear that
does away with sorry political violence. No no but political
violence in this part of the world you don't have the ability
to to influence. You think would say that if America sent boats
Israel that it's Wait, aren't there American boats that have
been stopped by the Houthies? >> Um, stopped? I don't know.
I don't think so. Definitely not. >> Just assume. So, let's
just assume a
You're saying Hassan would condemn the Houthi stopping an American
vessel to >> No, no, no. This is probably the best example
that you have. And this is one that I disagreed with. I don't
know if you remember that deer guy, the guy the deer avatar who
came out and argued. You remember that guy? That is like um like
I don't know how you can get away with not just disavowing. To
me, you don't even have to disavow the Houthies, right? You just
disavow them capturing the civilians. Yeah. That's absolutely
>> I don't know. A deer guy. I don't know who this is.
I don't know what that is. >> But like uh it was some guy.
It was some dude who's arguing that uh you're justified in capturing
those people. We just we both argue to the same guy. Do you remember
this? Oh, I think >> he's like a crazy dude. Yeah, he's
like he's like >> Yeah, but the the the issue is that guy
came from the same web of of uh B of thinking that Hassan is
where it's it's justified no matter what as long as it's anti-
or it's pro- resistance, right? This is literally what I said
immediately after um Hassan made the argument that it's okay
or well, he didn't contend the argument. uh he didn't push back
or or or make an argument against the >> kidnapping. This
is probably in my opinion the best example of this. >> Yes.
Yes. I think this is the best example of this. >> Okay.
But no, that is the that is the argument. If it's okay to and
justified to kidnap civilians for these things. If it's if if
you have your friend who's coming on stream who says that political
violence against content creators who he labels as propagandists,
which is all of >> I don't think sorry this no assention
thing doesn't connect to me whatsoever. But if you want to make
it from the argument that he did he refused to disavow the Houthies
actions in terms of capturing civilians, I absolutely make it
about that and I totally >> I think Noah Samson has a good
opinion on Israel Palestine and a part of Noah Samson's opinion
on Israel Palestine is that all of these different people >> you
agree with somebody's descriptive
agree with their prescriptions without agreeing with their prescriptions.
>> Let me ask you let me ask you a separate question. It
was what I what I was going to ask earlier. What do you think
people inside of Assange's audience believe after they see somebody
like Noah Samson make that statement and then get consistent
praise from Assan and even getting invited to his house? What
do you think their opinion is on political violence after that?
>> I don't know if they connect that. I do. You do you
think that their thoughts are well the thing I know Noah Samson
for is that he offers to people or he's he's encouraging us to
kill people. So Hassan having him over that means Han wants to
kill people. You think there's a lot of people who have that
opinion? I promise you there's a fair number of people who know
that Noah Samson made either that claim or claims similar to
that and they see him getting put up there, they just think,
"Yeah, I mean this is good resistance. This is good Palestinian
resistance." Absolutely 100%. And even beyond that, you see that
you see bad empanada saying that the CPS calls were based. You
see bad empanada talking about uh the skulls being funny. And
somebody correct me if I'm wrong. is did Ben Eanatada was he
not the one who made the shirts making fun of the situation or
was it somebody else? >> Okay, so when you see somebody
like that making shirts and laughing at literally harassing this
dude's kids and then another person who is
>> uh uh political violence. when you see all of this happen
on his stream and then you see him in no real measure condemning
uh the the kidnapping of civilians or the raping of the people's
position on the CPS >> What do you think their opinion
is? >> Can you tell me what Hassan's position on the CPS
calls is?
>> Can you tell me what Hassan's position on the CPS call
is? >> I uh I've heard him say like uh something like like
oh that that's not cool. No, don't do that. totally totally dis
about it. Said that's insane. Ethan's a good dad. Don't [__]
with him. That's [__] crazy, right? >> Um yeah,
because he frankly if he actually believed that, why hasn't he
condemned Bad Aanana for doing it? >> I would just say
that when he does when he does actually condemn things, right,
everybody's still going to attribute all these things to him
anyway, like you just did. You just assume all of those opinions
you've just No. The reason why is there is no way for him to
get out. Hold on. Hold on. No, no, no. You literally have said
on this call that there's nothing Hassan can do to change your
opinion of it. to be a rat. That's the reason why is Hassan a
>> you've already said on this call that there's nothing
Hassan could do that would change your opinion of him. Why does
he have to start going after the people who are attacking the
people who are unhinged towards him? >> I ask a couple
of questions and I answered. Is Hassan a socialist like he says
or is Hassan a sock like he says? Which one? He says he's both.
Which one is he? >> Are those mutually exclusive? Is Sakm
not just like a category of socialist? >> Oxde is not a
socialist. Sockde is not >> so is not a subcategory of
socialism. No, it is not. >> What does the sock stand for?
>> As as a social democrat. >> Oh, okay. Um All right.
I think I think Hassan's beliefs are for me difficult to determine.
I'd lean towards socialist, >> Okay. Because when he's
on NPR and he's like, "Yeah, I'm just like a liberal sock dimm
like whatever guy who just believes in healthcare." And then
on his stream he's like, "Yeah, you know what? I'm a socialist."
Or even
plays with communism. You understand in one of those situations
he's lying,
>> Okay. Well, so we've established Hold on. You can't
just yap that. We've established he lies in moments to make himself
look better. Correct.
>> Uh who doesn't? >> Who who doesn't change their
opinions like this? Can you give me a moment to like look at
who doesn't who my under
that if you think you're somewhere between socialist and sock
and you're not really that well read if you say socialist in
the place where you're closer to socialist sock the place where
you're closer to sock is that not something people do. You understand
that literally on his stream he is on sock dems right >> you
cut out liberals are people >> on his stream he is on his
stream he has done it >> so if he's on sock dems and then
going on NPR and calling people calling himself a sock dem I'd
be like oh yeah >> no it's not
holding
that's a that's a highle political position do I think that means
that when he states his opinion on an event that he's always
lying no >> I never said when he states his opinion on
things He's always lying. What I what I'm saying is I'm just
building a very simple character assessment. It's that in in
moments he will lie about his political opinions in order to
benefit him and and then take every single action in the opposite.
So he says things like, "Oh yeah, don't call CPS." But then he
has on the principal CPS endorser on his stream consistently
who's selling merch about the CPS call. Yes. So he doesn't care
about the CPS call. That is my argument. Bad empanada. And just
can we confirm has Bad Empanada been on Hassan's stream? >> Uh
I I don't know. I I don't know if he's been on his stream. I
I I mean to say he does streams with him and endorses him. >> Do
you see that? Like my my basic thing here is I just try to figure
out what's actually true about Hassan and you say all of these
things and I have to slowly like walk back these things for you,
right? But you're totally fine saying all of these things. You
you said it now like three times. I actually don't know when
I was on the stream. But you're just going off. I haven't said
a single lie. You could say I misspoke, but I haven't said a
single lie. >> You misspoke three times in a row in the
exact same way? >> Yeah. About bad empanada [__]
Yeah. No, I I don't I don't think that that is an insane misspeak
to say that bad empanada was on his stream versus he was on a
stream voluntarily with bad empanada signal boosting him and
he has signal boosted B empanada on his stream and he has played
multiple bad empanada videos on his stream. I don't think that
distinction is like super criticizing them for some of their
extreme opinions. Do you think that's you endorsing them, you
endorse that opinion entirely,
>> so you think if you go on some some other creators stream,
right, and they have really negative opinions out there all over
the world, you think that actually when you when you do that,
>> you're endorsing them. You're endorsing their opinions,
their crazy opinions. >> No, what I would say is when you
go when you have somebody on your stream who has really negative
opinions that you've been
on your stream.
>> Yeah, not even you're on the stream. Well, no. I mean,
he's endorsing them on his stream. When you're when people are
brought up with like if if somebody is on my stream or I endorse
them on my stream and somebody brings up some kind of behavior
that they have done, some actions that they have done, if I refuse
to condemn them for those actions when the evidence has been
uh presented before me, then yeah, I am endorsing or or co-signing
on that uh not being a big deal or not not being worth worthy
of note. Yeah, 100%. You can't get linked to clip showing like,
oh yeah, you know, hey, here's this guy doing this horrible thing
that you claim to care about. >> Wait, did he get link
the clip while the guy was on the stream, or are we just going
back to knowing? >> No, no, no. I I I don't I I imagine
you would instantly get banned if you tried to do that, which
is further evidence for my argument. If you want to try, I can
guarantee you'll instantly get
>> So, you think if you sent Hassan a clip about Empanada
saying something unhinged, you'd get instantly banned? >> 100%.
Without a doubt. Yeah. >> Okay. without a doubt. Because
even if it was in context, he'd say it's out of context or I
don't care, you're an H3
uh fan or you like Destiny and he just banned it 100%. >> Okay.
All right.
>> Can you give me a time where in which he has looked
at a clip critically of one of his friends and in any moment
like
>> I don't know what's been linked to him and I I no I
can't tell you. I don't watch enough of him. I haven't seen it.
I do think he covers for his friends as an instinct. Yes. But
I don't know if him and Bad Empata are like technically
>> He's 100%.
>> You think he Do you think he just has randomly people
that he endorses and watches his videos of and then says that
like they make very good videos? You think he just does that
randomly? >> Okay. I would 100% call them friends. He doesn't
do this with like random people. >> Hassan said he'd never
platform bad until bad started doing terrible [__]
to Ethan. That's not true. I think he actually watched some of
his Israel Palestine stuff before platforming any of the Ethan
stuff, right? and he started doing it because he liked his video
essays and he didn't want to and he explicitly said just I'm
I'm just responding to this chat and he explicitly said um I
can I can condone his Israel essays and nothing else about him.
Now is there a reason that after a year and a half of having
this drama cycle with Ethan that he might actually start going
and and replplatforming some of bad and banana where he feels
like Ethan's now basically calling me dude Ethan's now basically
calling me a bad uh Okay, yeah, I'll go with some of these other
things. Yeah, I'll run with some of the bad empanada stuff. Yeah,
I I understand why people would start moving positions on that.
I'm empathetic to it at least.
>> Wait, didn't the the I I don't even know anything about
the alleged thing, but didn't that only happened like >> It
did. I'm saying that like the the places it has gone to. Obviously,
there are a lot of people talking about Hassan, right? People
that Ethan platforms. Let's go with Dan Saltman.
>> literally we got the redact button on Ethan. But I mean
I would say most of what Dan >> it is just consistently
escalating back and forth, right? Do you disagree that it's like
consistently escalating back and forth? >> Yeah, but like
one one of the sides is way more consistently correct and based
in reality and the other one is like just throwing like CPS calls
and like that. You could say escalating, but >> wait, hold
on. >> I'm not even sure I would agree with >> You're
doing You're doing like CPS calls. I'm telling you like the leaders
of the Ethan side are outright lying. Dan Dan is literally an
associate of Ethan. He is outright lying about his I don't disagree
that he's an associate. I don't believe I think at worst this
is him misunderstanding what happened. I don't think this is
a lie.
>> You don't think Dan is lying right now? >> No,
I it is my opinion that I believe Dan actually believes this
is a call to attack Eva. I don't believe >> I've literally
gone through and explained to him how he's lying. I posted the
clip. He responded, "No, no, no, no. Here's the quote where he
says Ela Klein. >> Yeah. So, I think you're lying. >> He
believes that it is a direct call to violence on Ethan Klein
and that he's >> You understand? Hold on. We have to actually
cook now on the Dan side of things. You understand Dan's gone
on multiple podcasts, including to you directly and talked about
how he just lies because he'll lie to get whatever goal he wants,
right? >> Are you talking about the clip that like [__]
was >> I'm talking about when he went on a clip >> there
and I'm talking about how he also he pulled it back. He pulled
it back eventually. Okay. But he went on a podcast with Techone
and Noxaku and I think one other person. I can't remember who.
Okay. And he said, "Yes, you should just lie about these people.
They'll lie about you. Just lie about these people. We're just
lying now." >> Yeah. I mean, I I haven't seen that. If
I saw that, I would condemn that. I don't think that's good.
I don't think we should be lying. I don't think we >> obviously
obviously it's not good to lie. Thank you. I I didn't need that
from you. I understand that you think it's not good to lie. I'm
telling you that Dan is lying here. But you see how little effort
that takes include in not just when people are calling to violence
>> actually lying bad. Lying super bad. I'm sorry. You're
right. That that took a lot out of me. >> But no, you're
not making a connection. I'm not connecting to you. I'm connecting
to Assan. Why doesn't Hassan do what I just did? >> To
say lying is bad. >> Oh, come on, man. >> You You
want Hold on. You want to feel like it's incumbent on him. Hold
on. Hold and
about Noah Samson and about bad empanada. There's no
he this about people
just are you going to go and see if Dan has done these things
where he's gone and said he's going to explicitly lie about people
and then are you going to investigate some of the things he's
done to see if he's explicitly lied about people and then denounce
him and the actions he's done to lie about people. We're going
to undertake that because we expected him to sound right
>> I I would Yeah. I'm going to look for the clip where
he said or I'm going to ask for the clip and look for the clip
of him saying that it's we should lie about these people. I'm
going to look for the context. get the context. I'm gonna say,
"Yeah, that's not a good thing to do." I just took I'm taking
what you're saying at face value. I'll just assume that you're
representing it correctly. That is not a good thing to say. I
condemn that. The point that I don't know how you didn't see
that I was trying to make is there's a reason Hassan doesn't
do that. The reason Hassan doesn't do that is because he's fine
with it. That's the reason why. If I was Assan, I would just
go, "Nope, it was clipped out of context. Doesn't matter. It's
clipped out of context." You actually you wait. You sound >> like
you support Israel. >> That's kind of weird. You sound
like I'm not sure about this. I'm not sure about this. Let's
move on to the next topic. Yeah. No. Yeah, you do. Let's move
on to the next topic. Move on. >> I do support Israel.
>> Oh, that's crazy. You're actually a pro genocide baby
killer. Let's move on to the next topic. Like that's what I would
do if I was a son. You understand that, right? There is a clear
difference because there's a clear difference in goals. My aim
is to be like, "Yeah, no, that's not a good thing." And be honest
about what I believe in. His goal is not when it and it's very
conveniently when it comes to calls of violence against other
creators who are pro uh pro- genocide, pro- Israel, it's very
convenient all of a sudden he can't condemn these people. Weird
how he just all of a sudden can't condemn when it comes to when
his literal co-host is showing him articles saying people were
raped. I just I don't know, man. I just can't do it. like, you
know, you know, I I I don't know, man. I just, you know, >> I
think his inability to call people out is his biggest weakness.
Absolutely. >> No, but why can't he call people out? >> He's
already he's talked about why he doesn't want to call those things
out,
>> Why? Yeah. Why? >> He I'm pretty sure he believes
that like it doesn't make a difference that like having uniformity
like like literally just refusing to call out those those certain
actors is be is like actually helpful. is actually like okay
if I if I so in his opinion people will try to distract you from
the actual genocide going on in Israel by saying condemn you
have to condemn right now right you have to condemn and he says
that's a distraction don't pay attention to that you have to
keep driving home the point that there is a genocide going on
make them own the genocide make them own the genocide he thinks
he's a propagandist right that's that's how he sees himself >> in
the in the example I'm giving Ethan already owned the genocide
>> yeah but Ethan owns the genocide none of the downstream
effects he doesn't actually call out how Israel has handled at
all. Right. >> He he literally calls Netanyahu a genocidal
war criminal who should be in >> Okay, but you can't just
say that's Netanyahu. That's the entire Israeli
>> They're the people who continue to put that guy in power.
>> Israeli population dudes not belong in
>> Sorry, sorry, sorry. They they want Netanyahu as their
as their prime minister, right? Like there is there's a core
part of Israel that wants those people ethnically cleansed. Yes
or no?
There is a core part of Israel that wants that Gaza strip ethnically
cleansed, right? >> Yeah. I would say there's a fair number
of people. Yeah. >> Okay. So, like it's not enough to just
say, "Well, Netanyahu, Nanyahu, Netanyahu." No, there's a lot
of people in Israel who have horrifying opinions and that's the
reality we have to say. So, so you're you're telling me, >> but
Ethan Klein Ethan Klein thinks that oh, I could just denounce
Netanyahu and then it's a genocide and nothing else needs to
be done. wasn't to say, "Oh, yeah, Israel's participating in
a genocide. Net Netanyahu is a war criminal." But also, um, a
fair percentage of Israel is pro- genocide
>> and they need to reckon with that. Yes. Like the country
is actually
what reckoning do they need to have? >> Uh, reckon with
that as in you actually have to acknowledge it. You have to acknowledge
that this country is like okay with doing things that are totally
against our values completely. >> He he he is recognizing
that. What do you mean? That's where the That's where the cabinet
that's not Netanyahu. It's not the cabinet. It's the country.
>> No. The argument that the entirety of the country is
condemnable of it is no. That's ridiculous. >> Okay. Do
you think that Do you think Do you think Israel after October
7th has moved further right or further left politically? Sorry.
More towards Palestinian liberation or more towards like Palestinian
like >> further more antagonistic towards the people of
Gaza?
>> Sure. So do we think that the country that already had
Netanyahu already voted Netanyahu in power? Right. Do we think
that somebody better or worse than Netanyahu is going to end
up I technically somebody better could end up as the prime minister
because of the coalitions and stuff, but I think that the character
of the the country has shifted rightward and I think it's continuing
to shift rightward. And I think they've absolutely decided as
a country I think they have a fairly locked in position of like,
yeah, we're totally fine with whatever happens to these people
these people now. >> I don't think that is the characterist
the the uh I don't believe that you can characterize the entire
population that way. And if you can, then why don't you feel
the same way about Gaza? I do. I've said that explicitly.
Those people like those population
should be ethnically
I said they should be wrong. >> Why is Israel then wrong
with kicking all of the Gaza out people in Gaza out? >> If
you believe the people of Gaza are
literally starting to support another movement, if you believe
the people of
they're literally Hold on. If you believe if you believe the
entire population of Gaza is condemnable because they certainly
now have more antagonistic views towards Israel and and would
would favor an administration that would be actively antagonistic
or genocidal towards Israel than what what is your argument against
kicking them >> What is he? Well, originally it would have
been that they have no chance militarily against Israel. Israel
is total military supremacy over them, right? That's that you
don't need to ethnically cleanse them because you have complete
military supremacy.
>> My argument for like oh they should be moved out by
the international
I'm going to say my argument for them being uh ethnically cleansed
or forced out before the uh sorry after October 7th but before
Israel's ground operation was because I was like oh Israel's
going to genocide these people like actually now right that's
just to be clear. I don't think it was likely right. So the argument
your argument is literally both
>> your your argument is both sides want to genocide each
other. Okay.
>> Why should Israel
just go like okay I'm cool with you being my neighbor? >> Um
because their neighbor has is like a quadripollegic right they
have all the power in that situation. >> Killed what500
or 1300 people. >> Why did they have that why did they
have the security breach? Why did it take them so long to respond?
>> Intelligence failure to my knowledge.
uh because of an intelligence failure. It took them so long to
respond because half of their army was out of uh like off duty
and they were protesting Netanyahu trying to take over their
Supreme Court. Right. >> Okay. So, it was a it was a just
a complete like
that really shouldn't have happened. They do have complete military
supremacy.
It should never >> an entire population of 2 million people
that want to genocide all of them right next to them. uh they
basically should be the people who are more understanding or
more um more in control of the situation that they shouldn't
be able to keep those people in terms of they shouldn't be able
to keep them occupied even while they have those beliefs right
without um they shouldn't be able to keep those people occupied
while having total milit I don't agree with any of the points
that you made I don't believe that you can characterize uh uh
you should be characterizing the entire country of Israel as
genocidal against gazins nor do I believe that you should be
characterizing the entire population of Gazin as genocidal against
Israel. >> Significant portion of the country. >> Yeah.
I I don't believe that we should be characterizing it this way.
I think we should be characterizing it as uh the actions of the
government. When we look at just to be clear,
that is not a sufficient criticism of the state of Israel. That
is not a sufficient criticism if you think a genocide is going
on. I don't think a genocide was occurring. So, I didn't need
to do that. Right. But I think if you just if you think there's
a genocide going on and your criticism is well actually Netanyahu
is like a genocide of war criminal and it's all Netanyahu. No,
that that absolves so many people who are incredibly like it
absolves all culpability of that population.
>> What did he need to do? >> What did Ethan need
to do? Okay, hold on. Where are the Where are the other criticisms
of this? >> Oh, I need to figure out where some of the
other criticisms are of this. Oh, hold on. Somebody sent me a
clip here. Ethan has routinely criticized the Israeli government
even before he was hanging out with Assan. He was routinely criticizing
the Israeli government for their treatment of >> Palestinians.
What else do you need from >> I would need something. So
basically, I need something to show that he is still in support
of that group >> that isn't just Netanyahu is a genocidal
war criminal, right? >> Because in general, I think in
general, I feel like they have So again, I'm going off. donate
it to a char a Palestinian charity. >> Like what else do
you need? >> I I would assume some action that is like
that is condemning like all military operations in the Gaza Strip.
Something like that. >> He said he condemns the the the
military operations. No, >> I haven't seen him condemn
like broadly all military operations or but maybe he >> For
sure. Yeah, you're right. All Yes, correct. He has not condemned
all military operations because I don't believe that's condemnable.
I think when you're rocket and I think he feels the same way.
If you're shooting rockets from a [__] hospital courtyard
and [__] like that, they're you're gonna get the
[__] bombed. Yeah. >> Sorry. I haven't looked
into this stuff in a long time. My arguments were basically,
so when I watched this, it was he has the opinion that it's a
genocide, but none of his other opinions line up with somebody
who thinks there's a genocide. Like he doesn't think um any sort
of violent action from the Palestinians is like warranted, right?
Wait, that's not Wait, do you think I'm saying attacking Israeli
military members? I could have sworn that he was not that he
was not against or sorry, he's not for attacking Israeli Israeli
military members. >> So your opinion is that he has never
stated or has in no way implied that or we'll just say explicitly
stated that action against the settlers in the West Bank or the
IDF in the West Bank is >> No, I think he would say that,
>> but I think that's just to be clear. He did say I think
he would say that. Okay. So, he has justified action against
them. So, >> okay. I think that's like a totally I think
you could totally be in support of the militi
in general and say you condemn those, right? >> Maybe.
I mean, not I mean, sure, I guess kind of. Yeah. Kind of. I mean,
it depends on what kind of support you're talking about.
>> Well, I'm asking you, what kind of support are you talking
about? What are you looking for? >> What? So basically
what I was looking for is for him to
essentially complain about the state that the Gazins are living
in maybe like
30% as much as he complains about, you know, anti-semitism rising
in the West and all like the the plight of the Israelis, right?
>> If there's a genocide going on, I would just assume
that he would spend some amount of time talking about that, right?
Didn't he literally cry about Didn't he literally cry on camera
about a Palestinian
father who like held his dying child? >> Don't we literally
have footage of him on leftovers crying over this? >> Uh,
possibly. That's way before like any of this other stuff, right?
That's way before almost all of the stuff that was going on.
>> Maybe that's if that's like years ago. >> Yeah,
sorry. If that's if that's like years ago, I feel like that's
before this started. No, >> no, it's it was during the
conflict.
Sorry, I'm saying before back and forth.
>> Oh, yeah. No, that's going to be my point. My principal
point is I think that, and this is with all due respect, I think
this is a part of the gaslighting apparatus from the Hassan crew,
Ethan. And I'll tell you how I see this machine to work, and
maybe you're going to disagree with it. The reason why we have
far more footage of Ethan and Ela talking about uh uh the plight
of is uh Israeli people and people um is for two reasons. One
um when they experience anti-semitism or attacks uh based on
their uh uh them being uh uh Israeli or or the IDF membership
or whatever, it's >> it's
uh either unfounded, unjustified, or played up or exaggerated.
It's of it's almost never just like actually good criticism because
they condemn all all these various things. So the result of that
is going to be that they defend that. So they're going to spend
a lot of time defending themselves on that merit. And the second
one is that they they get a lot of heat
for saying that uh and especially from Hassan's community that
any defense of Israel in any way, shape or form is pro- genocide.
And so then they need to defend the point that being
against Israel no longer existing or like being for the existence
of Israel isn't inherently pro- genocide. And because they every
single day get attacked with these two points over and over again.
Of course, the majority of their content is going to be this.
Of course, the majority of their content is going to look like
they support Israel because every single day they get 50 messages
saying, "Hey, you hate Palestinians because you think Israel
should exist." And then they need to go through a diet tribe
about why thinking Israel existing doesn't mean you think every
single Palestinian should be strung up by the neck. So of course
>> hold on. Okay. So I agree with almost all of that. I
agree that Ethan didn't start this. I agree that Ethan was chased
around like unhingedly. Okay. I totally agree on that. I think
he started leaning back into it and I think he started getting
unhinged in reverse back at everybody sometime in the past like
six to eight months. Okay,
that's that's what I see is he was basically he is like the Palestinians.
Okay, his original grievance very valid. People went after him
for essentially no reason. But after a while he only he like
spins spends all his time going after these people. I just I
really the lawsuits, dude. The lawsuits. >> No, no, no.
I I'm I'm talking about a very specific thing. The you said he
spends so much of his time because this is literally the narrative
from like the Hassan crew. You spend 95% of your time talking
about Israel, yet you claim that you care about Palestine. He
spends 95% of his time talking about Israel because everyone
says his opinions on Israel makes him pro genocide when it doesn't.
And so therefore, he needs to explain. >> Here's here's
how. So I Oh, how do I So this is the argument in reverse. Okay,
this is the the other side's argument. So basically there's been
a genocide going on. Israel's had the intent to ethnically cleanse
Gaza since the start of this operation. And basically every time
somebody from the pro Palestine side says that says like, "Hey,
this is really up. This can't be allowed to continue. This is
crazy. This is wild. This military operation has gone way gone
way too out of hand." The response is, "What is Israel not allowed
to defend itself? What is Israel not like allowed to do anything?
What is Israel not have the right to exist?" Do you do you disagree
on that? That that is like very often the the revery we hear
from the pro-Israel people.
>> Well, I'm talking exclusively about >> Okay. Do
has Ethan not said this? Can Israel not defend itself? Does it
not have the right to exist? >> No, he he has, but I don't
believe he says this anytime somebody says that like the Palestinians
have a right to defend themselves. >> Okay. I my understanding
is basically it's like hey this is really crazy like this going
on like the military operation's bad and and Ethan gets dragged
into that right on the political points I don't know how much
Ethan um I don't know how much I disagree with like if you just
had him in a room alone I don't know how much I would disagree
with what he's saying right I don't have >> okay the whole
point of me bringing this up is you said that he just spends
a lot of time talking about Israel the reason he spends a lot
of time talking about Israel is because everybody thinks he's
progen genocide when he's not. Do you agree or disagree with
that? Israelis, the plight of Israelis and and like globally
like talking about anti-semitism. So like basically there's this
per perception of anti-semitism. He got skulls sent to his house,
right? And to me there's like probably if you think there's like
a really going on, you probably want to prioritize that as well
in in terms of your messaging, right? That like if you I don't
think there's a I don't think there's a genocide occurring. I
mean I I mean at the end of the day, no, not not super because
he's not a political streamer, but I mean a little bit. >> Okay.
Yeah, that's basically my argument is I think probably if you
think there's a genocide going on, I would see some indication
of that in your content
>> He has there is indication. You've already admitted
he said it at several different instances and he hasn't strayed
away from it. The only argument that you're making is that he
often talks about >> I'm just saying is all that there
is to >> What he donated? What else does he like? That's
the problem. You Because we already looped on this. You said
he just talks a lot and he speaks a lot about uh the Israeli
people, which is true, but he does that because everybody attacks
his position. >> Yes.
But I'm saying that as as like an aside, I would also expect
you to be talking about the like, hey, it's really stupid to
call me an anti-semite when there's a genocide going on. Like
that's what we could be focused on, right? But realistically,
um I just kind of doubt that. I think personally if your argument
was there's a genocide going on that you would just have more
of a focus on that. I think he I just think broadly his opinions
don't really track with it. >> First of all, that is a
made standard. You we should not have that is an objectively
dog standard. Hey um you just made an accusation about my opinions.
That is totally incorrect. Um what's I'm actually not going to
address any of that. I'm just going to say there's a genocide
going on.
>> You're literally telling them to do it strategy. What's
my accusation about your opinions?
>> What did you just say? >> You said you just made
an accusation about my opinions. I didn't hear what you just
said cuz I was like, wait, what are you saying? >> You
would you would expect him to react in a manner that is identical
to Assan, which is you're saying I'm pro- genocide when there's
a actual genocide going on and then move on. That is the Hassan
strategy. And that is horrible because that means he has total
immunity because he just straps dead Palestinian babies to his
chest and goes, "You think I'm pro genocide? Nope. There's a
genocide going on. Don't care. Not going to hear your criticism.
What? No. >> I don't understand what you're saying at >> I
don't I don't know how this is hard to understand.
It
ignoring criticism by saying there's a genocide going on is
>> Yes. You said when accused
of
anti-semitis or Zarya uh being
he should just say there's a genocide
and then that's it. >> I'm saying that if if there are
issues, okay, I'm saying if there are issues for him and he's
got all these people going, it's like, hey, I think a good response
would be, hey, there's genocide going on. Why are you why are
you worried about me? Right? And do some content on >> No,
that's horrible. That's the Hassan strategy.
That's horrible. >> You don't understand. You don't understand
that. You don't understand that using their position against
them is like an intelligent thing to do. >> No, it is not.
That is the That is the race to the bottom. That is the exact
opposite of what anybody >> You understand that it's like
tongue and cheek, right? That if you all agree there's a genocide
going on.
>> Yes. Like you redirect to the genocide going on, you
say, "Let's focus on that." And you do content on that.
>> No. That's a horrible thing to do when you get accused
of like uh supporting a genocide. You defend your positions.
That's what you do. You don't just go there's a genocide going
on so you can't criticize that I'm pro genocide. That is the
strategy. >> You can you can totally defend your positions.
Where's an instance where he's defended one of his positions
on
>> Can we can we get an example? >> My argument is
every single moment that he talks about Israel is the point that
he's doing it. >> Can we get an example? Yeah. The Hassan
>> So the Hassan debate, you think he seems pro-Israel
only because he's debating
>> Yes. Because he's defending his points that he's not
pro- genocide and that like he's also that Hassan has slipped
into a proterror position, which he has and he showed. >> Uh
he's slipped into a pro I think he's slipped into a position
where he has equated the terrorist to the IDF and then he feels
like there's no moral reason to call anybody out, right? which
is obviously. >> Oh, no. No. My problem is when I'm looking
for actionable steps for for Ethan to illustrate that he cares
about the people of Gaza. You gave me an example, which is I
think the worst thing he could possibly do, which is just not
take criticism and say there's a genocide going on, which is
one to one exactly what Assan does. And the reason why frankly
a lot of people hate him and including myself, it's that he just
you like the prescription is literally the meme strap strap dead
Palestinian babies to your chest and then just go well there's
a genocide going on. You can't say I'm pro genocide. >> You
understand? You understand that I'm saying that you would like
cover the content, right? You would cover the actual material
content. You would cover like, you know, Israel um setting up
the the food drops that like turn into death traps. You just
cover that, right? Go, oh, look, these people are complaining
about me again. Instead of this, I'm going to go cover that.
>> Yeah, that's still what Assan does. That's not good.
We wouldn't We don't want people where it's like, >> "Hold
on. Are the criticisms of Ethan valid or I'm just going to move
on and I'm just going to cover just really quickly. Are the criticisms
of Ethan valid or invalid?"
>> They are invalid. >> Okay. So, if he's got a bunch
of invalid criticism, is it not a better approach to go, you
know what, it's really that you're saying that, [__]
you. I'm going to go cover the the food drops that are getting
like uh like up by Israel. Uh I think it is more valid to illustrate
why these arguments are invalid. >> Okay. And then two
years later when you've been illustrating how those arguments
are invalid and you're still in the same cycle. >> Yeah.
I would say at some point you have to cut the cycle. Sure. But
the argument that he should just like because >> he was
like totally valid in all of his actions for like 6 months or
so and now I think it's like it's obviously gone way past like
>> Okay. So then your argument is that it would be valid
in that he shouldn't then
take your line of uh your line of action because now the criticisms
are valid. >> your argument now is that the criticisms
of him are valid. No. >> Uh mostly the criticisms on how
he is like like refusing to let this die, continue to go after
these people all the time. Whether or not they stop talking about
him, right? >> It's good. I mean I don't I don't I mean
they don't stop talking about him. They always make digs at him.
That always happens. But and and it's it's
your prescription I think is is a terrible prescription. Yeah.
At some point you do have to stop talking about it. But he can't
just turn into a political streamer. He's not a political streamer.
At some point he needs to just go uh I agree. Hey you think I'm
pro genocide like sucks to be you or whatever. And then just
cover I don't know relationship drama stuff with some celebrities
and stuff like that he does cover. But this idea that like this
is what he needs to show that he's pro Gaza is the exact opposite.
>> I I think just showing your that you're pro not pro
Gaza that you think there's a genocide and you support the Palestinians,
right? I think if you wanted to do that, you would do that through
your content. You would cover the stuff that Israel is doing,
>> He's not a political streamer. He streams about like
the funny teeth on Tik Tok on how Hassan is like is making really
bad arguments about Israel. Did he not spend all this time studying
for >> Yeah, he did because this Hassan weaponized this
entire audience for like over a year to just totally [__]
on this guy and character him. Of course, he's going to respond.
>> Okay. Two years, right? >> I I don't know how
long it's been, but >> it's Yeah, two years. We're coming
up on two years right away. >> Yeah, but this that's not
the way to respond to that. You're you're saying, "Hey, what?
He needs to just start covering politics now?" No, >> no.
I'm saying that if you're concerned about it being a genocide,
you're concerned about people's perception of you, you can cover
it to show, hey, here's like my actual positive position of why
I think Israel is committing a
>> He has he's done that >> because Ethan Wait, where
>> in not only inside of the debate that he actually had
with with >> Wait, what was his reasoning for thinking
Israel's committing a genocide? >> You said that the actions
that are going on in the West Bank were
uh
uh tanamount to genocide. No, he's talked about the West Bank.
The West Banks tanamounted genocide. Are you sure that wouldn't
be ethnic cleansing? >> Ethnic cleansing is a form of genocide.
>> Okay. Well, then I mean I guess then maybe I misunderstood,
but I thought ethnic cleansing was a form of >> Well, I
guess it could be. I don't know. Uh then I guess maybe >> Some
people think ethnic cleansing is that ethnic cleansing doesn't
mean >> Yeah. The West Bank's like not even a >> Well,
you don't have to kill somebody to commit genocide. >> The
West Bank. Um, you could like castrate them, but the the idea
is to >> cultural genocide and stuff like that >> Okay.
Yeah. But then I think you have to say cultural genocide and
that's a totally different thing, right? >> Yeah, I would
agree with that. Yeah. >> But e either either way, he has
stated and he has done content including with Hassan back when
leftovers was not a uh
a total failed mission, but he has done content talking about
Palestinians. He's donated to charities.
>> If you if you want to believe that he >> again
to me to me if I believe the Holocaust was happening and I was
going to go and do content constantly on people who talk about
how the Holocaust is bad, right? Then I'd probably slip in some
content to show that like, oh yeah, I still am like super against
the Holocaust. Here's like the latest thing they did in the Holocaust.
probably
if you feel like he's done that, if you feel like he's appropriately
expressed when Israel's done bad things and like talked about
it and Israel, >> I feel like this is a double standard.
Why is I feel like this is a double standard. Why can Assan say
once that he
doesn't support the attacking of civilians, but in like n 90%
of his coverage, he does the opposite.
But Ethan has in 90% of his coverage he attacking of civilians.
Just you're going to stand on that. Then in 90% of his coverage
Han avows the attacking of Israeli civilians.
>> you just said in 90% of his coverage, Hassan avows attacking
Israeli >> Yeah, absolutely. Yeah. Because he kidnapping
when it comes to the kidnapping for the who they use when it
comes to literally his coverage post October 7th. 90% of Hassan's
coverage says yeah, what did either not bad or good? Yes.
>> Okay. Okay. >> You disagree with that? I I disagree
that either of us have actually watched enough his coverage to
make a to make a real statement on that. I think we've both seen
the same clips and I think you haven't seen like counter clips
for that and you're making your assertion off of clips only.
I think everybody here
coverage on Israel Palestine is him saying that he avows the
attacking of civilians. I think that's wild. Or like anytime
he talks about October 7th, he avows the attacks of civilians.
That's >> I can give you endless opportunities when confronted
point blank.
Is this kidnapping of civilians? Is these raps bad? And he either
refuses to answer or says it's okay. >> Okay, give me the
clips where he asks where he's asked are bad and he says it's
okay.
>> Okay, not the the for the I don't think he says it's
okay. But >> we're just making up, dude. I don't know what
the I don't know. >> Wait, wait, wait. To be clear, I gave
two examples and I said either one of these things. For the kidnapping,
he says it's okay. It's justified. And for the he says, "Oh,
I don't know anything about that." Or just refuses and moves
on. I gave you two separate examples. It's not that I'm making
up. Don't pull that [__] If you want to go debate
row, I can hard debate bro you, but let's not do that. Obviously,
I give you two different examples. I'm talking about two separate
examples.
>> I'm swear to God, I'm having fun. Why don't people come
on to talk anymore? Why can't we just yell at each other all
the time? Um, I do kind of >> I don't think I don't think
that is very fun. You know exactly what I mean and you're just
trying to >> I don't know. I actually don't know exactly
what you mean here. I'm I'm literally like listening to the things
you say. >> He says things like what? >> Yes. Okay.
I know what he says. What? That's not saying are good, right?
I think to me, okay, you're going to steal man that. How would
you steal man that? Cuz I know how I'd steal man. How would you
steal man that comment? So, just to be clear, when I'm saying
that they're okay or justifying them or any of these different
things, that includes a streamer in front of 40,000 people not
recognizing that something that objectively happened, not recognizing
that it happened. That's what I'm saying. That is the same thing.
That is that is saying something that's the same
or I can agree that you don't operate that way. That's okay.
But me mel
that something happened is saying that it's okay. Assad is bad.
Assan is bad. Um,
yeah, sure, sure, sure, sure. Uh, I don't I don't know if I agree
on that. Maybe. Um, >> no, because he knows they have >> Wait,
wait, just to be clear, when Hassan is talking about the when
Hassan is confronted with the in front of Ethan, to your knowledge,
this is going to be very revealing. Does Hassan know the happened?
Yes or no? >> Does he know that have happened? Yes, he
would know that would have happened >> on October 7th and
after October 7th. Does he know that they happened? uh he knows
happened on October 7th for sure and he knows about the one testimony
at minimum of somebody who said they witness in captivity. >> Okay,
we can just operate off of that even still
then why when confronted by Ethan does he refuse to condemn them
unless he's okay with it. >> So he says I refu So Ethan
says will you condemn the and he just he says I I won't condemn
the >> he just doesn't condemn them. He just tries to to
move on talking about how there isn't evidence that there's evidence
in these cases. He talks about how there isn't evidence inside
of these cases. Yeah. >> Is it possible that he doesn't
feel like Ethan's operating like not asking this question like
Ethan's trying to get him to like I don't know call himself a
that he just wants to move on? Do you think that's not possible?
You think it's more likely that he totally avows these >> what
what I'm sorry. Do do I feel like it's more likely what >> I
don't remember the debate. I don't remember the Hassan. >> If
you want to ask what Hassan is trying to do, Hassan is trying
to save face. he objectively is. If you disagree, you're and
I don't trust you as a human being. >> So, I agree that
he's trying to stay I agree with you that he's trying to stay
trying to stay the only disagreeing.
>> Uh gen chat's not muted. You can sign up for the Patreon.
It's just locked to Patreon subs. Um
now,
uh sorry, I just lost it cuz I answered a question. >> If
you are somebody who
I'll say 35, he is objectively trying to save face. That is it.
That is the only thing he's trying to do. trying to save face
100%.
>> Yes. 100%. >> But what is the motive for refusing
to condemn the motive for saving face that he avows rap of civilians
or is the motive for saving face that he doesn't want to admit
to things that he doesn't know happened? For sure, right? That
is he trying to say like I don't know like
systemic racism. >> Is it of your opinion that Hassan has
just never read a single article about how there were on October
7th? It's of my opinion that he believes that Z squirrels
propaganda on this 100%. >> No, no, no.
>> Like I think there's no way you can read that UN report
on violence on October 7th and believe that assaults didn't occur,
that multiple sexual assaults didn't occur, that you would even
that you would fail to even call it mass assault like mass.
>> It's flippy floppy because in your own statement you
say that he has recognized rapes have happened on October 7th.
You have said this, right? >> Sure. before. Okay. So then
why wouldn't he admit it in front of him when we've already established
yes saving face but after that he we know he knows happened on
October 7th. So he is intentionally trying to withhold it from
with what >> I don't know. So I'd have to watch the clip.
I would imagine if it's like will you disavow the will you dis
I assume if that's how the clip is going then I I would understand
how you might be like hesitant to just like give that person
what they want. I understand the hesitancy. You shouldn't be
hesitant, right? I would just wonder what his >> when somebody
who when somebody when somebody who knows that the rape happened
refuses to condemn it because they want to save face. Are they
not
>> Let's just finish watching the clip. >> Okay.
I Hold on. I need to ask you. You have time to finish watching
the clip and then we have to go back and finish >> What
is this clip? Is this from the >> Yes, this is from the
debate. Yeah. >> And then we have to go back and finish
watching the actual thing. We have to finish going through the
notepad with the actual points and through what Hassan's saying
because we've totally switched onto a different like a totally
different um >> argument now, >> right? Like we're
having a totally different argument Ethan that I don't really
I'm not really prepared for. I don't really care about >> and
I do want to go back to this >> argument you were making
because you said a part of your argument was uh uh Ethan calling
Hassan
a and so you're you're making an argument that with that in mind
he's just like looking to get a jab and like that. My my arguments
are isolated um to exclusively Hassan's content as a whole and
Hassan's statement in this context. >> Wait, he is Wait,
we both agree he's trying to get a jab. >> Yes, but your
your convers your point had to do with like Ethan calling him
a or something that this was >> that he's trying to get
a jab because these guys are going like hard on him still. Yeah,
100%. >> All right, you can go ahead. >> Okay, we
can watch this stuff. I'm just going to grab some water. I don't
know if you do. You need a minute to grab like water or something
too if we're going to go over these last two. >> I have
water next to me. >> You good? Okay. Give me a second.
>> You put on me. >> I sure did. >> There is
one
instance in captivity
that we have actually gotten verifiable evidence on. Beyond that,
the the systematized mass rapid
deal built on October 7, not a single bit of that has been verified
and people still roam with it over and over. >> Okay. Do
you disagree with that point that not a that systematized rap
mass rap has not been uh that there's no evidence of that? Do
you >> depends on what you categorize as systematized or
mass? >> Okay. So there's evidence that
leadership and as a organization didn't care about their
>> So we don't consider this clip denial >> No, I
would I would say it is because there's there's one he says there's
one case of rape that happened that we know of in captivity.
So he's not even talking about mass systematized. He's talking
about uh even singular instances of this and there isn't just
one. There's multiple. So he's separating between captured people
>> in the UN report. In the UN report
sure sure in captivity means of of captured people like once
they're taken back into government. >> Yes. In the UN report
it's let me finish my sentence. In the UN report, it states that
there's overwhelming evidence or or uh clear and convincing evidence
that rape is currently and sex violence is currently happening
or or was happening post capt uh hostage taking post October
7th in captivity of uh adults and children. So at least if you
read the UN >> the UN report I read I feel like I don't
I'm 99% sure it's the same one. People just didn't read that
part. I'm like 99% sure it's the same one. Unless >> sounds
like there's four reports now. I don't know when this clip was
and how many reports were out then. >> The UN report in
question was 100% out. I believe I specifically read the UN report
in response to this. >> There are four reports. Do you
want the link? Oh, there are four UN reports. I'm talking about
the first one that the Zcroll person misrepresents.
>> Yes, that one. Yes, that one. It is in there. We can
go through it right now if you like. Uh, I mean I I guess I believe
>> I can just read this actually. >> I just don't
recall it. Yeah. Yeah. Here. Well, hold on. I'm going to hit
play. I walked I walked back just to ask what you thought about
the mass systematized thing. Okay. One second. >> And over
again. >> Many young people who were simply
attending a music festival.
Women were >> I can't see myself by the way if you're showing
my reaction. >> You're giggling. You're giggling. It's
so funny. >> No, I'm not giggling.
Bro, what did what are you talking
>> Anti-semitism account that considered me to be anti-semite
of the week has also been hallucinating once again doing rap
fantasies once again because they're [__] mentally
ill. >> You know that that's something you go to a lot.
You notice that? >> Call people mentally ill. >> Find
that odd. Probably should revise that. I don't know if that's
kosher for leftist values.
you know, I'm not exactly doing a lot of stuff. That's kosher
for leftist values in general. >> Okay. So you so you have
no problem uh weaponizing mental health. >> Yeah. When
someone is hallucinating, I think I it's appropriate to say that
>> by your authority, I will decide who's hallucinating.
Hassan
>> girl horrific act sexual violence
>> and took I am so sorry. You promised that we would watch
this. I pulled it. Sit silently and enjoy. >> I got the
point. You're saying that like you're showing clips of meual.
You're showing clips of me saying
women and girls, men and boys slaughtered
after enduring violence,
the deadliest day of the for the people. >> Doesn't matter
if [__] happened on October 7. Like that doesn't
change the dynamic for me even this much.
So that's the other part of this problem that many people can't
contend with.
>> uh that clip is not anywhere near as bad as what people
say. >> I can't believe how quickly left >> Oh, also
I'm back. What's up? Do we want to stop on any of these clips?
Cuz to me, the worst one by far and the only one that really
stands out to me is the what happened on uh sorry, what that's
the one clips or these clips in isolation. They build a greater
context for his work. >> A lot of these clips are taken
totally out of context. This clip specifically with the Terren
Howard thing. He's he's I don't think you disagree with the sentiment
there whatsoever. >> Uh okay. I didn't look into that one.
What is he saying? Uh he's saying that like even if happened
from it doesn't change my view of the genocide one iota which
I think is just like a actual
>> hold on I'm trying to really be good faith here. He
can say things that if you or me said them we can be reasonable
about where they're coming from and even that it's not like uh
uh
for progenocide or anything like that. but in the greater context
paints not only his uh content but also his other statements
in a pro- genocide or cover up fashion. He he can do that. So
like in that that context where it's like it doesn't I don't
m I I don't care. I wait I don't understand how you can have
this double standard. So for Ethan, he can say that uh uh
Netanyahu is a genocidal war criminal who should belong in prison.
But I can't say is proter terrorist, proter terrorism. Even though
on record he has clips like oh what did in all these various
different clips
there's like no evidence of him saying
committed horrible acts of October 7th that was widespread. I
condemn him from top to bottom. I think I think leadership should
be there is no such clip that exists of Hassan.
>> Can we just go through those point by >> My god.
>> Sure. So the the one where he's proterm it's like I
do think he's proter terrorism but terrorism is like a subjective
label right like is there any do you do you not agree that Ethan
would consider the IDF terrorist a terrorist >> I think
he said that it is in the debate he said it was. So basically
it's you could be a lot of people are pro IDF terrorism or pro
antiIDF terrorism. Why why is Assan significantly different from
those people? Like anybody that is avowing like Israeli attacks
on Gaza.
>> He never condemns. >> Okay. Lots of people don't
disavow Israeli operations into the West Bank. I'm not saying
I'm just saying in >> He condemns Israel. Ethan condemns
>> Sure. So why are you saying there's insufficient like
there's you're it feels like this is a double standard. I'm having
to prove that I'm telling you that Hassan is not pro Palestinian
is pro Palestinian enough and you're telling me I literally said
this doesn't refer to Ethan.
>> I literally said I wasn't referring to Ethan right now.
>> But for me telling you Assan is like this. It's like
it's insane. >> Okay. I'm telling you how Hassan like built
this position, right? Is that he thinks the IDF is a terrorist
organization and anybody who's resisting that terrorist organization
is justified, right? It would be like if you went into Iran or
sorry, Iraq during the Iraq civil war, right? And you supported
some militias group that was on your side because they resisted
ISIS, right? It's like probably that militia group is like evil,
but realistically it's the only thing there, right? >> The
claim that the double standard claim I'm making. >> I'm
just talking about why. So, I'm saying I agree with you that
he's pro terrorism. I'm explaining to you why he's proterm about
the double standard. I'm not saying there's not I'm not saying
there's a double standard. I'm saying that I agree with you that
he's proterism. I'm explaining to you why he's pro terrorism.
>> So, my point is that I don't feel like Ethan Klein should
be jumping through all of these different hoops, right, to be
able to justify these these things. And yet, we're going through
this VOD so I can say to you that Hassan is proterm. If you think
Assan is proter terrorism, why are we even here? >> Because
I just Why are we watching this? Why are we watching this VOD?
>> You just aren't listening to me. I just explained to
you why being proterism might not be a bad thing in in Hassan's
world because we're investigating your claims on the radio. >> I
don't give a am I talking to Hassan? Is your name Hassan Abby?
>> Okay. So, I'm not talking to Hassan. I'm talking to
Jtock. I don't give a if he thinks it's not a bad thing. I know
he doesn't think it's a bad thing. >> I'm talking to you,
man. What the I'm talking to you. Are we not talking about like
what has how Hassan operates in the world? I think that there's
some argument that if there's an organization that is
operating as a terrorist organization but is also a part of a
state that I don't necessarily think the terrorist organizations
around that state are like the significantly worse moral actors
in some cases. I do believe that the Israeli government actually
abducts and and kidnaps like basically civilians from the Palestinian
population then lets them go as they see fit. Right? Like basically
the argument is in terms of the relative in terms of the relative
morality in those locations there's not a significant difference
between supporting the Houthis and supporting Israel. That's
like Hassan's argument, right?
>> Okay. Do you think that's totally without merit? >> Yes,
I believe it is totally without merit. The Houthis versus Israel
are entirely different entities. Yes. Because Israel has people
>> Yes. But Israel has entirely innocent people and even
anti-war people in it. The Houthies do not because they're a
militant group. If you want to talk about the people in Yemen,
I could maybe agree with that. Yeah. >> Say that again.
Sorry. Say that again. Say that again. Say the whole thing. I
I totally didn't understand what you're >> Okay. The Houthies
are a militant group. It is fair to say every single person in
there is a military uh like operative in some
IDF. >> You cannot say the same for Israel. >> So
just switch it to the IDF. >> you can switch it to the
IDF. Yeah. Uh I still I still don't think it's one to one because
they aren't capturing vessels that and taking hostages of international
uh individuals and stuff like that. They most of the lines are
relegated exclusively to that specific
>> Do you think Israel wouldn't do that if they felt like
um those people were supporting
um like like the Houthies? Like if one of those ships was delivering
weapons to the Houthies, you don't think Israel would do that?
I think I think they probably would, but the Houthies don't exclusively
take vessels that are aiding Israel. >> Uh, but that's
their claim. I don't I think they don't damage vessels that are
like supposedly not aiding Israel, >> but they still take
hostages, which is the important. I don't give a about damaging
the vessels. I care about
>> Okay. Yeah, I would agree with you >> right? We
would both care only about hostages, right? I I mean, I don't
care if you >> The point is the point is the IDF does the
same. >> The point is the IDF basically does similar things,
right? Do they do they capture innocent civilians because in
in this when they have no connection to no connection to Yemen
or Yemen? >> No, but tenuous connections. I would not say
no connection. >> What? Can you give me an example? >> Say
tenuous. >> Um, off the top of my head, no. But I believe
like so I haven't done a ton of digging into these, but I do
believe this is broadly accepted that like like because and again
this I think Loner Box's argument is like well here's the difference.
This is the difference between the Houthies and somebody else,
okay? is that you know that Israel does do things like this.
You know that Israel does actually take um you know take people
prisoner when they shouldn't because they have their own regulatory
bodies. They actually have their own oversight, right? That is
the thing that makes Israel better than uh the actual terrorist
organizations is they'll report on themselves.
>> I agree with that.
>> So I think that's probably where you get to. But it's
not that like they don't do the same things. It's not that they
don't get into the same that they don't make like really evil
decisions. It's not that they don't do like really things. It's
that they have their own oversight. Uh, and so they will eventually
hopefully figure that stuff >> Okay. So, I I also I I found
the the excerpt from the UN article that for some reason uh none
of those mouth breathers could ever read. Um, and so I just have
the excerpt. This isn't for you. This is to prove that they didn't
read it. Okay. People like Assan didn't read it. So, the mission
team reviews incident of alleged violence related to hostages
in Gaza based on the firstand accounts of released hostages.
The mission team has clear and convincing information that violence,
including rape, torture, and cruel, inhumane, degrading treatment,
occurred against some women and children during their time in
cap captivity, and has reasonable grounds to believe that this
violence may be ongoing.
>> Period. So just to make it in that statement alone there
is more than one person including children
that it has clear and convincing evidence of and it has the standards
laid out and clear and convincing is not the highest standard
but it's a significant standard right and so they just didn't
read this. >> Okay.
So I
>> so but to be clear the reason why this is relevant is
because they claim to have read it. They claim to have read it
and then so when uh somebody like Ethan is referencing excerpts
from it, they're like, "Hey, why aren't you guys recognizing
some of the things that literally exist in this document?"
And Hassan is saying, "There's only one instance of this happening
in captivity." When if you just read it, they're just definitionally
on women and children, there is more than one. Let alone that
when they say women, they might mean more than one
woman. They might mean more than one. And when they say children,
they might they might mean more than one child. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Sorry, I'm just I'm pulling this up on stream for
myself as
>> Yeah. I just read that bar for bar. >> Okay. Based
on first down accounts of released hostages, there are reasonable
grounds to believe that female hostages were also subjected to
other forms of sexual violence. So, oh, hold on. Is the issue
here that the mission team received clear and convincing information
that sexual violence including torture and cruel inhuman and
degrading treatment occurred against some women and children
during their time in captivity and has reasonable grounds to
believe that this violence may be ongoing.
>> this is the same UN report that all of these mouth breathers
said that they read. This is the same exact one. >> So
I would say the argument they make which is a horrible argument
is uh based on the evidence, right? Like what evidence was provided?
Oh, right. Based on first. >> I mean, and and and Ethan
gets Ethan gets into it and just says, "Yeah, it's just a frat,
bro." Hassan's just like a frat, bro. It just is what it is.
Women cannot testify firsthand. It can't be that. They need photos,
which by the way, if you also read this, there is photo evidence
that they're using to come to that specific conclusion. As you
read, they if you read uh up in the details of how they came
to it, they actually do have photos. Now whether or not it's
photos of the explicit acts, it doesn't go into vivid detail,
but it says ex they have photos to be able to come to those conclusions.
So there is evidence around that, including like photos and stuff,
but yeah, this is where Ethan makes fun of them for having that.
Yeah. >> Okay. All right. Somebody said go to 86 where
it says that the uh the magnitude and scope couldn't be established
and require a larger investigation. >> This means literally
nothing.
This was obviously used by Assan's brain. It means literally
something, but it doesn't mean what they're suggesting, >> It
It doesn't mean anything. It It means literally nothing. That
to be clear, it could be that every single soldier raped somebody
or it could be that only just a couple did that they were able
to verify. That's all that means. It It's literally nothing.
It's we don't know. That is all that means. >> What changes
in the follow-up reports? I would just want to know what changes.
>> No, no. The the reason why I'm pointing to this and
the reason why Ethan and stuff did isn't because this is objective
proof of the underlying facts of the matter. The point is that
people like Hassan will point to this article and they explicitly
will point towards like 86 and they will leave out the rest of
the details. For instance, Noah Samson notoriously did this in
his video where he went through this document and highlighted
specifically 86, right? and that and didn't highlight any of
the other that for instance we spoke about or looked at. I think
the thing that actually upsets me about this is that people talk
about the October 7th attacks like the stuff that happened, right?
Um and they'll say that there's not there's not like any evidence
of this and there there absolutely is. JS
of it >> that's the issue where it becomes malicious. No,
this is malicious. This is a malicious attempt to cover up rapes,
is it not? >> These people have read the documents
>> Yes. uh from Hassan. I don't >> but even like
Hassan, he says he's read >> I think Hassan has an insane
bar because of his distrust for the Israeli state. I think um
I think Lonerbox cooked him completely when he's like, "Oh, well,
we don't have forensic evidence." And it's like, "You're not
going to get forensic evidence of this retard." Like, they're
they're dead people from a like an atrocity. Like, of course,
you wouldn't get forensic evidence
people of an atrocity. How do we not How can we not say it's
malicious when when Ethan is literally showing him articles right
in front of his face when he says he's read articles that say
or the UN report that explicitly say >> I think it would
be >> good to continue going through it cuz I agree with
you totally on the UN report that it says that there's multiple
instances in captivity. So it is weird that he said there's only
one instance in captivity. Now I don't know when that from it's
not weird. It's not weird. Stop. It's not weird. We know why
he's doing it. Stop. It's not weird. I feel like I I'm I'm I'm
having to literally smack your face into a brick wall, man. It's
not weird. It's not weird. It is very obvious what he's doing.
>> Okay. I'm just going to go through like this stuff as
we go. >> I'm I'm We're going back and forth. >> I'm
not getting like emotional here. I'm just going to go through
this like step >> step. You're not getting You're not getting
emotional because you're I'm not being the one that's I'm not
the one who's being frustrating here. I'm having to smack your
head into the wall 100 times to get you to understand this dude
is maliciously
maliciously
trying to cover up that are happening so he can save face.
>> I'm literally just I'm just going to walk through this.
I I'm telling you I didn't I don't remember watching this part
of the debate. So I'm going to walk through this. I need to see
this for myself. It's really nice that you can say well no I
know that he's being absolutely malicious here. I'm gonna actually
just walk through this and we can go through it calmly or we
could freak the out. Either one, but I was thinking calmly might
be a good way to go about it. >> No, I I I'm talking about
>> I don't think we've proven out a systemic issue yet.
I do not think from a base level we've proven out a systemic
issue and I'm good with walking through it with you.
>> We're not here to prove that it was a systemic that
happened. We're here to prove that when he says he's read stuff
like this, that means he's lying. He's either lying that he read
it or he's lying about the conclusions that yet. I haven't seen
him deny the conclusions of it. I haven't seen either of those
things happen yet. >> So, you're saying you've never seen
him say that he's read the UN article that Ethan specifically
>> Yes. I'm saying I've never seen him say he's read the
UN article or if I have, I don't remember it. I have seen him
say what do I have seen him downplay some of the things that
I think we all assume did happen, right? I've seen those things,
but I don't know that I've seen that he's read the UN report,
him saying that, and then directly after seeing him read the
UN report or directly after seeing that clip, seeing him say,
"Oh, I deny the violence." and then how he reacts to it in the
debate. That's what I'm trying to get if we can walk to >> Sure.
I'm not sure if it's in this section or later, but go to the
part where he starts showing him articles right in front of his
face. I don't know if this is the part I'm not talking >> I
think we got the whole with the whole section. Okay. >> I'm
not I'm not going to sit here for an hour and watch all myations
narratives. And also here is um the Israeli prosecutor Morang
gets acknowledged that 15 months after the events of October,
forensics evidence to actually
the answer to that clue. I do I do deny good. Well, there you
go. >> There is >> Oh, what is he deny happened and
you're doing it right now. of >> Yeah, I've definitely
seen this as well, Alibaba, which is my belief of like where
he got this information from is this this stupid ass Zcirrel
tweet and that's what he was basing a lot of off of and that's
why he looked like a total when he said like oh what do >> violence
and I just showed you up until this point just showed you and
I both agree on you know that agree with that you know that I've
talked about it you know that I've acknowled
that happened
>> you deny that mass rap happened. Not that happened.
Listen to >> Okay. So Ethan's position is Hassan denied
mass rap not.
>> Yes. But then he goes
to he goes in he goes into individual you've represented it to
me that way. >> Okay. That's fine. I I frankly it's not
a big deal. If you keep watching all of this, he brings up that
happened right in front of him and he keeps refusing
>> Keep playing. >> We'll we'll keep watching >> to
my words. I'm just saying that like
I do I do good. Well, there you go. There is no there is no evidence
and for the show the clips that you used ironically enough there
context is because at that point at that point
>> I think maybe skipped over some of the some of the things
but I I think he shows more. I'm not sure if this pops up
>> well I'm not sure if it pops up on screen. I was told
that >> this is this is the >> this is the UN article.
>> This is the UN article >> report, right? This
is the one everyone refers to. >> I was told this one doesn't
bring them all up on screen.
>> How these Oh, I see. >> papers work. They do a
a ve like a very precise conclusion at the end that summarizes
the main um thesis and points driven home in the article. That's
what the conclusion is. Let me read it for you.
Overall, based on the totality of information gathered from multiple
and independent sources at different locations, there are reasonable
grounds to believe that conflict related lines occurred at several
locations across the Gaza periphery, including in the form of
gang during >> Do we believe Hassan denies this right after
having it read to him? Is this where he would deny these things
>> Believe he obiscates. >> Okay. the October 7th,
2023 attack. Credible circumstantial information which may be
indicative of some forms of violence, including genital mutilation,
torture, cruel, inhuman, and degrading treatment was also gathered.
>> Okay, perfect. Thank you. So, I'm going to I'm going
to walk you through this real quick. >> Are they hallucinating?
>> No. So, do you No, you just don't know what words mean.
So, credible circumstantial evidence. Do you know what that means?
>> It means that there's Yeah, of course. Credible circumstantial
evidence is not a substitute for forensic evidence. Credible
circumstantial
evidence is not enough to happen for one second. Do we agree
on what point he'sating? We agree he'sating, right? >> I
think he's like totally [__] And if he just read
the conclusion, not the whole article, then that would explain
everything. So, if he said he's read this whole article somewhere,
then he's lying because the credible forensic evidence is bodies
that have their their hands tied behind their back and their
>> he's spoken about before specifically spoken about that
before on stream. I I don't I don't Wait, hold on. Can I can
I make this statement because even if I can't find you
where he's reading it himself, you understand for him to comment
on these issues without reading the article that he's been bashed
with over a hundred times about the on October 7th that he that
would have to be malicious in and of itself, right?
>> Um I might as well call it malicious. Yes. If he's going
to deny that there's evidence, credible evidence of on October
7th, then and and he hasn't read the report at all, he doesn't
know what the actual evidence is because this is what Ethan should
be cooking them on here, then I would agree that that's probably
malicious. Like, I would think >> I mean, it's malicious
or >> So, if he hasn't read it, he's malicious. And if
he has read it, he's malicious, just to be clear.
>> If he h >> Yeah, sure. I mean, unless So, he's
going to make this point here. Hold on, hold on, hold on. He's
going to make this point here and Ethan needs to bring up this
evidence. So, he's saying circumstantial evidence. Ethan needs
to drive this home right now. >> No, he No, he No, he doesn't.
No, he >> I would expect him to >> because he's being
a frat bro. He's literally being a frat bro.
Pixar, it didn't happen. Ethan is right. >> I'm going to
ask you. >> Ethan is literally right. >> Wait, how?
Wait, how is that not Pixar it didn't happen? >> Did Israel
lie or not about certain atrocities that happened on October
7th in the immediate aftermath? Did Israel lie and push the narrative?
Is Israel the UN? >> So, is there a reason that Hassan
might >> No. No. Is Israel the UN? Is Israel the >> Where
did the UN get the reports from? Where did the UN get their their
firsthand witnesses from? Where did the UN get the evidence from?
Who collected the evidence? >> Do you believe that the
UN literally just believed everything Israel said? >> I
believe they would have done their own interviews, but I think
that there's a >> They did their own interviews. They did
their own investigation. >> I'll just I'll just for you
really quickly. Just let me I'm going to differentiate between
my position, Hassan's position. Hassan might have a bar of forensic
evidence because he hates Israel. He hates the state, right?
He doesn't trust them. He's got a a memory of all the times they've
lied. He doesn't trust it. Right? I trust the UN report, but
I'm telling you that I understand why he would say something
like forensic evidence. I don't necessarily know that the rises
to malicious yet. I would like to see if he could be pushed on
the evidence at all. comes from a lack of understanding of the
UN report. The UN doesn't just walk up to Israel and just go,
"Hey, do you have like pictures and testimony and stuff? They
do a lot of that stuff operationally themselves." In the report
itself, it states pretty plainly they didn't have all of the
tools necessary to set up the full scope and magnitude necessary
for like a full-blown operation. That is why 86 exists. That
is why 86 exists where it says, "Hey, we cannot establish the
prevalence." It explicitly details the reason they can't establish
the prevalence is because of a limited uh limited access to bodies
and stuff like that. But the scope the scope >> from the
families
>> from the families.
The families,
>> bro, you're doing it with me. You have. Have you read
it? Have you read it? >> Have I read the whole report?
>> Have you read it? Have you read it? Have you read the
report?
>> Okay. I have. And you're doing it. You're You're here
doing it with me. You're talking about like, hey, who's limiting
all the question? And I'm telling you, I'm making you like you
can tell you're lying to me.
>> am I telling you? You're lying to me. >> No, the
problem is you're saying like you're saying like Israel's you're
implying that Israel is limiting it. I'm telling you there is
limitations on this for the prevalence of stuff. And it's not
just Israel. It's not like the UN walks in and just goes, "Hey,
Israel, we'll just accept all of this information from you."
explicitly in the UN, it says Israel was giving them uh in that
report, it says Israel was giving them specific information that
they couldn't verify. And it says Israel gave us this information
we cannot verify. They don't just take them at their word.
>> I wouldn't think they just take them at their word.
>> Okay. But I'm telling you, Hassan knows they don't take
them at their word. And so when you say, "Well, maybe Hassan
thinks they're taking them at their word." He doesn't believe
that. He knows that's not the case. He's being >> Asan
almost certainly does not trust the Israeli government for anything
they provide here. >> This is the UN. >> Okay,
we're just going to go through this loop again. The UN would
check other sources, right? But I believe if they had credible
information from Israel, what they believe to be credible information,
which Hassan wouldn't trust, they would publish that. So I'm
saying, can we differentiate between these, right? Based on what's
in the >> Can we differentiate what evidence for which
areas like comes from the is comes from Israel, comes from first
party testimony, comes from all these things. just I just told
you they explicitly say they were given some information
in sources and then they were able to to look at certain sources
themselves with clear and convincing or or uh reasonable uh uh
suspicion in these they have their >> which one of those
did they get like reasonable suspicion from that's like independent
of Israel what which one of these did they have that's free from
suspicion so we can go read it >> the one that I gave you
the one that I specifically said where children were in captiv
captivity were insulted. They had videos and or sorry pictures
picture evidence of you can look up photos. >> The absence
of comprehensive forensic evidence limited the mission teams.
Would it be something like this? >> Uh I'm not sure if
this is a specific paragraph, but maybe. >> The absence
of comprehensive forensic evidence limited the mission team's
ability to draw definitive forensic conclusions. In many instances,
this was compounded by evidence being spread among various agencies
and limited organization of the material. And the fact that the
process of linking individuals with specific photos and video
is still ongoing. The inaccurate and unreliable forensic interpretations
by some non-professionals also represented a challenge. Uh lastly,
the mission took place over a limited period of two and a half
weeks and in the a context for Israel where no dedicated UN count
team or infrastructure is operational. Considering the scale
and magnitude of the attacks, the range of the locations and
the high number of casualties, the mission team could not comprehensive
comprehensively cover the full range of the situation. Uh it's
the one I sent to you. It's specifically and explicitly about
the systemized order on OC on October 7th. Well, I'm saying Hassan
would deny that. Yes, I understand. Hassan would deny that. Is
that what they're going over right now? Wait, hold on. I don't
Oh, >> they're going over this. They're going over this.
>> My wand. I'm on a different account. Hold on. I don't
even have you. If you're not in my Discord, discord.gg/jk,
you have to go put it in. My main account's banned. If you're
sending me stuff on Discord, I do not get it. Okay.
videos the team
based on other findings not linked to specific locations. So
71 clear and convincing information. So this says based on first
hound accounts of the released hostages for this one. >> It
doesn't say >> you're going to say that they're like
>> spies or something. >> Photos and videos. I don't
see photos and videos on this one. >> I just you you'd
have to go through you just passed like nine different meions
of it. You can see there is photos. I did. Sorry, but this is
the only one I can find with women and children. Um, it's fine.
I
We'll just take your word for it that that is one of them where
they have like independent photos and videos and and all this.
>> Wait, wait, go back. >> I think it literally says
it right there. The mission team also gathered and reviewed information
based on photos and videos of October 7th attack that could not
be linked to specific locations of the attack. The mission team
was able to determine at least 100 bodies had disrupted burn
damages, preventing the findings of anything uh what may have
occurred to including the uh any assessment of sexual violence.
But it states earlier in prior to these conclusions that these
were the same bodies that were referenced with like their [__]
parents. Um I mean you go >> I do agree on that. I do agree
probably that that would have happened. Yeah, I would agree.
Okay. >> But they saw bodies. They they firsthand saw bodies.
>> Yeah. I like I totally believe all of their invest in
investigations of the actual kabutzas like I believe that there
were victims of sexual violence in those kabutzas. 100%. >> Okay.
But that wasn't isn't this whole argument as to whether or not
all of this or even the
principal evidence needed to be able to come to these conclusions
stemmed from the Israeli government. >> I would say no.
No. I in Hassan's mind he's going to say that they would have
talked to the hostages, right? but he's gonna want to believe
that. So, it's not a good it's like it's >> it doesn't
matter if it's in Hassan's mind. What I'm saying is that this
is a uh this is very obviously like uh uh him if he read this,
he had to he had to specifically ignore like their standards,
their firstand account and stuff like this. >> This is
not the only report. So I believe her father has said that there
is no like firsthand testimony of people who are
>> I believe he has said that because I know Den has said
that >> I know Dennis said this >> I don't know I
I don't know. All right, let's keep >> which is precisely
the reason why the Israeli prosecutors themselves have said that
in the absence of a singular victim coming out and also with
all of the forensic evidence that has been >> wait I totally
agree on the the Hassan like here where he needs to where he's
trying to say that there's no forensic evidence there just wouldn't
be forensic evidence right >> tarnished already >> show
me evidence for anything you're >> what right so isn't
isn't that the the argument the argument that He he has an impossible
standard and he's talking about there is no nobody who comes
forward and to my knowledge he has uh >> so I'm listening
to all of the other things I I totally have always agreed with
the impossible standard point. I've never once disagreed that
that's like a >> Okay. Well then what are you looking >> I'm
going to follow up on the statements you made about what Hassan
was saying where he openly denied to Ethan's face. Like having
the different standard is not saying >> deny rape to his
face.
>> Having the different standard is saying it's inconclusive.
It's not saying it didn't happen. I think that's evidence. >> When
presented with when presented with evidence, when presented with
like a source that he has trusted before multiple different times,
including on Israel's actions against the Palestinians, he's
saying
that sexual violence, there's no evidence, right? Him saying
there's no forensic evidence, that's not denying the >> He's
saying he doesn't He's saying he doesn't believe it without forensic
evidence, which is insane. Yes. But I don't think it's denying
them. No, I think he's saying that like we would need more evidence.
I would want prosecutions to happen. I think he is
agreeing. Deny is the wrong word, but I feel like the same thing
you do. I'm just telling you. Just hold on a second. I'm just
telling you denying is the wrong word, but I probably feel the
same thing you do, which is like I think this is like insane.
And clearly he just doesn't want to admit. >> The reason
why I believe it's denying is because I know he knows what he's
doing.
way. Nah, there's there's no way. There's no way. There's no
way. It just can't be. So I'm I'm again >> so he only does
this so he only does this for this specific part. >> No,
no, no. This part I totally agree with you. He is downplaying
here, right? But we went beyond that and it's like well he obviously
denies any happened. There are multiple claims here. I was just
investigating your actual claims. I should have written them
down and now I didn't. But I've totally always agreed when I
read this or when I watched this in the first place. I totally
agree that if you're asking for forensic evidence, if you need
kits, you're [__] insane.
No, it's not just that he's insane when presented with these
situations where did happen. He's denying. He's saying like,
"Yeah, no, I mean there is no forensic evidence." No, whatever.
When these same standards he uses in other circumstances, that
is denial to me. Is that not denial to you? When the same standards
he uses to be able to corroborate other instances of sex violence,
he just conveniently doesn't do it for this one. He just happens
to not be doing it for this one. It's just >> No, I think
this one involves the Israeli state. I think that's where his
that's where his anger comes from,
>> Where are you getting that? >> Where am I getting
from from? Obviously in here there would be testimony or evidence
from Israel. Israel would have had Would they have gotten these
photos themselves? Would they have gone to all these places and
taken the photos themselves? I believe they say they didn't do
that. I'm assuming they got photos from Israel, right? There
were some photos. There were some photos from Israel and there
were some photos from like on uh like the like floating around
online, but they also literally visited some of these places,
had the personal accounts interviews, and they saw dead bodies.
So the mission team, specifically the forensic pathologists and
the digital analysts, reviewed over 5,000 photos and 50 hours
and several audio files of footage from the attacks provided
partly by various state s state agencies and through an independent
online review of various open sources to identify potential instances
and indications of conflict related sexual violence. Okay, so
that is they've gotten them from Israel or the internet. >> Not
just the internet, but yeah,
>> Israel or the internet. Well, it says through it uh
provides open sources to me just means like
yeah online review of various open sources. Is it the internet?
>> I'm okay. So, we'll say the internet. I'm not sure what
they specifically mean by open sources because it could be that
they're talking about like open sources that exist maybe exclusively
inside of >> Sure. So, I'm just saying that there would
be reasons if you distrusted Israel from a fundament like a foundational
place, there'd be reasons you'd argue I need more evidence than
just testimony or just um like photos or >> They have firsthand
accounts. They talk about firsthand accounts. >> They do
have firstand accounts. I'm just explaining to you why Hassan
I'm explaining to you why Hassan might have >> Wait, no.
No, but that's not from
>> Okay. All right. through the material provided by national
agencies. Though the material provided by national agencies appear
to be authentic and unmanipulated, it could always be it could
not always be independently verified by the mission team. Efforts
were made to verify the most important pieces of digital evidence
gathered by the mission team. For the purpose of this report,
only items found to be reliable and related to the October 7th
attacks were considered. Okay, so
they went through these and they apparently must have discarded
some evidence provided by the Israeli state when they couldn't
verify through other sources that it was like reliable. So, I'd
say that works in the favor of like, okay, it's unlikely that
this stuff was doctorred. They're basically saying that like,
hey, we had stuff that seemed like it might have been, could
have been, and we didn't include that in this report. I think
that's kind of an important point. No, for your side. >> No,
I mean, I'm telling you, I've read this. I I don't know why.
Like, I understand for your reasons you're you're like have gone
over it. I've read this. I know what it says. >> Okay.
All right. Fair enough. And my point is that he can't have read
this and come away with the opinion that he did while trusting
the UN reports because of things like the firsthand accounts.
He can't have read it. And if he didn't read it, then he's malicious
for having commented on it in the manner that he has while uh
in in speaking on this issue cuz this was a really important
piece of documentation that he was presented with dozens of times.
it it it seems when it comes to >> I would say from his
position I would understand why he could read this and potentially
like downplay specific parts of it, right? That's why in my opinion,
you just like listen to what he says. You listen to Ethan bring
up like the specific evidence and you could just cook him on
that, right? >> What would you what would you need to hear
from Assan to see that he's denying >> to say that he's
denying if he didn't know the evidence? Like if I heard him say
like, "Oh, well, no, I don't I don't trust that." Like, yeah,
those photos of those bodies with their like bottoms removed
and stuff, that's that's like not that's not evidence of anything.
I want to hear exactly what he's talking >> Acknowledge
that the evidence that is convincing exists for him to say >> or
for him to say that like this didn't happen. I think this is
totally >> How is that substantially different than him
casting aspersions on
credible >> because I think casting and denying are >> in
the manner that he is? I would say it
>> Okay. I this seems like just basic >> because
he's trusting the same sources, man. He literally use he I believe
he uses a UN report to to talk about uh uh Israel's
violence against Palestinians.
>> Okay. Um Oh, sure. I would wonder what the uh evidence
of that is, by the way. >> it's not. Show me evidence for
anything you're claiming that isn't some unhinged freak on Twitter.
>> Believe all women. Hey, this is >> Hey, are we
believing all women unless they're Israeli? Right after October
7th attack in Israel, Zaka, the d the disaster uh victim identification
volunteers were among the first civilians uh responding on the
scene. Zaka is an Israeli rescue and recovery organization primarily
staff. >> Okay. Apparently
people are saying with this report Hassan is denying like mass.
I don't think that's the case. I think he's saying I think he
specifically keys in on the word like um circumstantial evidence
and says oh well circumstantial means non non forensic evidence.
I think he shows he goes circumstantial evidence. Well, that's
non forensic
by ultraorththodox volunteers known for their work in collecting
human remains for proper burial. Uh according to law,
I think what happened is a lot of what happened is that
obviously you don't someone and then keep them alive, right?
So hope someone were murdered and a lot of the forensic evidence
article about how to debunk the council of fuel global dispute
over Israel. This from May 22nd, 2022. This is about the uh this
is about the the witness testimony that was discredited. Okay.
>> But so even even if one account was discredited, there's
many. >> It's not one account, it's two accounts, but the
rest of the >> There's way more than two accounts. >> Can
you
know what you're doing? You're like, "This girl lied about being
therefore all these women need to be questioned." That's actually
what you're doing. You're saying Pixar didn't have it. I don't
believe >> you point me to Can you point me to actual like
to to victims that came out because as far as I understand, Israeli
police have asked victims and witnesses to testify about and
violence in the aftermath of October 7. And it seems like their
investigations were inconclusive because by the admission of
the Israeli prosecution
>> Medi Hassan tweet. Hold on. Let me check out this Medi
Hassan tweet. We like Medi Hassan. What's the vibe check on Medi
Hassan? Really? We a fan of Medi Hassan. >> I think he's
kind of annoying, but yeah. >> Since Octo, >> not
going to be good. Debunked. Israel's top 10 lies on Gaza.
I don't trust this guy about Gaza. About a that is hard to remember
them all, let alone keep up. Here in less than 3 minutes are
Israel's top 10 lies about this genocide. Are you watching? the
clock
again
was that Hamas was stealing the aid going into Gaza but turns
out according to Israeli military released all the
gender based violence October the 7th now no one in Gaza from
Isra what he says about this I'm guessing it's going to be the
same thing um no evidence of mass or systematized or coordinated
no evidence of or sorry but there is evidence of violence happening
both in captivity and at the individual kabitzas and maybe he
might get into the lack of forensic evidence or maybe the Israeli
organization that handled the bodies off the bat. Maybe >> there
was systematic mass rap by on October the 7th. Now, no one's
saying there wasn't any gender based violence on October the
7th, but mass as a weapon of war. Well, the times of London,
a pro-Israel burden right-wing newspaper did a deep dive last
year. Quote, Israel says weaponized, but investigators say the
evidence does not stand up to scrutiny. The UN Commission of
Inquiry said last year they had not been able to independently
verify allegations of because of obstruction by the Israeli authorities.
And the main Israeli prosecutor on the case has said, "In the
end, we don't have any complaintants." Line number five, there
is a command and control center. >> So that's essentially
I would say his position and Hassan's position are one to one,
right?
>> Where because Hassan references one in captivity and
then refuses to recognize the happened inside of that UN report
which he >> it happened right
>> did happen. He just >> one he said one explicitly
one
>> uh in captivity. He might be getting in captivity wrong,
but he admits that happened on October 7th. >> That there
was violence on October 7th.
>> As far as I know, Hassan says that there's been did
happen on October 7th, like on that day. >> Uh I I don't
know if I've seen a clip of him actually saying that. Um but
either way, I'm talking about the one in captivity, which according
to the report, that's not the case. There's uh clear and convincing
evidence that uh there was at least two bare minimum two. >> But
he he also brings up the article in the debate, right, of um
the debunked ones from In Captivity. >> Those are not the
debunked ones. >> Okay. Well, but that came out after the
this report, right? >> This report comes out on March 2024
and I believe the other one comes out March 2024. We look at
the what? >> This was
>> Yeah, they're not talking about the same ones. This
is sorry, May 22nd, 2024.
And then so I would assume that if there's there's a Wait, you
know that the debunked ones are taken out? >> I know that
the debunked ones are not the ones being referenced in that UN
>> Okay. All right. Okay. >> So, you know what you're
doing? You're like, "This girl lied about being therefore all
these women need to be questioned." That's actually what you're
doing. You're saying, >> "Can you point me to actual like
to to victims that came out?" Because as far as I understand,
Israeli police have victims and witnesses testify about October
7th and it seems like their investigations were inconclusive
because >> so that's exactly what as far as I can tell
Medi Hassan said right that there are no prosecutions. Nobody
is coming out to like try to press charges in any way. It's just
like which again not not dispositive. Absolutely. I can see somebody
having that happen. They go well what smoking pile of rubble.
How are we going to find the guy? I'm not going to go complain
about this. Absolutely. Because by the admission of the Israeli
prosecution of anything said that there were no victims that
came >> Yeah. Let me guess. You read on >> Har.
You don't wait. Do you think that credible institution is at
this point? >> No, but you guys lean on that. You just
>> That's pretty bad point right there. Why is Jen chat
locked? Uh so people can come talk in the in the chat here.
So, so the the
in the UN report itself, it talks about how the lack of people,
there's two main components for the lack of people coming forward
with firsthand accounts. One is there's a big culture diff in
Israel where there's a lot of women who just straight up do not
want to say that they were raped by militants. And two, a lot
of them are >> Yeah. I think there's no reason to go after
most prosecutions. Right. >> Okay. So, >> I would
say this point is not
>> I was just pointing out that Medi Hassan and Hassan
probably have about the same standard for for making these claims
lying about >> I I I don't know. I don't I I I don't really
care about that other guy. Um with with that in mind and with
this idea in mind that this standard would not be ubiquitous,
right? that he has not had the standard for other instances.
This is where uh I get my opinion on on uh how he views the Okay.
Uh one second. Kingler is saying uh apparently we get what is
it here? Apparently we get Ethan says you deny them happening
on October 7th. Then Hassan says yes I do because there's no
evidence.
Uh that would be a thing to say. That would be denying the reality
of what you've seen here. But let's see. Okay. I have to I'm
going to try to pull up the transcript here. Give me a second.
There is no evidence.
>> Oh, this is going to be mass. >> You deny mass
happened. Not that
>> You deny that mass rape happened. Not that happened.
Listen to my word. >> Kingler just totally misstated this
again. Complete. You already watched this. God damn it. Sorry.
I'm going to watch time here. >> I'm going to watch a clip
on my own. >> Could you send me play on the stream? >> Could
you just send me? We could play it on the stream together. >> Yeah,
I I'll I'll just take a look at it. I want to just look at it
real quick. I don't want to do the whole thing. It'll take a
second. >> Okay,
keep watching. >> Yes, I do. I do deny good. Well, there
you go. >> There is no there is no evidence and for the
show the clips that you used, ironically enough, the reason context
is because at that point at that point >> I personally
took a position where I said
very carefully and very deliberately that >> I cut it.
What did I cut off?
Wait, what did I cut off? What? What did I cut off here? Yeah.
>> So, I don't know. Just to be clear, my position here
is 100%
uh Hassan's standard is insane. Probably comes from his distrust
of Israel. I would want to know like what evidence there was
for some of the things. Like I would say you probably have to
go through and read the whole report to get a good idea of like
what evidence came from what place. That are two to three plus,
right? I dude the whole argument over mass the whole argument
you get into with mass is like basically just to play like denial
games in my opinion that's been my opinion from the beginning
when you talk about like mass systematized you like use that
it's just easy to say there's just there was violence right there's
lots of violence it's sort of like the it's the exact same word
game people get into with genocide where they're like well what's
genocide then it's it's like just stupid it's like no just say
that like there's insane wanting destruction and violence on
Israel's part in the Gaza Strip you have to use the word genocide
cuz then you just get into a stupid argument over the label genocide.
What's up? You got a >> No. I I think I think the clip
is bad, but I don't think it's going to show what you want. So,
I I'll just move on. >> What was the clip? Could I just
know? >> There's a clip of him saying that some didn't
happen
didn't happen and then brings up a squirrel post trying to say.
>> Well, I think he absolutely believed that squirrel post
off the bat. That like totally disingenuously edited squirrel
post. >> Okay. So I guess so then maybe we can stop all
of this. What I consider to be denial is having a separate standard
for that is impossible to hit that is clearly uh uh in this instance
at least but in other instances motivated by something right
I consider this to be a form of denial motivated by something
where uh uh you deny the facts or the evidence as being
conclusive for the purposes of X and Y and Z gain. In this instance,
he is denying the happened by saying that the evidence is inconclusive
to the point of needing an amount of evidence that's impossible
to hit. He knows it's impossible to hit. And so he he denies
arrests that are uh happening off of that basis. I I believe
that is denial is setting an impossible standard when presented
with
um in this instance at least for explicitly uh political motivations.
So, for instance, if somebody comes up to me and says, "You somebody
and then I were to go," well, do you have like uh a video recording
of it happening and then they go like, "No, I mean that's like
a weird thing to do." And I just go, "Well, you know, I don't
know. I I don't know. Whatever." And then you just move on to
the next topic and you obiscate and say, "Well, then that's not
enough to do." I consider that. Do you? >> I'd probably
say I don't like I think I think we basically consider it the
same thing. What I would what I So, let's just call it. Okay.
Let's say it's denial. When he says, "Oh, I want this standard
instead." Okay, let's call it Rick denial. Where do you think
that comes from? Where do you think that idea of Rick denial
comes from?
>> Uh, I think I think it comes from him uh not wanting
to look bad for his support >> I disagree. I think there's
a there's a concerted effort from Hassan and people around him,
people on that side of the aisle. I think there's a concerted
effort to try to not play into the atrocity thing, right, where
Israel lied about a whole bunch of things that h happened on
October October 7th to manufacture consent to go and do their
ground operation in Gaza, right? I think they've like stayed
in that same like mindset basically this whole time. Do you think
that's a part of it, significant part of it, not a significant
part of it? >> I'm waiting I guess I what what off of that?
I would just say it's motivated from a place of like there's
a reason to distrust like negative news about the Palestinians
and there's a reason people can't like actually evaluate the
news very well here and I think there's a reason why Hassan would
expect a different standard in this case
but I I will totally like concede that I think that equates to
in this case. I don't have that same level of distrust of the
Israeli state. I don't have that same level of distrust of like
>> No, no, no, no, no, no. It's not trust in the Israeli
state. It's trust in independent action. So he already said in
here that he believes the Israeli state coached people on their
>> He's already said in here that he believes the Israeli
state coached people on their interviews.
>> Yeah. So that's the point of setting up an impossible
standard.
>> Yes. But where is that impossible >> I believe
it is denial when in order to >> I've already conceded
that it's denial. >> Then why the we here where it comes
>> And you said it comes from like a selfish place where
he doesn't want to look wrong. And I'm saying it comes from a
motivated reasoning beyond behind like, hey, whenever I get these
bad pieces of news, but the Palestinians, it seems to me, >> you
recognize that earlier you said there's no evidence for Assan
denying. >> I said there's no evidence. So I've already
said I think so I'm conceding here and saying that if you want
to call that rape denial, I'm fine with calling that rape denial.
I would call that like I call it casting aspersions. I would
call I would have called that casting aspersions before. For
the sake of this
what is rape denial to you?
uh saying no that didn't happen. >> Okay, so he has to
actively say no that didn't happen when >> instead of saying
it's inconclusive
>> instead of saying it's inconclusive. So, it's impossible
to deny rapes if you just go like, "Well, I don't know." Even
if there's like 9K
for like footage right in front of you in VR >> that there's
not 9K for he sees like a UN report that says I'm asking you
that question. I'm asking you that question. We can establish
that denial only occurs if you say, "Hey, no, none of it happened."
Not if you like
there's like a whole bunch of other ways you could say this.
He's casting doubt. He is needlessly casting doubt on these things,
right? You could just say, "Oh, I I need to see more evidence
or something." Right? Now, would there be more evidence and like
on the balance, should he think this? Should he think it happened?
I think so. But I understand with his worldview, how he sees
the Israeli government, how he sees what's been perpetrated on
the Palestinian people. I understand exactly how he sees this.
And I don't think that makes him like evil or a participant in
rape culture. I mean, he has a different standard for information
that works against the Palestinians and in favor of the Israeli
state. >> So, I think you can be And just because you're
doesn't mean you don't deny I'm when I am referring to him being
a denial denier. I think we've already totally I think we both
agreed that the Israeli state fabricated claims right after October
7th to manufacture consent for their trusting Israel. We're not
trusting Israel. That's >> in part trusting Israel. Israel
would have debriefed all of these people. Israel could have talked
to all of these people. Right. There is a there is a level of
trust for Israel. >> Why do you say could have? Do you
have any evidence that their conclusions were not their own?
>> Uh, do we have to go to the Herets article? What's the
Herets article >> What? Why am I Why are you bringing up
a Herets article >> that they're talking about? >> I'm
talking about the UN report. >> I understand you're talking
about the UN report. I haven't seen the Herets article, but I
do you understand how knowing about the Herets article
and saying I don't trust parts of this,
>> So, do you not you don't understand what I'm saying
at all? >> No. What are you saying? I'm saying that h never
mind. It's I'm never going to get this through. It doesn't matter.
It's fine. I It's fine. I've already said that I think he's t
what he's doing is tamount to rapile in this case. >> Okay.
So just put very simply for me what I consider to be recile is
when you're presented with clear and convincing evidence that
you have used before for to be able to convincingly say that
occurred which to be clear he has used evidence 1 1 millionth
as convincing as this to say that a
>> example where he's used way less convincing evidence
to say a happened >> uh during the during the Twitch
assault escapades or what is it that that came down where there's
dozens of he kept talking about like misconduct that occurred
like with the um the one guy, what is his name? Um the guy from
OTK, you people know what his name is. He used to date that star.
>> Oh. Uh he still dates her as far as I know. Rich.
>> Yeah. Rich Campbell. That guy. He talks about Rich Campbell.
There's 1 millionth the evidence for Rich Campbell as there is
for multiple different assault victims in from uh in Gaza. And
yet, >> wait, he has do you know that is not forensic evidence
versus where's the forensics evidence that happened during all
that was not >> uh Philly? No. No, not right now. Sorry.
>> There there's so there's tons of examples of uh but
even still we could go through a a various list of several different
moments where in which he >> talked about I don't know
if he believes the Saburn Chhatilla stuff. I don't know what
there is felp there. I agree that Saburn Chhatillaa is a better
example of this um for believing that standard, but I don't I
haven't seen Hassan speak on Saburn Chhatillaa. I understand
Saburn Chhatilla by the way. I wish other people who were pro-Israeli,
okay, I wish they'd care about the other from Saburn Chhatilla
like hey the maybe the guy who oversaw and orchestrated that
whole event becoming your prime minister might be a bit of a
concern, but the character of the country,
I don't know. Just throwing it out there. We're gonna throw we're
going to parade out these saburn chhatilla victims, but also
honor
based Ariel Chiron every every year. >> Also, literally,
I would argue that there's more evidence that more than one happened
on October 7th than there is Donald Trump being arrested. I would
literally argue that. >> Yeah, sure. >> And I think
I'd win that pretty
>> I agree with you. >> Okay. So we we have established
that there is he has a separate standard of evidence for that
are happening in one instance versus another. Right? And with
that being the case with that uh that that happening I would
say that that is is deny denial when you set up two separate
standards where you have one that is impossible to reach. We've
all agreed that it's impossible. >> You're just describing
like like a totally relative personal. You think most liberals
actually think Donald Trump physically like held somebody down
and penetrated them?
You think most people believe that? Or do you think people hate
Trump so they'll call him a on basically no evidence? >> You're
just describing the exact
totally so he doesn't believe them. >> I I I believe most
people believe that Donald Trump is a because he was held civily
liable for rape. >> Do you think they even know what it
means to be held civily liable for rape in this case? >> No.
But I don't think you have to know what it means to be held civily
liable to for to believe that somebody is a >> Sure, but
I'm saying we're talking about the standards of evidence. I'm
saying he has he hates Donald Trump, so he has no standard of
evidence. There's the same thing with Destiny, right? I don't
believe he's looked through any of the Destiny stuff. He'll still
call him Destiny every name that he can, right? He's got like
a totally subjective standard. I guess if you just want to show
that he has a double stick. But then like then I guess for Hassan
if you want to take his permissive standard and say that's normally
he does a lot of >> is is when you it is politically expedient
to you or personally expedient to you. You set up an impossible
standard for to be hit and then you attempt to obiscate and move
on. You attempt to uh uh minimize or cover up and that's >> I
think he has absolutely done those exact things here. >> Okay.
Okay. Do not deny any of the things you said there or not. I
guess I'm not I I don't really care. >> Do you need me
to call it rape denial? You can't just say I agree with you on
>> I think that's pretty obvious like rape denial. But
yeah. >> Okay.
But but as long as I'm not giving you the like moral satisfaction
of saying denial, which I already did, by the way, and tried
to move on. >> No, the whole point of >> I can just
agree with you on all of the individual points,
>> but I already agreed with you on all of the individual
points. >> The whole point The whole point of us being
here is because you refused to call that. I don't think Hassan
ever uh uh was presented with 9K evidence and then said, "No,
that that is not a that right in front of my eyes is not a rap."
He just says things like there's one instance of that happened
in captivity when he he knows that's not the case. He's read
the stuff that shows that it's not the case, but he has an impossible
standard that he set up to. That's that's the problem. And I
feel like I'm pulling teeth. Oh my god. Oh, [__]
>> Hey, I'm totally fine. I can totally disagree with you
on all of the points, though, that he is he's objectively setting
up a double standard. He's objectively like um obfiscating. He's
he set a standard that for this that he wouldn't set for other
atrocities, especially atrocities against the Palestinians. I
agree on all of those things, but I agreed on those things from
the very beginning. So, >> uh why this whole thing did
>> because you wanted me to call that denial. And I think
it's driven by other things,
right? I think it's driven by other things.
driven by many different things, right? >> I eventually
just said we can call it rape denial, but to me that would be
like no, this didn't happen, not know this is inconclusive.
>> I wouldn't say that that not wanting to admit it because
you have like an emotional investment in one side is not saying
rape denial. It's saying it's inconclusive now. It's not saying
it didn't happen. Saying we don't have enough evidence to say
it happened. >> You literally yourself raped somebody and
then said, "Uh, I don't know. There's inconclusive evidence."
Would that be No. >> Uh, yes. >> Why? Because I have
conclusive evidence. I literally have my first part my my personal
experience. Right.
>> So So it's not that you would believe that I raped.
I would believe that I raped. I don't know if Hassan believes
that this happened. That's what I'm telling you. That he might
have read this and still not believe that it happened because
of his distrust of the Israeli government. That's foundational
to my entire argument this whole time. >> Okay. And even
if I were to
>> I just want to point out again that I agreed with you
in all of the individual things he's doing. You just don't like
that. I won't call that. I just realized how late it is and I
have roommates. So, >> uh, we never, we actually went on
a totally different topic and didn't talk about the clip. >> I
mean, we talked about the clip for like an hour. >> We
didn't go through the whole clip. We still have not gone through
the whole >> Yeah, I understand we didn't go through the
whole clip, but I mean, we can probably just agree to disagree
on the
>> We don't have to agree to disagree. I I still believe
you are totally disingenuous if you actually believe that this
doesn't apply later on. that hey, targets in the West Bank and
targets in Gaza are the people who could be targeted here. It's
not other people. >> Um,
no, I don't. So, you could say you're No, I don't I don't believe
that. I don't believe you believe that. You don't think there's
any reasonable person that could >> No, even not. Okay.
So, that's first of all, that's weird. But even not a reasonable
person, an unreasonable person could look at that clip and then
take away that he is talking about uh Elen Klein being like morally
acceptable to attack. >> It's in a context and you're trying
to remove the context and you have to clip >> No, I'm asking
you even an unreasonable person do that just like a dumb >> Sure.
An unreasonable person could do anything
at this point. >> Yeah. like an unreasonable dumb person
like a person
>> like literally if I talk about if I talk about joking
about somebody themselves and then somebody killed themselves
right and I'm like doing a clear joke that everyone in my chat
understands as a joke or sorry that people in my chat like are
offended by or something right let's say they're offended by
it they don't agree with me on it and somebody does
I can't be held responsible for what audience is stupid they're
and they're primed to sh on these people and dehumanize them
and then he gave them prime bait to further dehumanized elix.
My bad. Um, he gave them prime bait to do that. And uh, yeah.
So, yeah. No, I don't think it's a stupid standard. When you
set up a stupid audience that is primed to take arguments and
dehumanize people, you need to realize you're speaking to that
audience. I'm not going to go in front of a bunch of rapers who
have, you know, room temperature IQ and speak the same way I
do to you. It's not going to happen. >> Okay. I just I
don't I seriously just do not understand from a personal perspective
um how you can take like the clear the clear progression he goes
through the statements he makes how he's building this up and
you just like throw that out you say like oh because of his audience
he actually
a bit detached to say that >> like a bit detached because
it it is very obvious how somebody could listen to that and then
come to the conclusion yeah you know what I actually think that
this is uh this It looks like he's pushing for violence to be
uh uh brought against or he thinks violence is okay. >> Are
you sure we don't have time to finish the clip? >> Yes,
I I'm very confident. I did not realize it's past midnight. >> I
don't know how this happened.
>> Uh do you mind if we chat again tomorrow? We just like
finish this clip. We just walk through the clip only. >> If
you're around, >> maybe probably I'll probably be I mean
I'll definitely be like streaming and stuff. So yeah, if you're
streaming I'll I'll probably have time. >> Perfect. Awesome.
Thank you for coming >> Super appreciate it. I >> Good
luck. >> Enjoyed the combo. >> Much love, buddy.
>> I literally have said a hundred times, STV, did you
not understand me when I said this? You literally can see me
in the channel. My main account is banned. Message me on the
account that you just saw me in the Discord on. Damn, that guy
hates you. Uh, I don't think so. I will debate you on this. Air
Force One. You lost. I don't care about the Hassan thing. I've
had that exact position on the Hassan thing forever. that like
the the double standard thing, right? The Sabburn Chhatilla argument.
I've watched all of that. It's like a totally adjacent argument
to the one I wanted to have. We ended up arguing about Ethan
Klein. I literally don't give a [__] about Ethan
Klein. I literally just want to have this argument about Hassan.
That's it. Some brainwash victims to come defend this. The clip.
I mean, I would I would talk about the clip. We ended up talking
with Rei the whole stream, unfortunately. Find out what her are
you talking about right now? Hold on. Again, nothing said there
by Han is incorrect
in my opinion. And I yeah I don't think he has any there's nothing
uh he doesn't have any responsibility to be like responsible
with Ela after the way Ela and Ethan are treating him like I
think it's I think it's flipped and I don't think he has any
requirement to be like he he can't lie but if he's got a moment
where it fits and it's funny it's totally fine.
Uh Really thank for the raid. Let's go. Welcome back guys. How
dare you mention the raid she willingly admitted to and looked
back on without regret. I don't know if she looked back on it
without regret. I think she said it was weird and she didn't
go again. If anybody wants to hop in and talk about the clip,
we could do that. Otherwise, I think we are nearly at the end
of the stream here, guys. Uh, you know what? Let's do what, 10
subs for another hour. I can do 10 subs for another hour. I'm
not really that tired. I'll give uh five minutes. And if we don't
hit it, I'm probably going to header,
you know, do five minutes. Let's go.
15 minutes for 10 subs or the equivalent, guys. We uh we apparently
got some retweets on the uh on the clip. I see the clips clip's
like popping off on Twitter now. Seems like some Hoscore people
found it or you just got two 200 viewers. Don't end now, bro.
Those people would have been coming here anyway. Oh yeah, that
clip popped the [__] off. Damn. Damn. Getting retweeted
by the whole Hassan Orbit. Let's go. Huh. This is just This is
just what I wanted. I'm going to be the first person to be a
Hassanabi head, a DJer, and a Groper all in the same year. I'm
running the triple crown and we're getting it done. All right,
let's go. Where's the Fentes clip? Let's get it going. Where's
Kaiser Rev,
guys? Guys, guys, anybody who's tuning in because they're a fan
of Hassanabi, I have to introduce you Oh, wait. Hold on. Don't
do that. Hold on. Introduce you to my favorite clip of all time.
Okay, hold on.
That's a epic song. Epic. last Friday
>> Hey, if you can hear me, please.
>> Hold on. Let's check it out real quick.
r/jstock low tier god gives his take on rogs. And >> I
know some people are going to watch this. some. >> Okay.
Low tier God reacts to Nick Fentes. Let's check it out. >> Hold
the you mean well behave. You see what that's the I'm talking
about, [__] We was We was well behaved. We was picking
that mother. We was on the fields. We was well behaved. We getting
We ain't behaving. We tired. >> All right. So, uh, social
media influencer Nick Fuentes demands brutal honesty with regards
>> Kaiser, you've uh you've missed some of the stuff. Okay.
to much of the
commonly accepted AA behavior.
>> He describes to his black audience the impression the
world has of them and why it's difficult for anybody to disagree
with this tape. All right, before we even start the video, you
guys know what type of black I am. I consider myself a new age
black. Uh new age black is somebody who doesn't fit the typical
stereotypical mold of an average rogue. So basically um I'm not
somebody who
>> Oh, LTG uses rag as a standin for the hard R. Oh, now
I feel less good about this title or the thumbnail. >> Necessities.
I'm not somebody >> or maybe it was the title in the subreddit.
Jesus.
Jesus, bro. >> Who, you know, smokes, drinks, does typical
rogue, so on and so forth. I never was that kid growing up. Even
though I was around it, I was always different, you know. Anyways,
I don't need to give you my whole life story. I'm just a new
age black. Uh, let's see what Let's see what Nick Fuentes is
talking about. Do I and will I agree? Something tells me I will.
Let's see what he's talking about. >> That's a shame. I
really do believe Look, I don't I think black people are not
irredeemable,
but there just needs to be brutal honesty. It's like, look, these
black people are really struggling and they're turning into these
maniacs. The It seems like they don't do anything right. They're
obnoxious. They're rude. They're inconsiderate,
and you know,
>> aggressive and cruel. I would say the majority I do
feel like the easiest
the easiest people to get into a fight with or a commotion with
are blacks.
Um, if I >> Bro, I I feel like um is this a bad is this
a bad reactor for Nick Fuentes? Like you think I'm going to say
it. I I'm actually not sure legitimately uncertain
who might be more racist to black people. I my inkling my inkling
is that LTG is the more racist person to black people. I'm sorry.
That's my inkling.
That's my immediate reaction. That's my inkling. And I I'm guessing
>> I mean, let's just say this. If I look at a black too
long, that could be my last day on Earth. Or >> Okay, never
mind. Never mind. It's not close. It's not close to LTG by a
mile. Holy [__]
What the [__] It could be a commotion. If I look
at any other ethnicity,
I'm staring at a white guy like
the All right, honey. I don't know. Walk away. If it's Hispanic,
be like, "You all right, fool? What you looking at, bro?" All right.
Anyways, go Asian. Look at you Indian hood. Look at him.
The you looking at you see some of it. You know somebody over
here, [__]
You know what I'm saying? Why do you think people Why do you
think people use blacks for skits all the time on YouTube? Easiest
people to agitate. Blacks. Easiest people to get on prank >> Okay.
Okay. Let's be honest.
40 to 60 year old white women right up there with like a 16 to
24 year old black dude. Okay. In terms of easy ease to agitate.
All right. Let's not pretend we don't have plenty of clips on
TikTok of these people getting extremely upset.
>> Yes. Nobody else is going to fall for >> Look,
nobody hates black people for being black. I if there are people
like that, I think that's exceedingly rare and I don't consider
myself one of them. >> I will say that. I'll always say
it's like this. A lot of people are so quick to use the word
racist instead of prejudice.
Always say that. There's a big difference.
>> The reason that people have negative attitudes about
black people is because most people's interactions with black
people are negative. Most people's interactions with black people
is when you're stuck in traffic and you see a Nissan Ultima speeding
down the
>> And that's true. That's true. How many You know how
many times I've been driving right now? I'm driving in a car
that is way faster than a than a Nissan Ultima. And for some
reason, it'll be a get
driving a Nissan Ultima with one of those sundried paint that
like the top will be sundried paint. You know how only Nissan's
do that? It have the sun dry paint and you you're trying to beat
me in traffic. Like do you see like my car is designed to dust
you and you're like they they literally be whipping Nissan Ultimas.
They'll literally whip Nissan Ultimas like Corvettes.
Literally like their V8s. >> Why Why do you guys keep updating
me on the lingo? This is wild. >> Just whipping through
traffic.
What the [__] You're not supposed to do that.
If everybody did that, it would just be another lane. And you
know, not everybody can do that. But it's like these people have
no respect for decorum. They think the rules don't apply to them.
They have no respect for society.
Like that's the their interaction is they are a waiter and they
wait on a black table and the black people don't tip and they'reing
rude,
>> dude. Did you guys see Oh my god. What's his name? Oh,
hold on. You guys see that WestJet video? That's like clearly
super racist and like like I think that WestJet guy on YouTube
is just blatantly playing the racist. You guys see that? Hold
on. Am I am I crazy?
Somebody showed this to me. Okay. Kaisen
Westjet. You guys see this? The title is the Kaisen fatigue is
real. The Kaisen fatigue is real. He makes multiple jokes about
how Kai can't swim and a bunch of other in this video. It's It's
kind of crazy. Anyway, sorry that was um and it's revealed it
was revealed to me in this video that apparently Kaiat never
tips his Uber Eats drivers or his Door Dash drivers. Z tips all
the times or all the time. So, sorry. Uh Nick made me think of
that. Unfortunately, it's
>> You know, it's funny. I really do think that it's just
like a black thing though, right? >> That's what the video
is about. Yeah. >> Um my mom is not
>> Never was never was that type. We was the only non-
ghetto blacks.
>> Is your claim that Nick scripts his show word for word?
No. Uh, it would be general talking points and then bits. I think
he does the bits that he's going to do in the stream. If he's
doing like a bit during the stream, I think he does script out
his bits a lot. I don't think as anywhere near as much of that
is off the cuff as people expect. I think his rants that happen
later in the stream for super chatters are probably off the cuff.
But then I wouldn't I wouldn't be shocked if he preatches some
of those too on the block basically outside of some Jehovah's
Witnesses across the street. But I do catch her getting an attitude
with people quickly. Like if we go somewhere,
she'll be like, "Uh, you don't have another place we could sit?"
"Um,
no, I don't want those. Let me get the other one." "Uh, nope.
I don't want that box. Give me the other one. So, I don't Yeah,
it's just it's just people's interactions.
I I don't know what it It's just people's interactions with blacks
is what give people the wrong depiction of us. And like I said,
one good black is going to suffer with the whole bunch.
One bad apple spoils the whole bunch. That's like a classic saying
or whatever. One bad apple spoils a whole bunch. Unfortunately,
you're going to get secondhand embarrassment. you're going to
automatically be deemed that as somebody who might do a smash
and grab or somebody who's going to steal in the department store
because that's what rags do. So, whatever ros do, us regular
blacks, us new age blacks, us blacks that are civilized or in
some of you guys might be rags that just positive rags that don't
steal. >> Dude, this guy is out of his mind. >> You're
going to suffer from the rabbit rugs. This is so This is so much
more racist than I thought it Dude, I thought this was going
to be a competition. Like a little bit of a competition. Okay,
a little bit of It's not a competition at all.
This >> most people's interaction >> for the rabbits,
you're going to suffer. A rogue means ratchet or ghetto. >> It's
stuff like that. They go to the DMV and they see a black person
behind the counter and they say, "Oh, here we go." And the person's
rude.
Now, it just goes to show people are not racist. It goes to show
people don't like people that are rude
that people don't it's unpleasant.
People want to be treated with consideration and respect. And
it is true that black people are in this day and age unfortunately
seem to have very low moral character. It's not even just the
violence. Although the vi I mean the violence is pretty striking.
If you live your life and you know that you're going to be mugged
by black people, it kind of colors your opinion or perception
of black people. Wouldn't you say? If 99% of the carjackings
and stabbings and that you see in Chicago are by black people
when you're walking down the street at night, guess what you're
looking for,
>> Black people. >> This is rough cuz like >> the
double racist react is [__]
>> Yeah. I Dude,
it's like what am I supposed to say? If you only get mugged by
a certain kind of person, you're not going to be scared of that
kind of person. I can't say no to this, but it's like is that
what the crime stats are in Chicago? Come on.
>> How do I push back? I don't want to be racist with these
two
>> less blacks. So, I made I made sure that I move so far
away from blacks that if I see another one, I know that I have
nothing to worry about because this is a high regarded area that
only somebody that's black that has their [__] together
can live here in the first place. Literally, >> it's actually
men. >> Cuz let's be real, man. I I don't want to live
next in a >> I'd say men's far more predictive of violence,
isn't it? Unfortunately, you need men for society. >> I
would never pimp. I would >> Oh god. No. No. No. No. No.
No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. We're not watching
that. Air Force. >> You know what to >> When you
live next, they love dumping their mattresses and old TVs and
like that right in front of the apartment
>> The apartment complex that I was living in to save money
before I got here to, you know, that I was paying like, you know,
cheap rent just to stay there. Being smart,
bro. All the blacks would dump their they would dump their old
furniture in front of the apartment complex all the time. Mattresses,
old strollers, everything. Just [__] up the environment.
Also, every single confrontation, physical confrontation I've
had in my life has been with blacks. Unfortunately, that's just
been my life ever since. All the way from second grade and up.
Guess who has a higher murder rate? Hedge 14 to 24 black women
or 14 to 24 white men. There's something in like the 14 to 24
there that feels weird to me.
Well, you're asking me, so it's going to be black women, but
I don't trust you. So, bullied by blacks, chased home by blacks,
been made fun of by blacks because I didn't have the best Jay's,
the latest Jays, so on and so forth, been clowned for having
one pair of shoes for the whole school year, being roasted by
blacks for liking wrestling. Roasted by blacks for liking Street
Fighter and video games. Roasted by blacks for not having the
latest fits. Roasted by blacks for not having a crispy fade lineup.
Roasted by blacks because I always spoke with some sort of poison,
you know, eloquence. For those that don't know what that means,
roasted by blacks for speaking proper to the point where so much
so I had to dumb down my dialect just to fit in with.
>> And you equate that with danger.
And it doesn't take a lot of them to spoil the whole bunch like
that. And um and we just want black people to take accountability
and say, "Look, I'm not I'm not a bad person.
I'm not a bad person. It just seems that every time I encounter
you people, for the most part, it's negative and sometimes extremely
negative. Like I could get a gun in my face. You know, that's
a problem." And people go, "Well, you are just loaded up with
hatred and racism." It's like, I'm really not. I'm a really friendly
person. I'm a really polite, friendly person. And I give everybody
a chance, but if I'm someplace and I see some black, this is
giving me Analysia vibes. Dude,
do you not remember the end of that that arc where like Analicia
was arguing and then LTG came in and was like, "Yeah, you don't
know how to do this. Move out of the way." Black people steal.
Black people will steal all the time. Look at what black people
steal during riots. It's not anything they need to make their
lives better. It's Gucci. Like, dude, it's like that's that's
how LTG came into that debate, dude. Dude, LTG came in was just
like, I am the most racist. Jesus Christ.
>> What the [__] Where did Kenny come from?
I When did you join? I didn't get a sound. How long have you
been here for? Oh, I just
>> Okay, cool. >> Person walking in with their pants
sagging and they they're can't articulate what their problem
is or what they need and they're rude and they're aggressive
and I I'm in fear for my life. Like, yeah, that I have a problem
with all of that. >> Yeah. Just like I'm saying, what he's
saying is it's the negative stereotypes and the negative stereotypes
is going to follow you whether you're that type of black. >> Your
take is perfect. I just can't listen to the Zach since he isn't
black and doesn't know what black people
>> I get it, >> man. Trying to think. And people
go and these black people go, "Well, you're racist. You're racist."
It's like, no, I just hate inconsiderate behavior.
If black people were super well behaved, we would be racist in
the other direction. We'd say black people. Oh, >> no.
No, no, no. Don't donate now. Don't donate now. We're going to
finish this and I'm going to head to bed, guys. We started late.
Okay. >> Yes, dude. >> Started very late on the stream.
>> I don't know. Some people are going to watch this. Some
blacks watch. Oh, what the mean? Well, beh. >> Holy [__]
Do we even finish all of the stuff?
Hold on. Do I have to do more [__] on my docket here?
Oh, we didn't even go through all the hutch stuff
>> That's the I'm talking about, [__] We was
We was well behaved. We was picking that mother. We was on the
fields. We was well behaved. We getting We ain't behaving. We
tired. Definitely. We'll find a way to baker about it. We tired.
>> as soon as there's a riot, we'll steal the Jays. You
know, we'll bust up stores. We'll jack iPhones. >> Oh my
god. I just said what his opinion was. And there's the there's
the opinion coming from LTG. Just said it exactly. >> Disconnected
as soon as you store. We're going to jack Chargers. You know,
>> you know, typical.
My day is about to turn around for the better. What can I help
you with, sir? Please come right on in. Man, what a relief to
see you here. What? You're a sight for sore eyes. If black people
are known for being the best, then we would be we would be racist
in the other direction. Oh, finally.
So, yeah, that that really bothers me. It just bothers me in
this damn city cuz that's all it is in Chicago is just these
black people who can never take accountability. >> Well,
I mean, he's it's whether he likes it or not, it's just never
going to change. Yeah, I mean, it's never going to change. But
what he should I mean, the thing that sucks when you said he
better stay in the house after this 24/7. What sucks is that
why is this a bad thing for somebody of a different ethnicity
that has the experiences of dealing with rags to tell the truth?
Why is that a bad thing? This I don't I didn't find racism with
this at all. I found him judging the the negative stereotypes
of blacks. Not judging black people as a whole, but judging the
negative stereotypes that loom. >> Okay, now you got to
sweep for Nick, too. God damn it. >> Around blacks, you
know, that's basically what it is. It's just judging the negative
stereotypes. You said he hates every race that's not white. Listen,
he might be a purist of some sort. And a purist could be a purist
could come in the form of a black, a Caucasian, an Indian, an
Asian, so on and so forth. You might just be a purist to the
point where you only want to procreate with your ethnicity. I
don't really think that makes you racist at all. It's just okay.
I only want to procreate with such and such. But um that was
just a little quick take. I want to get deep, you know, I don't
want to deep dive or hear about other things that he said. But
uh like I say, blacks, you know, I would love for us to just
blend in. Just that simple. I would love for us to blend in.
I would love for us to uh not beef with each other over dumb,
not each other, not steal from each other, so on and so forth,
and just be civilized. love for us to have flourish in communities,
flourishing businesses, everything. But it's just like it it's
just never going to happen. You know what I mean? It's like literally
it's literally impossible. As that sounds, it's literally impossible.
Uh do I agree with what he's saying? Yeah. But I mean, I haven't
dug be or anything like that. It's the first clip I've ever watched
of his and
>> bro. Um >> which is basically that. >> Okay.
All right. Very, very exciting stuff, guys. Um I think that debate
I think quite a few people were watching that debate. I think
quite a few people will disagree with me on the um the clip.
So hopefully we can form some debates for tomorrow out of people
who want to come and talk about that would be ideal. Um h
how many donos to continue? Uh continue with what? I have like
other content but I um bro I'm like hungry and I'm like tired
and we started stream late and I went seven hours. So realistically
I just kind of don't want to keep streaming. I'm like good. I'll
be back tomorrow. Okay. I can be back tomorrow and then I think
Tuesday night I'm off and then we're back on Wednesday. Okay.
So, what is it? Jesus. I'm not getting it. Today's Monday, right?
Yeah. Today will be Monday when I get up. Okay. I will be back
tomorrow. All right. We can have a massive stream until the sleep
takes you. No, I have to clean and stuff. Okay. I have to clean
and stuff. I've got family coming down on Tuesday morning. So,
all right. Anyway. Anyway guys, thank you for being here tonight.
Let's see who we can host. Who we got? Who we got? Who's online?
We got Darius. We got Nick. We've got
Resi. Resi was watching that debate, right? Got Resi. We've got
Nick. We've got Train Rex. We got Ice B.
Yeah, I'm going to rate Ice Boseidon. Have a good night, guys.
Do not say anything mean. Oh, wait. Hold on. Hold on. No, no,
no, no, no. Hold on. Is low tier god online? I'm not going to
rate Ice Beside. That will that could get me in trouble. Okay,
LTG is streaming. We just watched an LTG clip. Go over to LTG.
Okay, love you guys. Have a good night. We'll see y'all later.
All right. Have a good night. Love you guys.